Вітаю!
Привіт, привіт!
Доброго ранечку!
Вітаю!
Привіт, привіт!
Доброго ранечку!
Вітаю!
Привіт!
Доброго ранечку!
Вітаю!
Доброго ранку всім. Доброго ранку.
Геллоу, випускники.
Хеллоу, хеллоу, ебріван.
Я рада з вами.
О, Лєра, боже, яка краса з вами.
Це за мини-принцеса, мини-мини.
Доброго ранку.
Привіт.
Яка красива у нас.
Ще плюс один.
50 ранку зараз. Треба доплачувати. Ай, Василю. Меркантильний, не спорю. Та що таке, меркантильна ви особа. Можна просто продітися, заздрощива будь, заздрощива. Така красива ж принцеса неймовірна.
Добре, усіх вітаю. Давайте почнемо, як завжди, з нашої вправи.
Що мені сьогодні заважає навчатися, що мені сьогодні допоможе навчатися.
На все про все у парах 10 хвилин. Вигружаємо контейнери.
Що вже? Остання зустріч? Така остання зустріч. Ну, нічого. Добре.
Давайте почнемо на 10 хвилин.
Дякую.
Так, я відкриваю зали, тільки щось я не можу на 10 часу виставити, тому я їх вручну закрию, коли буде потрібно.
Добре.
Дякую за перегляд!
то сьогодні зі мною Аліна чи Юля Юля а Юль привіт да я сьогодні з вами добре дня вітаю з народженням
дякую дякую вам я ось минулого модулю з вами не була це я зрозуміла що ви були у пологовому
Да, да. Татьяна, доброго дня! Я вас здаюся з сьогодній залу.
Юлия. Юлия Екатерина, я вас здаюся з сьогодній залу.
Мої вітання, бо тоді Аліна приходила, казала, розповіла мені всю історію, що вологи мають бути.
18 квітня я народила, у мене було кесарево, взагалі так все швидко відбулося.
Мене поклали в родом за декілька днів, у мене тиск піднявся дуже сильно останній тиждень,
а 13-го я взагалі мала народжувати, і ось лікарь каже, що нам чекати?
Оляна, доброго дня.
Добрий ранок. Додаю вас в сесійний зал.
Так, ось, і все. А я думала, я ще проведу модулі, там от з понеділка якраз народжу.
О, ні, і отак от в суботу я не будила.
Все відбулося, да?
Ну, мене так і попереджала Аліна, да, вона казала, що так воно має бути.
І я вже сьогодні, а у вас голоса трошки схожі, не дуже, але схожі, да?
І я вже така в рєбусі, думаю, боже, хто сімною сьогодні?
Ні, сьогодні вже я останній модуль, я завершую.
Соня рівно місяць, до речі, як виходить, я народила.
Так, круто, це дуже круто.
І як перший місяць після народження?
Ой, набагато чого нового, так, взагалі, ну, дуже відчувається, що гормони так перебудовуються,
що, знаєте, от, ти там по-іншому на все реагуєш, ну, я така стала, знаєте, така впечатлительна, переживательна,
От так, хоча я сама по собі не така, так якось перші два тижні перші було так важко, тому що незвично, все в новинку, а зараз вже звикаєш до ролі і все супер, все класно, особливо коли є допомога, то
взагалі просто моя мама допомагає, зараз Світлана, я вас також додаю в зали.
Світлана, я вас додала в сесійний зал.
Та-та, добре, але я можу бути тільки слухачем, бо я за кермо.
А я вас слухачем, слухачем додала третью.
Дякую, дякую вам, ага, дякую.
Ми быстренько раз-раз-раз обкидались мамкиним чатом з Катією, що нам буде заважати.
Ну, діти, цвіти жизни.
Привіт, Светочка, привіт.
Кита, несешся, глянь, несеться, несеться.
Я бляха, я їду сьогодні в Стамбул, лечу на виставку, я розвожу собак до мами, собак везу, поняла?
Я сьогодні буду на колесах цілий день, бо мені треба туди-сюди щось завезти, розвезти.
Але дуже хочеться побути, знаєш, останні ці хоч послухати, ну, десь підслухати щось.
Будь акуратна.
Будь акуратна, я не можу.
Тож, Влада вміє розказувати так, що заслухаєшся, відлічешся.
Ні-ні-ні-ні-ні.
А які собаки?
О, вон, Влада, зараз вам покажу хвилинку.
Ано.
Тифуня, тав, на.
такі гарненькі а ще така маленька не знаю чи ви бачите отут не спряталась где-то
чихла хуа в нас дві собаки в нас одна лабрадор одна чихла хуа іще я везу невістки собаку ми всіх
везем до бабусі на канікули.
Як круто.
Це не вітки повезло.
Це круто.
Так, вони в нас такі чемні сидять.
Вони вже знають, що їх везуть на волю.
Що вони будуть гуляти,
скільки захочеш. І вони дуже
щасливі просто надзвичайно.
Якби мене везли до бабусі,
я б також була щаслива.
Чому ні?
Ой, Влад, я не знаю. Мене коли везли, я не була щаслива.
У мене... Тепер я розумію,
чому так було, але...
У мене ось ця травма покинутості, я супроводжувала мене дуже до глибокого зрілого ліку, і я завжди сумувала, мені здавалося, що мене відвозять і мене можуть не забрати, і я завжди плакала десь в ку
точку, ну таке.
Ой, ну добре, що поверталися, що все ж таки повернулися.
Повернулися, 100%.
Таке в них було життя тоді світ, вони самі не знали, як з дітьми бути, це ми вже зараз такі навчені, все розуміємо, все знаємо, як робити, більш-менш.
Ні, я от під час навчання, знаєте, я зрозуміла, що насправді покинуті дорослі також виховують покинутих дітей.
І однією з єдиних мотивацій, основних, чому я пішла вчитися – це, щоб розірвати цей, знаєте, якусь таку цепочку-рундогу і щоб моїм дітям було інакше, щоб вони це не відчували.
Хоча в мене дорослі діти, в мене вчера танці 32 роки було, і син в мене військовий, йому 30 років, але вони теж, ну, типу, дорослий, який виріс з травмою покинутості, він не може виховати дітей, які
відчувають ось цю, ну, підтримку, і що ти є безумовно, і що ти теж нікуди не дінешся.
Це все якось зараз по-іншому видно і захотілося просто показати, що насправді воно може бути інакше.
Ну, не так. Ось.
Бо у мене є внучка і 5 років, і це теж, ну, типу, якісь покоління далі.
І насправді цим дітям вже треба показувати.
Є можливість показувати інакше.
Просто треба собі знайти силу, аби це віднайти, відновити і відпустити.
Так, так. Але є гарна новина. Хочете дізнатися?
Так, хочу. Яка?
З кожним новим поколінням ця травма стає меншою.
О, це чудово. Це реально дуже чудово.
чудово. Ну, появляться новий, Влад. Моим детям всегда буде, що розказати своєму психологу.
«Какая п'є не було, мама? Я там на п'єдестал не лезу, мать-года, але все ж...»
Там могла б. Там могла б, да? Ну, могла б, ну, зачем? Ну, я считаю, що для своїх дітей так лучшая мама.
Ну, я їм все время говорю, що вони мене вибрали, не я. Я снимаю эту ответственность себе.
Ну чесно вам дівчат скажу чесно що найважче було з цих трьох дітей це моєму сину тому що
його виховувала сильно волюва мама в нього не було тата не було моделі як треба не було діда
і він десь ще в 10-12 років взяв на себе обов'язок що він мусить бути цим
Зрослим чоловіком.
Так, Оксано.
Ой, Світлано, Світлано.
Так, повертаємося.
О, у нас тут ще більше, плюс один.
Ну, добре.
Добре, усіх рада бачити.
Давайте сьогодні почнемо.
У нас останній семінар.
Чи є якісь питання по минулому навчанню?
Все зрозуміло, чи що? Так добре розповідаю, чи немає зацікавленості, що там у вас?
Саме собою, що добре розповідаєте, нам цікаво, але цей місяць, якийсь у всіх був такий шалений,
що напевне не вийшло передивитися, щоб зрозуміти, чи є питання, чи нема.
Добре, всі живі, всі здорові, тому добре владналися і впоралися з цим місяцем.
Добре, давайте тоді почнемо.
У нас сьогодні дуже-дуже цікавий семінар, неймовірно.
Ми будемо говорити з вами про адаптацію.
Тут написано адаптація та процесуальна модель.
Але давайте так спрощимо трошки, скажемо, що це адаптація.
Тобто, як ми адаптуємось до цього життя.
Дитина приймає рішення про те, ким бути і як поводитись, виходячи з того, що необхідно для виживання в її семейному середовищі.
От така класна фраза Еріка Берна, що кожен з нас приймав свої рішення.
Що думаєте про цю фразу? Як вона вам?
Трошки влада так собі, оце ж ви сприйняла оце в діттві, так?
Так.
На зв'язку з поведінкою навколишніх людей, які на мене мали вплив.
Тепер мені майже 45 і оце живу по тим штукам.
Але завдяки, зокрема, вашому влада-предмету, я колосальний прорив зробила в особистій терапії.
просто колосальний прорив і стільки прийняття власних якихось моментів які мені не подобалися
там в мені чи що і хочу поділитися був два на дві напевно лекції назад коли була сценарна
матриця мені так було погано після того я на наступний ранок проснулася я так себе обнімала
оце да от себе там дообнімати до того всього і знаєте що я зрозуміла я собі сказала Боже Сніжана
Ти така зараз велика, ти така доросла, от це ти коли була така манюнічка, така манюнічка, пухлі ручки, пухлі ножки, ти все це зробила.
Все це зробила, ти вижила, ти змогла, ти прийняла свої рішення.
Давай, вставай, прийми нові рішення, як ти хочеш тепер з тим бути, як і що.
І це так було класно, і це було якесь нове переродження, прям таке якесь зовсім інакше,
і таке велике відчуття відповідальності за своє життя.
Те, що треба в 45, в екзистенційному такому моменті.
Тому ваш предмет, це для мене просто мастхев і для життя, і для роботи.
Буду вчитись далі, потім вам напишу, якщо можна.
Пишіть, як же, я завжди вам усім рада, приєднуйтесь, пишіть.
Дійсно, транзактний аналіз, вам знаєте, зараз починається,
Він такий дуже, на мій погляд, просто сказати привіт і подивитися, що він може робити.
У мене вчора студенти, до речі, складали залік за три роки навчання.
То вони вже такі сиділи, думали, такі вже крути, йдуть на четвертий рік.
Вони вже навчаються, будуть вивчати розлади особистості, про їжу, про цих межових людей,
про нарцисів, то вони вже там очікують.
Вчора я була дуже строга вчителька, вони не очікували це все,
але все, все, всі впоралися, 30 людей пройшли благополучно,
три людини не пройшли.
Так, так, щоб знали, що буває по-різному, все добре.
Я бачила, у вас також має бути екзамен, то я дуже за вас радію.
Будете дивитися, що ви вивчили.
Круто, Снежан, це гарна новина, гарна новина, живіть дуже довго і щасливо усі, будь ласка.
Настя, я ж бачу, що рука була. Чи це так була замануха?
Це ж тут закладається, звісно, він погружає в грусть, іноді і печаль.
А в принципі, з іншої сторони, для того, щоб я сьогодні тут була і вчилася, я зробила в дитині все, щоб вижити, прожити і вирости.
Чудесна нова. Це чудесна нова. Дуже гарна нова. Знаєте, що ми всі живі, здорові, змогли впоратися з усім, що в нас було у дитинстві.
Сьогодні будемо дивитися, як це все на нас повпливало, як воно взагалі вплинуло, що є, чого немає, як нам працювати з людьми, які до нас приходять, не тільки про себе, але й про інших сьогодні
поговоримо.
Дивіться, план нашої роботи, модель особистості, тобто, які ми є, поговоримо, як ця модель розвивалася.
Я покажу вам цікаву оціночну матрицю.
І от на мій погляд, оце найголовніше в нашому семінарі – це двері контакту.
І знаєте, мені б хотілося вам дати трошки такого дуже глибокого матеріалу, показати, які є розлади в людей, які є адаптації і як це поєднується з розладами.
Покажу вам розвиток цих адаптацій, покажу, як ми створюємо з клієнтами первинний контакт.
Ось, бо буває у вас так, що люди приходять до вас, починають з вами розмовляти,
починають з вами говорити, а у вас такий дисконнекшн.
Ви йому одне, а він вам інший.
Ви йому щось таке, ну це ж і в житті, і так буває, а вам щось інше.
Оце означає, що ви не в ті двері взагалі пішли.
Цікавий для вас такий план, чи ні?
Якщо будуть питання, будь ласка, задавайте мені питання і, як завжди, ми почнемо з контракту.
Що ми будемо з вами робити? Зараз ви, будь ласка, згадайте, як ви себе поводите у нових групах або коли навчаєтесь.
Згадуйте. Коли вам щось цікаво або коли вам щось складно?
Вам бути разом з людьми, от уявіть собі, велика група, і ви такі зайшли і думаєте, вау, це моє середовище, я наче як та риба, так багато людей.
Чи ви любите залишитися на самоті?
Подумайте, чи ви берете на себе відповідальність у спілкування,
чи відступаєте осторонь десь там, чекаєте, дивитесь, доки до вас хтось прийде.
Подумайте, чого ви хочете навчитися на цьому семінарі,
якщо ви розумієте, як ви себе поводите.
Подумайте, чим ви можете собі заважати, як ви будете допомагати.
І моє улюблене питання, як ви себе порадуєте.
Добре?
Ось так.
Давайте в тріючках на 10 хвилин.
Влада, у нас немає ще методички.
Можна ще раз попередній слайд, щоб можу собі не скрінити?
Бо нам чомусь не скинули ще.
Добре.
А чого ж?
Не можна.
Оцей слайд, Сніжан?
Так.
Та, там, де оце от, ми ж зараз підемо в практику працювати.
Ага, ну, добре.
Дякую.
Все, погнали. На 10 хвилин.
Заходьте.
Так, ще Анна.
А подскажіть, що треба доделати?
Контраклю.
Приведу.
Да, тільки після тренування.
Чуть.
Утро все буде у мене по расписанню.
Подключати?
Перекинуть куди-нібудь ще,
тому що там Катя,
она бежит, ребенка, быстро собирати,
а я с ней одна в зале, більше нікого.
Давай со мною.
Или тут будемо оставатися, що нам не заважається.
Така я щось...
Тебі може щодня мешати.
Анна, розкажи нам.
Що тебе щодня може мешати, а що помогати, а що...
Я надіюся, що вже нічого мені мешати не буде,
тому що я вже потренировалась, я вже полна енергії заряда.
Я бігаю дому і буду з полноцінною робити.
Другой вопрос. У нас, як я себя веду в групі, а не що мешається?
Я нехорошо себя веду. Іногда не поднимаю руку і встреваю просто так.
Настя, ти себя як ведеш?
Смотри, які обстоятельства, які люди.
Якщо треба провести вау-фект, то можу з ноги сразу в обществу врываться.
І якщо потрібно присмотреться, чі халопи будуть, то можу адаптивно понаблюдати минут 15-20.
Чесно кажучи, я дуже сильно поменялась, дуже.
Я год назад і я зараз, це два різних.
Ну, у тебе буде там горевання.
Зараз, якщо я тест проходила б год назад, і зараз, це зовсім два різних відповідь.
Тому, зараз я менше кажу. Раньше я був, ах, Орликино, Орликино...
Сейчас у мене такого немає. Ну, тим не мене.
Зараз я дуже багато прохожу часом з собою наедене.
Мне хорошо і з людьми, мене хорошо і без них.
удовольствие получаю там и там но честно большие уже шумные кампании вообще не моя
история я вот назад у меня было больше энтузиазма интереса к этой профессии
Я прямо була бодра, а зараз я вгорю.
Мені вже неінтересно, я хочу, що другое.
Я кажу, що мені неінтересно, а насправді мені інтересно.
Можливо, з теорією зв'язано?
Я реально поняла, що я люблю розтанкувати,
я люблю передавати, я люблю передавати інформацію,
я люблю делитися їй максимально.
Делегіровання – це, взагалі, мій конєк, і, ну, як я це в бізнесі вже зрозуміла, і столкнувшись з людьми, і вже працював в практиці, практикував бізнесменів, я розумію, що дуже багато затык в тому, що
вони не можуть делегіровати, вони не можуть відпустий контроль, і не то, щоб контроль, вони не можуть так настроити свою роботу, щоб контролювати точечно, т.е. не весь процес, а тільки точки контроля
.
і це бача проблема для ноги, вони тягуться на себе.
У мене з цим все ок, я можу об цьому розказувати і ділитися цим залишним опитом.
І взагалі я знала, що в компаніях я люблю від гвіздой, в плані передавати інформацію, розказувати їм, просвіщати, я б так не знала.
Нежели просто слушати. Чоловіше слушання активно, це взагалі слабої сторони.
ой мене тако мене стало нравиться бути наблюдателем активним слушателем така
интересна может быть это связано с тем что все таки а так зберегаю да уже на русском
даже забыла я зберегаю до сохраняю свои свой вот значно свое внутреннее состояние все таки
я щас не могу у меня нет много столько энергии да еще возвращается потихоньку возвращать год
понадобилось нам для восстановления и потихоньку возвращаюсь все ровно год назад мне сделали
последнюю эту операцию так чего я хочу навчитесь одна тема семинарий усвидомлечи свои стратегии
поведінки і обрати і обрати і передати
да більше відкрити більше понять більше прочувствувати більше углубиться
чтобы більше більше качественно передати прикольно
Як ти можеш себе заважати сьогодні? Расскажи мене.
Я можу не высидеть, наприклад, чисто физически, таке количество времени. Я розумію, що мені тяжело в цей день.
хоча я ще тренировалась може бути проще, у меня ще силовая була, а можна бути я усидчивася в себе, в себе воспитаю, но вечером обязательно пойду гулять, а как будешь помогать, помогать, ну, если чай
помогает, сидеть попивать чай и слушать, то, наверное, будете чай и слушать.
На самом деле, мене що помогає? Гиперфокус. Гиперфокус появляється у мене тільки тоді, коли мені інтересно.
Якщо мені інтересно, я готова слушатися. Якщо мені скучно, ну, сори. Я не вважаю в цьому вигоди для себе. Вважаю за цим трату времени, тому я делаю приоритет в сторону того, що мені інтересно.
Ну і чим себе порадуєш, кроме вечерній прогулки?
Я всю життя радую.
Скажи, мені теж це таке... Я с утра уже себе просто... Я на опереження йду, я ван сам балуюсью.
Для того, щоб себе радувати... Такой вопрос, мені кажучи, це для людей, які себе постійно накажують.
Я себе не накажують, тому у мене все время я радуюсь.
Ну хорошо, а пощерять? Ну вот ты сегодня... Кто молодец? Я молодец.
Я всегда молодец.
Скажи!
Знаєш, що кажучи своя мотивація. У мене мотивація «от» — взагалі не працює.
Тобто я зроблюся ради чого-то. Ні. Мені інтересно, і я йду туди.
Це як, знаєш, дитська непосредственность, дитське любопіттво, любознательність.
Вона завжди у тебе була?
Да, з дитину.
Якщо мені будуть наказувати,
що поєш бірш і підеш.
Принципіально не буду бірш їсть.
Тобто це не грається.
Якщо, якщо.
Тому я завжди...
Для мене кожна цей, кожна достигаторство
— це як приз.
Уже сам по себе, а не то, що я чого-то достигну,
то достигнула, а потом получу еще какой-то приз. Не, не работает. А ты, я скажу про себя. Я иногда,
когда начинаю отключаться, я начинаю включаться активно, как не только слушатель. Короче,
когда я начинаю уплывать, как слушатель, я начинаю включаться и что-то отвечать, врываясь,
так сказати, щоб пробудити в себе.
Настя, це енергія, яка сидить, копиться, і вона, як існує пуль.
Та, так, я, так, пользуюсь злочим, вриваюся в ефір, це значить все, я починаю отползати
не фокусуватися ну і побалувати мені та ж самая історія сь утра себя набаловала іще люди все
балують що мене може ще відвідувати мене може мене чимодан максим дергать мене забирать
переживають що-то забудеть, ще, ну короче, збору кучу гуру. Главна, труси і зарядка.
Його-то на літо надо собрать, відправити. Аа, ти на літо відправляєш?
Ааа, я думала ти на недію? Ні, я його відправляю. Я 9 місяців отробляю.
У мене наоборот, у мене малий приїжджає в іюні, зараз з папою, я їду забираю його, з дам універі, пойду за малим, заберу його.
О, все, повернулися всі. Всі в нашу кімнату ворвались.
Добро пожаловати. Все, я на лифт. Поки ви будете тут спілкуватися, я піднімуся.
Добре, чи є якісь можливі інсекти, озаріння, чи все зрозуміло відносно того,
говорили, як ви зустрічаєтесь, як ви спілкуєтеся? Добре.
Якщо будуть питання, задавайте, будь ласка, навіщо нам вивчати адаптацію?
Для того, щоб ліпше встановлювати контакт з іншими людьми і розуміти себе.
Бо іноді люди, одна людина хоче десь там закритися, посидіти окремо і не спілкуватися з іншими людьми.
Йому говори, що ти такий, якась нелюдяна ти особа, давай йди до нас, давай спілкуйся.
Тобто розуміти свої особливості, які в нас є.
І знаєте, мої студенти, вони говорять, вау, такий крутий семінар, так прикольно, життя стає ліпшим.
От, наприклад, одна жіночка говорила до того, що я не знала про ці адаптації.
Я думала, що чоловік мене не дуже любить.
А от коли вивчила цей семінар, зрозуміло, так любить сильно, так любить.
І все наше сімейне життя дуже сильно змінилося.
Бо я до цього ганялася за нею.
Я кажу, проводзі мною час, проводзі мною час, проводзі мною час.
А він дуже був сердитий після цього.
А після того, як зрозуміла, який він, що з ним відбувається,
я зрозуміла, ну, от така людина.
Тепер я час проводжу трошки по-іншому.
Тому, я думаю, що потрібно їх вивчити.
Легко будувати контакт вам з іншими людьми,
більше мати вибору, що робити.
Ну і взагалі, знаєте, більш спокійно ставитися до життя.
Почнемо з моделі особистості.
Що таке, що це взагалі за оця модель особистості?
Дивіться, ви, я, кожен з нас має свої власні потреби і має свої стилі комунікації з іншими людьми.
Дивіться, комусь потрібно поговорити, прийти і почати розмову, говорити. Людина більше говорить і прикольно з тими людьми, які поруч з нею. Інша людина говорить, наприклад, слухай, мені з тобою не
комільфон, мені з тобою не прикольно, що ти оцей час весь бла-бла-бла-бла-бла, не говори мені.
Іди, дій. Навіщо витрачати час? Навіщо витрачати час? Приходь, зроби мені чашечку чаю, кави приноси. Оце мені підходить. Знаєте, оця книжечка, яка вона дуже така там. П'ять мов любові. Слухайте, там
не п'ять мов любові, там просто різні адаптації. Тобто, як адаптація, як ми навчилися вжити і виживати в цьому житті.
Ось, комусь поговорити, комусь щось зробити, і це нормально, і це класно.
Тобто, вчені, вони аналізували оці відмінності, що люди роблять.
Хтось думає, хтось говорить, хтось діє, і вони це все описали в такому модель.
І сказали, ця модель від того, що ти маєш робити, буде називатися моделью особистих адаптацій.
І ця модель особистих адаптацій, перш за все, допомагає зрозуміти ліпше себе.
Ні когось іншого, а саме себе.
О, що таке взагалі визначення, що є особистістю, особистісна адаптація.
Дивіться, це стиль почуттів, тобто що я відчуваю.
Бо інша людина може зайти і сказати, о боже, в мене такі почуття, в мене такі почуття, зараз я вам все розповім, як я себе відчуваю.
Або стиль мислення, або стиль поведінки, який формується внаслідок вродженої схильності, а головне – вашого сімейного досвіду.
Тобто, як ви відчуваєте, що ви думаєте і як ви з себе поводитесь.
Оце все і називається вашою особистосною адаптацією. Зрозуміло?
Як ви відчуваєте, що ви будете думати і як ви це все зробите або не зробите?
Визначення зрозуміло? Алін, слухаю.
Добрий день. Ще раз. У мене дивіться питання.
Значить, як мені зрозуміти, умовно, називається мову любові, ту адаптацію.
Якщо мені не вистачало самого тілесного контакту, емоційної близькості,
мова любові моєї мами була через подарунки, гроші і покупки,
то як мені зрозуміти, яка моя зараз адаптація?
От зараз красиво про це, Аліна, розповім. Я не буду так...
Я забігла, да?
Так. Я зараз дуже красиво буду про це розповідати. Буде цікаво.
Тобто це не така оця популярна книжка, там де ми будемо визначати, хто я кого дуже сильно любив.
А я вам покажу більш такі наукові знання, і вони дійсно, вони трошки взяті з психіатрії,
але для суспільства їх адаптували так, щоб люди всі розуміли.
Не так, що там кажуть, о, блін, в тебе діагноз.
Ні, в тебе не діагноз, в тебе це називається дуже красиво,
тобі калір про це придумав, я буду вам цю модель показувати.
Адаптація. Тобто ти крутий, бо ти вижив.
А вижив саме от так. Добре? Ідемо далі.
Що важливо? Існує шість основних адаптацій, особистість них.
І є якась наша генетична схильність, ми ж знаємо, органіка вона є, але є і події у дитинстві.
І ці адаптації, любі студенти, вони універсальні, бо кожен з нас має оцей набір.
і генетика, і як знав ми себе, наші батьки поводили.
Добре. Але, так, Ань, слухаю.
А швиденьке питання стосовно адаптації, як ви сказали, що вони формуються,
вони формуються до якогось певного віку, правильно?
Так, так. А зараз все ж покажу. Боже, як це в мене зацікало.
От мені подобається, коли в мене багато питань.
Це до якоїсь віку, але дивіться, в кожного з нас є декілька своїх дві виражені адаптації, тобто буде такий мікронабор.
І одна адаптація, дивіться уважно, це дуже важливо, вона була в вас сформована для вашого виживання до трьох років.
Щоб ви вижили в тих родинах, де ви народилися.
Вона дуже важлива. Вона допомогла вам вижити.
Бо батьки ж бувають різними.
А інша адаптація від 3 до 6, вона називається для отримання схвалення.
Це для того, щоб ваша родина вас прийняла і сказала,
«Добре, ну добре, ти свій, давай, залишайся».
Тобто вам було потрібно отримати це схвалення.
Одна, щоб вижити, інша, щоб вас хвалили якось, на вас звертало увагу.
Ось так.
І зараз дуже маленька, коротка вправа.
Подумайте і запишіть, як ви себе поводитеся у стресовій ситуації.
Одне-два речення просто собі занотуйте.
І друге, що ви робите для того, щоб виправдавати очікування інших людей?
Тобто, як ви себе поводите у стресові ситуації?
Ну, наприклад, давайте, for example.
Закриваюся.
Становлюся антисоціальною особистістю.
Ну, стрес, що мені?
Пофіг. Піду по головах, по трупах піду.
Або стаю такою собакою-подозрівакою, як я кажу, все, весь світ мене переслідує.
Або, щоб отримати схвалення, я багато працюю, або багато даю радості іншим людям.
Або становлюся такою пасивно-агресивною заразою
і роблю якісь тільки, знаєте, як оташий покляк пакості.
І ніхто не знає, що я її зробила.
Давайте, от на 6 хвилиночок в пари,
занотуйте собі, які ви люди добрі у стресі
і що ви робите для того, щоб вас інші люди любили.
Дякую за перегляд!
А Юля, можеш мене, будь ласка, дата до зала випадково викинула?
Так, давай я переміщаю.
Сюда.
Дякую за перегляд!
Лада, я вам надіслала там фото. Я вам надіслала фото нашого маленького, можете подивитися.
Яка вага була? Принароченні чотири рівно. Ого! Оце такий величенький.
Ми потім гуляємо по городу, я дивлюсь на пари, в яких троє дітей з таких поводок. Я думаю, які ви герої, я не знаю, ні з одним. Троє людей не справляються біля одного, а троє дітей.
Який красивий! Як його звуть? Лука. Красивий, дуже красивий.
Нехай він буде здоровим та успішним, нехай в нього все буде добре. Вам на радість.
Дякуємо, дай Бог. У вас вже двійнята чи близьнята, як ви відразу з двома малезенькими так справлялись?
вам допомагали чи ви так самі все? Ні, ми тільки самі у роддомі, а потім все няні, ти ж не можеш повернутися в нас.
Це з однією дитинкою, це як чіла, це як у раю, бо ти можеш і поспати, і погуляти, і погодувати.
Ну, взагалі, то прикольно з однією дитину, бо в мене ж старша вона народилася до цього раніше, то це просто кайф, кайф.
А з двома то все, рай закінчився, тут ти годуєш, тут ти перевдягаєш, тут ти знову годуєш, тут один спить, а інший прокинувся, тут один бежить в одну сторону, інший в другу.
О, це був челлендж.
Так, я так поки не народила, я дуже хотіла двійнят, близнят, відразу двох, так мені подобалось.
І коли я народила, я розумію, Боже, це так важко, з одним важко приходити до себе.
Ми ж його перші півтора-два тижні годували кожні дві години, і він виходить її в сорок хвилин.
І вже через час тридцять, час двадцять потрібно його знову годувати.
І я думаю, боже, це взагалі, це ж нереально.
А він їсти хотів?
Він хотів, так. Схуд ми виписали з родома 3580.
І дуже, як би, схуд сильно, і він не хотів їсти.
Він дуже довго, як би, спав.
І нам сказали все, кожні дві години його годувати.
І ми в нього прям впихували, знаєте, це було так.
Зараз вже все добре, з апетитом, зі сном, вже кожні три годинки, і вже легше, набагато.
А, це добре.
Добре. Ну що, занотували ваші шедеври?
Так, добре, далі будемо з цим працювати.
Йдемо далі.
Звідки ця вся історія, вона взагалі з'явилася?
Слухайте, дайте я вам задам питання.
Ви хочете трошки психіатрії почути?
Бо це такий паралельний процес.
Вам цікаво, щоб немо це п'ять мов любові та-да-та.
Давайте я вас трошки так, ну, таку професіональну вам надам інформацію,
звідки ця вся історія почалася, як я вам вже говорила.
Значить, так.
Історія почалася з Пола Вара.
Його так говорять українською, полвер, його переводять, але полвар зазвичку, тата бікалєра.
Знаєте, як завжди геніальні ідеї, вони приходять одночасно до двох людей.
Тобто два чоловіка, живучи десь дуже далеко один від одного.
Один психіатр, інший психотерапевт почали розмірковувати над однією і тією самою ідеєю.
Так, добре, без камери.
І Пол Вар, він почав досліджувати людей, він працював психіатром у лікарні.
І він усвідомив, що є дуже багато способів, як люди пристосовуються у своїй родині, щоб вижити.
Тобто, задавав питання і слухав, що там люди йому говорять.
Тобто, це було у 1978 році.
І в 1983 році він далі продовжував розробляти ці концепти.
У той самий час Табі Калер, до речі, дуже цікавий такий чоловік, він зробив багато грошей на цьому, подивіться на цього багатого цікавого чоловіка, бо він вів авторське право на свої адаптації.
І він розробив опитувальник, який давав іншим людям, і цей опитувальник, він ґрунтувався виключно на концептах транзакційного аналізу.
І він дивився, як люди поводять у своїй драйверній поведінці себе, і потім пристосовував це все до особистих адаптацій.
А ну-ка, зараз я буду середи тої вчительки.
Скажіть мені, будь ласка, зараз, Сніжаночко, я все бачу.
Які є драйвери?
Чи таке драйвер взагалі, люди, добре?
Хочу відкрити зошити, подивіться.
Драйвери можна назвати?
Не надо, надо, Оля.
Радуй других, будь сильним, старайся, поспішай, і ще один.
Будь досконалим.
Будь досконалим, так.
Боже, ну все, добре. Хоч одна людина з курсу відповіла, що таке дрейвери.
Алло, прокидаємося, це ваші захисні функції, як ви живете.
Один сильний, інший радує інших, третій досконалий,
четвертий тільки намагається щось зробити, але не робить.
Або є ще такі люди, які все поспішають. Сніжан, слухаємо.
У мене коротке питання.
Ми коли будували ту сценарну матрицю, там будуть драйвери.
Це туди, так?
Після цієї теми можна додати сценарну матрицю?
Ні, взагалі сценарна матриця – це окремо сніжан, бо це окремий інструмент.
Ти береш, розкриваєш сценарну матрицю, тут собі драйвери написали, хто там, що люди, до чого, взагалі, як вони виросли.
А тут заборони. От тобі вся сценарна матриця. Тут, як люди себе проводять у стресі, драйвери – це стрес поведінка, тобто, яким ти стаєш у стресі.
А тут, що тобі батьки наказали, що вони тобі заборонили робити або жити, або дозволи, якщо є такі щастливі люди.
Хорошо, поняла, дякую.
Добре. Тобто це все з собою поєднується.
Оцей чудовий чоловік, він взяв і це зробив.
І він це назвав процесуальною моделью, тобто він подивився, як люди себе поводять.
А Поль Вар, він собі досліджував свої історії з психіатрією, і ще до них усіх приєднався Вен Джойц.
І він, ну це більш такий сучасний, подивіться, такий сучасний чоловік, він взяв і це зробив сучасним.
Тобто оптимізував цей питомельник. Все.
Це зрозуміло?
Був психіатр, був транзактний аналітик.
І ще один, який це все узагальне.
Все зрозуміло? Питань немає?
Немає.
А тепер готуйтеся.
Зараз будуть дуже-дуже цікаві назви.
Показую.
Поєднання Ола Вара з Табі Кайлером.
Дивіться, як це некрасиво називається в психіатрії.
Перша тут написана адаптація.
Істерична.
Некрасиво?
Некрасиво.
Бачите?
А люди ж не люблять діагнози.
Коли ти приходиш і кажеш, що ти істерико, що ти тут робиш, знаєте,
це коли там скандали якісь, це ж неприємно.
А дивіться, який був розумний табі калір.
Він назвав людей, які мають дуже багато почуттів, надреагуючий ентузіаст, тобто емпатік.
Красиво? Заходить, люди добрі? Це ж ліпше, ніж істерка.
Дивіться далі. Це нормально вам заходить? Мені красиво за табі каліром.
Мені не подобається цей полвар, які такі діагнози усім подобається.
але ж це психіатр, слухайте, ну про що він, взагалі це все дослідив, давайте далі, наступна історія, я вам буду називати,
і кожного ще буду пояснювати, обсесивна, компульсивна, не красива, також, ну що ти, сидиш собі, компульсія якась з тебе,
Дивіться, як красиво. Трудоголік, працеголік. Я не знаю, я російською це все, знаєте, перекладаю. Трудоголік я його називаю. Ну, давайте, як люди нормально. Бо що це? Працеголік. Який він працеголік?
Він трудоголік по нашій мові. Людина багато працює. Зрозуми? Красиво, теж нам підходить.
Дивіться, тут написано параноїдно, знаєте, оце я кажу, собака-подозрівака, а що, а воно, а ти, а що ти, коли ти будеш.
І дивіться, як він красиво назвав тобі калір, блискучий скептик.
Тобто людина просто задає багато питань відносно того, як в інших людей будується життя.
Такий контрольор трошечки.
Далі. Шизоїдна. Це не шизофрінія. Не пишіть собі, бо в мене студенти кажуть, що це шизоїдна, це капець нам. Шизоїдна, ну така закрита собі людина.
А тут дивіться, як красиво. Творчий мрійник. Нормально? Дивіться, ця адаптація пасивно-агресивна. Пасивно-агресивна. Оце така шипокляк.
А це називається в нього грейливий бунтар. Нормально, заробив гроші, назвав красиво, а грошей, боже, люди, добре, якби ви знали, скільки він бере за навчання в своїй адаптації.
На х помножено те, що ви заплатили.
Дуже багато, бо в нього це дійсно цікава модель.
І наостанок, занотуйте собі, занотуйте, дивіться, антисоціальний.
Ті люди, які по головах йдуть.
А тут це називається чарівний маніпулятор.
Ага, красиво. Все? Ви собі табличку зробіть, скріншот, щоб знали, бо будемо до цього повертатися далі.
Нормально, красиві назви, все, запам'ятали, комусь щось там вже підійшло, ви подивіться, що ви там собі писали, можете вже галочки ставити, де ви, яка назва вам більше підходить, добре?
Тепер йдемо далі. Що це означає? Починаємо з істеричної адаптації. Давайте зараз я вам розкажу все відносно психіатрії. Так, Василю, слухай.
У мене питання. Нам скидають ту методичку в іншому форматі, і там не все є. Чи оце є там, чи немає?
Я не пам'ятаю зараз Василю, бо я працювала цей семінар, я його готувала раніше.
Табличка порівняння є, але пояснення, що таке історичне і все решта, немає.
Я вже подивилась.
А, красиво, тобто ще буде.
Тобто в нас в сумі, в тих методичках, колись від тебе прозвучала така фраза, що в тих методичках є не все, а більше є отут.
і в принципі я хотів тобі це в діректу написати і цей просто питання якщо ми все одно були тут ми
це забрали та і коли ми хочемо повторити ми не маємо цієї презентації ми все одно забудемо
тобто ми доступ до цієї презентації тих хто навіть був теж мати не можемо тобто по цих бо от
мені прямо цінно ну приходиться брати коли я передивляюся скрінити екран вирізати форматувати
ти бачиш Василю як я добре заставляю тебе навчатися знаєш як люди навчаються вони роблять і
переписують головний для них матеріал то я геніальна вчителька Василю це перше по-друге я даю бонуси
люди які приходять сюди ну бо я ж знаю студенти ж сама студенткою була вони такі приходять і
Я все знаю, я все розумію. Вони тут послухали, вони запам'ятали. Потім передивилися, ще більше запам'ятали.
Скрин собі зробили, щось занотували, те, що дійсно важливе. І воно красиво, Василь.
А ті люди, які не прийшли, я ж кажу, це не моя проблема, Василю. Це не я, я це знаю.
Я не про тих, я не про того себе, який не прийшов, я про того себе, який прийшов і докладає, ну типу, мені реально це комфортно.
Василю, дивися на мене, дивися на мене.
Василю, головна інформація для тебе, все, що дуже важливо, я для вас залишила.
Так, але ізюминки, вони смачніші, але я почув, окей, дякую.
Оце, що дійсно важливо, щоб не перегружати мозок, що ти не сидів, як той троль, знаєш, з усіма оцими пакетами.
І такий, а ну-ка, я подивлюся, 150-89 сторінку. Все, що важливо, все є.
І є, о, тут ще технічні спеціалісти нам пишуть, в нас є доступ до перегляду.
Ну, взагалі, так, красиво, в себе дуже багато.
Технічний. Це я написала, що в нас є доступ до перегляду. Давайте не забирати час на те, що я вважаю не дуже зараз.
А це ж нормально, Юлія. Люди приходять, вони хочуть дізнатися кожен раз. Це ж не перша група. Так воно буває.
Ідемо далі. Буду пояснювати про цю істеричну адаптацію. Добре? Чуємо? Слухаємо? Показую. Буду показувати, буду пояснювати.
Головне, це дуже такі активні залучення до життя інших людей, вони чуйні, в них багато почуттів, вони легко входять в ролі, вони легко контактують з іншими людьми, вони люблять розважати інших, розв
ажатися самостійно і вони бажають бути у центрі уваги.
Але в них є емоційна нестабільність і вони спокушаючі. Вони дуже зосереджені на почуттях інших людей, істерично.
Зрозуміло? Подумайте, що таке Сніжано? Вже є розуміння, хто є?
Та ж зрозуміло, хто ніхто, навіть потім. Що це було?
Так, далі йдемо. Обсесивно-компульсивно.
Ще є таке нав'язливо-примисове.
Давайте залишимо обсесивно-компульсивно те, як я вам дала.
Тобто люди, вони більше не люблять бути з багатьма людьми.
Вони люблять бути наодинці з собою, але вони активно вирішують питання.
Активно.
Тобто вони беруть на себе, ні, це взагалі добрі люди, гарні люди,
бо вони все можуть зробити замість ваш.
Вони очікують, що хтось підійде до них, з ними встановить контакт,
і вони будують стосунки з тими, хто їм подобається.
Дуже відповідальні, тримають слово, все роблять правильно.
Отакі трудолюбіві люди, люблять, залучені до праці.
Це зрозуміло?
Не дуже це важко відносно психіатрії розглядати.
Нормально?
Йдемо далі.
Шо в нас тут далі?
Далі.
Шизоїдна адаптація.
Тобто люди займають пасивну позицію у житті.
Знаєте, це такі люди, одиночки, які сидять і чекають,
що хтось прийде до них і з ними буде спілкуватися.
Самі вони не ініціюють цей контакт.
Іноді вони можуть бути залучені у мистецтво, у програмування.
Це туди.
Айтішники, хто там є з айтішників, знаєте,
у вас можуть бути найкрутіші айтішники, вони мають оцей стиль адаптації.
Вони поважають межі інших, вони можуть формально погодитися,
але внутрішньо не погодитися.
Мало зважають увагу на те, як вони виглядають,
для них дуже важливий комфорт, вони в душі мріють про контакт з іншими людьми
І, знаєте, є в них от така історія, вони думають, що хтось гадає, що ти від нього хочеш, від цієї людини.
І він очікує, доки ти прийдеш, і його будеш робити те, що він хоче.
І використовують мало слів, не дуже люблять говорити.
І будь-яке спілкування, от таке близьке спілкування, не те соціальне, знаєте,
бо айтішники в нас є такі, які прийшли і на конференціях виступають,
а от таке спілкування близьке, воно є для них великою напругою.
І дуже важко зрозуміти, чи вони ображені, чи не ображені,
тобто вони зникають і пішли, знаєте, пішов сам у себе і залишився там, не повернувся.
Оце я вам казала, коли перенаводила той випадок,
що жіночка думала, що її коханий її не любить,
А в нього просто була оця адаптація шизоїдна.
Він її любить, але не дуже контактний.
Так, далі йдемо.
Пасивно-агресивна адаптація.
Зараз оця шапокляк.
Дивіться.
Вони включаються в спілкування.
Вони, включившись, залишаються пасивними.
Тобто, знаєте, люди, які очікують, що хтось за них візьме відповідальність, вони чинять опір і вони надмірно контролюють ситуацію.
Такі люди, якщо вам погано або ви щось не те зробили, вони стане і буде каже, я бачу твою помилку.
А що ти зробив? Тобто ті, які ще й будуть вас критикувати.
Тиханечко так, тобто, я ж тобі на благо хочу щось добре сказати.
І виглядають начебто такі гарні, дуже такі, ну, добрі люди, але ні, ні, ні, ні, ні, вони мають таку історію, що вони будуть агресувати на вас.
Тобто, вони можуть випадково або вибухнути, або зробити вам щось не дуже добре.
Тобто, вони завжди не погоджуються з вами.
згадайте, будь ласка, є такі у вас люди
слухайте, жінки такі ж бувають
якщо їм хтось щось погане зробив
і вони мають доступ до прання речей
такий клієнтський випадок
в мене одна жіночка
в її чоловіка був дуже гарний кашеміровий свет
такий дорогий, падлюка
6500-600 євро коштував
Ну, а може і більше.
Вона каже, ой, не встийла я тобі, кохані, занести той светер у хімчистку.
І закинула на приння.
Коханого був розмір 3XL.
Дістала вона той светрик, от такий сінький, манюсінький, гарний такий, красивий.
Як ви думаєте, після чого це все відбулося?
Так, коханий щось їй неприємне сказав, вона светрики йому попрала.
Отак, зрозуміла, що це означає?
Ну, це не завжди так, що там дуже погано,
але просто таке життя так буває.
Добре, далі.
Параноїдна адаптація.
Тобто люди видають перевагу цієї самотності.
Вони люблять бути самотніми, такі, знаєте, вони собі щось думають,
Вони бухгалтери класні, юристи класні, організатори класні,
добре контролюють і підтримують структуру.
Нормальні люди, але вони схильні до грандіозності.
Це люди, які в них є саме своя думка і більше немає.
Це зрозуміло, тобто вони такі стратеги.
І антисоціальна адаптація, тобто люди зациклені на собі.
І вони агресивні. І вони і цікаві, і агресивні, і гарні.
Вони завжди маніпулюють, щоб досягнути якихось своїх меж.
Зробити те, що їм потрібно.
Завжди конфліктують з соціальними правилами, нормами, дуже гостро реагують на стрес.
І головне, що вони роблять, завжди діють у власних інтересах.
Егоїсти, без відповідальні, можуть бути агресивні і імпульсивні.
Чи це зрозуміло відносно психіатрії?
Є якісь питання?
Наслухаю.
Ну, знаєте, як це в хорошому анекдоті.
Примірила все на себе, все є місце бути.
Зависимості від людей, від обстоятельств, від сфери, ну, проявлено все, все части, я не можу сказати, що де-то там, ну, де-то, може, раніше що-то більше, де-то що-то менше, але, опять же, смотри, в
якому контексті, ну, все, я можу і манипулирувати красиво, і можу, і можу закрыватися, і ні з кем не общаться, і мені там добре, можу себе бухгалтером бути тут часами, а можу бути, взагалі, так це
розуміти.
Я можу бути разною, але вибири, будь ласка, нескільки будь ліпимих вариантов, то є ми-то всі можемо бути разними.
Ну, да, так а неактивно? Я не знаю, как.
А вот надо сейчас буквально на 4 минуточки разбиться в пари, выбрать то, що вам більше всього відкликається.
Там, де ви чувствуєте мою. Один, два.
Я стабендер, я взяла частями, але мне надо все сразу, мне все подходит, беру все.
Настя, не підходить, тепер треба сість подумати і вибрати ось це. У мене чаще буває це, у всіх у нас буває все, але щось, давайте на 4 хвилиночки зробіть цю вправу відносно адаптації поля вара, для
себе поставте галочки і подумайте, як ви це робите з іншими людьми у житті.
Влада, відкриви, будь ласка, табличку ще раз назад, бо я її не встиг відкрити.
Зараз. Зали відкриті. Я в чат надіслала її.
Надіслала. Бімба, дякую, Влад, не потрібно.
Дякую.
Як ви з'їздили на відпочинок?
Гарно, дуже красиво відпочила.
Набралася сил, побачила подружку і повернулася.
Нічого не почувала.
А де це ви були?
Я була в Англії, а потім поїхала купати дітей у моречку.
Трошки там, трошки тут.
Клас! Я за вас рада дуже.
І я сама рада, бо і мені хотілося.
Дітям дуже сподобалася Англія, неймовірно, особливо синою.
Він каже, що це його тепер улюблена країна.
А де це ви були в Англії?
А біля Манчестеру.
Там є таке невелике мастечко.
Там якраз цей час і провели.
Подружка в мене там живе вже майже 4 роки.
А чому сину сподобалася Англія?
Йому, я навіть не уявляю, просто йому сподобалася атмосфера, йому сподобалося все, але там дуже холодно, якщо відвертою.
Так, ось це, знаєш, погода, це ж ти така.
Неймовірно, холодно, я там замерзла так, що, мабуть, так я вже давно не замерзала, мені було не дуже добре від цього, але що робити?
Мія дуже сильно хворіла, не жаль, але вона молодець, навіть впоралася із хворобою.
І все нормально, повернулися всі назад.
Накопалися, відпочилися і приїхали сюди працювати далі.
Ось це я знаю, що в Англії просто завжди всі кажуть, що погода там дуже така нетипова для нас,
прям незвична і ось через погоду багато хто не вибирає Англію, тому що це так.
Так, дуже-дуже-дуже, дуже там холодно, я, може, там би і була, бо там красиво, там все гарно, але все одно.
Я теж така теплолюбива, і навіть ми зараз, коли повернулися в Учгород, я кажу, боже, як я забула, що тут так тепло,
В порівнянні з Києвом, з Варшавою, де я жила, тут на порядок декілька градусів тепліше і там швидше тепліє.
Знаєте, я тут така теплолю пива. Але класно.
Дуже класно, бо для мене це важко, коли ти прокинувся і ходиш у зимових тапках в кімнаті.
Мені погляд, це прохолодно дуже.
А в них і отоплення таке в квартирах не дуже?
А в них отоплення, воно включається автоматично, тільки під ранок, а потім виключається.
Так, повертаються.
Добре, скажіть, є якісь питання чи ні?
У мене питання. Влад, а можна, пожалуйста, поставити, коли ми виходимо у кімнати, і там нема таймеру?
Я не орієнтуюся, коли воно закінчиться чогось цього разу. Це тільки у мене, чи це у всіх так?
Таймер був, Таня. Таймер був? Да, да, був.
Таймер є, але він вибиває. Ну, типу, немає цього віконечка, як зазвичай, лишилось там скількись.
Воно, типу, є час-час, а потім 30 секунд лишається, і воно вибивається.
Це вже втретєта.
Так, так, так. Оце мені трошечки
я плутаюся у часі.
Таня, я, чесно,
не технічна.
Це не важливо. Якщо ні, то ні.
Юль, тут є питання,
треба зробити. Я не знаю, як це зробити.
Так, на цей раз 15 секунд.
Зараз подивимося, тут галочку вімкнула
одну і подивимося,
наступного разу буде
ось ця віконечко.
Дякую, дякую.
Добре, Лєр, слухаю.
Владочка, у мене такий питання. Ми з Татьяною столкнулися з тим, що дуже схожі обсязивно-компульсивні і параноїдні нам показалось.
Можна ще раз разницю між ними? Хорошо, скажу прямо.
Прошу прощення, що схожесть нашли в тому, що вони більше в себе уходять.
І хочеться ще більше розницю зрозуміти, що один і що другое.
А я буду патом говорити ще більше розницю.
Я просто не останавливаюсь на психіатрических історіях,
тому що люди, коли слухають психіатрию, вже починають зівати, їм тяжело.
Якщо сказати просто, а обсесивно-компульсивно,
це люди, які відповідальні, багато роботають,
і вони розшають вопросы.
Якщо говорити о параноїдной, це люди, які багато подозріють, грандиозні і считають, що їх мнення личне дуже правильно.
Понятні становиться?
Поняла, благодарю.
Тобто вони різні. Одні уходять в роботу, інші уходять в мисли і розміщення, як я б зараз создав весь мир.
Одна людина собі пішла, тихенько працює,
щось там, собі роботу робить, гроші заробляє,
а інша людина починає говорити.
І оце люди, які мають тільки своє мніння, це що?
Ну, це мають.
Своє уявлення і ніякої іншої.
І спробуй тільки їм докажи, оцій грандіозній особі,
що в тебе щось якось по-іншому.
Будете витрачати багато часу.
Добре, з полям варом трошки розібралися.
Давайте зараз перейдемо до «Тести будуть, все буде».
Дайте мені можливість показати вам до кінця семінар.
Ви хочете все одразу, все буде, все у вас буде, все буде красиво.
Дивіться, за Табі Кайлером, він досліджував більше поведінку і він її дослідив за цією матрицею.
Тобто він дивився, як люди поводять себе.
Є дві осі – активність і пасивність.
І є залученість, тобто я іду в контакт з кимось.
І є відстороненість.
І він зробив такі 4 сегменти основні, що є люди, які активно залучені.
Тобто вони активні і залучені. Вони прийшли до вас, самі з вами почали говорити, збирати групи і робити щось.
Інші люди, вони активно відсторонені.
Тобто вони активні, коли ти до них підійдеш, і вони люблять спілкуватися ван-то-ван, тет-а-тет.
Такі зустрічі.
Тут пасивна залученість.
Тобто людина пасивна.
Вона не ініцює сама, але хоче бути частиною групи.
І пасивна відстороненість.
Тобто людина, яка чекає, що всі проблеми вирішить замість нього.
Ось такі чотири сегмента.
Табі Калір він більше досліджував цю поведінку.
Що означає активність?
Активність – це коли людина бере на себе ініціативу, сама діє, сама спілкується.
Пасивність означає, коли людина чекає, що хтось за нею вирішить всі проблеми і не ініціює контакти перші.
Залученість. Тобто, коли людина залучається, вона обожнює великі групи.
Її подобається це.
Відстороненість або уход російською мовою.
Це означає, що людина любить бути на одинці.
І є отакі чотири елементи.
Чи є по цих елементах якісь питання?
Подумайте, які ви люди.
Де ви з цих чотирьох сегментів себе бачите?
Так, Ань?
Я хотела спросити, а по етапам жизни, в зависимости от ситуации,
ми же можемо мінятися по цим чотирьом секторам?
Тому що я на самом деле очень активний чоловік, ініціатор.
Но на сьогоднішній день я активний, или пассивний, неактивний.
То есть я буду ждать, пока кто-то решит.
Хоча все ромно, якщо я буду видеть, що не так, рішають, то я, конечно, включусь.
А давайте так.
Так, може ли бути ситуація життя, чи якихось етапів в житті міняти ці сектора?
Тобто ми все ромно, мені кажеться, входимо в більшій степені.
І звісно в ці ситуації.
Ми можемо по ним ходити, але давайте так, усугублю історію.
Либо компетенція, тобто там, де я чуваю, що я компетентна, я знаю, я буду активним ініціатором.
Там, де я не розбираюся, я буду посильна.
Посмотрите, кем ви чаще буваєте,
і подумайте над тим, як ви буваєте в момент стреса,
як ви себе ведете в момент стреса.
Или ви іщете групу,
или ви уходите куди-то в себе,
или ви решаєте вопросы,
или ви в ожиданні чудес.
Просто поставте собі десь галочку,
куди вас Бог послав, як ви суваєте.
Так, везде.
Ань, не бывает.
У мене такий час період, що я везде.
В цей момент времени, Аня, в цю секунду.
Активна.
Ну, це добре, ставимо галочку «активна».
Все ровно степаж остається.
Может быть, я везде, но личності ж никуда не денешь.
Якщо була активна, то, в принципі, останешся активна.
Якщо іниційувала контакти, будете іниційувати контакти.
Так жизнь устроена.
Настя?
Це серія.
Якщо я активна, активна.
Але зараз момент передышки.
Человек встає, система встає, здоров'я, то я в такому положенні.
Але все одно вона проявляється.
Активна частина.
Набереться ресурси і опять туди.
І пошла.
Все одно ти вернешся к этим істокам.
Грубо говоря.
Вернешся.
То есть, де я себя більше вижу.
Где мене більше, в якій части мене більше.
Що таки розслухаю.
Ладно, тобто якщо навіть оце перехідний, тому що навчань дуже багато,
зараз переходимо в різні такі апгреунди мозку,
і відповідно база у нас є, ми можемо в цьому самому форматі реагувати,
але вже більше усвідомленіше, вже більш керованіше,
тобто вже більше, якби не бути на імпульсивному це рівні,
а перевести на усвідомлений рівень, але базово в нас адаптація ось така йде.
Правильно я зрозуміла?
Так, так.
Тобто, що повністю зміниться адаптація, але є, що ми навчимося бути в цій адаптації більше професіоналами.
Ми будемо розуміти, чому ми в цій адаптації, і не будемо відчувати стрес.
Дякую.
Поставили собі ці галочки?
Добре, йдемо далі.
Зараз покажу, як оці всі за полем, варом адаптації, де вони знаходяться.
Дивіться.
Істероїдна.
Активний, залучений.
Абсесивно-компульсивний, оцей, той, який багато працює.
Отут.
Далі, пасивно-агресивна, отут історія, тобто залучений і пасивний.
Відсторонений і пасивний, тут, і дивіться, шедевр оцей, який йде по трупам, антисоціальний, отут, посередині, тобто має все, що йому потрібно для виживання, це нормально.
А параноїдна, він відсторонений, і він і неактивний, і не пасивний.
І от Поль Вар, він виділяв три сфери, через які людина взаємодіє з світом.
Це мислення, почуття або поведінка.
Так, Василю, слухаю.
Це звідси пішли оці всі продажники, які вивчають, що кудові людина контактує і зразу в цю точку б'ють.
НЛП відносно теж, виходить, звідси йде, так?
Так, так, так.
І дивіться, що придумав цей геніальний Поль Вар.
Він придумав, і це дуже наглядно і дуже красиво, двері контакту.
Тобто, уявіть собі, що у людей є двері, через які ви можете до неї зайти.
Тобто, легко, ми можемо один з одним спілкуватися.
Давайте наведу приклад.
Наприклад, я починаю з кимось розмова.
І я починаю, ну, давайте, з кимось поговорю зараз.
Хто хоче зі мною поговорити?
Я вам покажу, як швидко
оприділяти двері контакту.
Давай, Сніженко, говори.
Давайте поговоримо.
Давайте, Сніженко, поговоримо.
Розкажіть мені трошки
про те, як ранок відбувся.
Сьогодні?
Так.
Я все не готова розказувати.
Ну, якісь історії,
ну, щось таке для публіки.
Мені трошки хоч послухати.
давайте відпочити а як як відбувся рано як я проснулася в чудовому настрої
зрозуміло що сьогодні буде прекрасний день розділені на дві частини навчання
потім гулянка ніжанко досить
зараз покажу
Сніжанка, це так, тільки по першому реченню те, що почула.
У нас є три двері.
Якщо, Сніжан, я буду з вами розмовляти про те, як ми вип'ємо каву.
Це цікаво вам поговорити?
Ні, що мені оце «вип'ємо каву» говорити, ні.
А що, щось зробити? Що ми будемо робити сьогодні?
Та ми сьогодні будемо, ми будемо вчитися сьогодні, потім ми будемо збиратися на п'янку,
потім ми будемо там забавлятися, класно з людьми спілкуватися, танцювати.
Дивіться, є різні двері контакту.
Є те, що я почула, Сніжана сказала, прокинулася, там щось зробила, діє.
Це легко, те, що можна зі Сніжаною обговорювати.
Далі вона сказала, я відчула себе чудово.
Друга, це почуття.
І наостанок вона сказала, я подумала.
Тобто, якби я хотіла зі Сніжаною розмовляти,
я би в неї і запитала, і я інтуїтивно в неї запитала.
Сніжано, як сьогодні відбувся ранок?
Я пішла.
Про дії було.
Про дії, так.
Сніжано, легше говорити про якісь дії, про якісь справи.
Туди поєднувати почуття, ніж говорити про свої думки.
Так, легше зі мною, легше в початку про справи, про дії про справи.
Розумієте? Тобто є двері контакту.
Як ми можемо з будь-якою людиною встановити контакт?
Зараз я вам це покажу.
Хвилиночку.
Бо це відкрита дверь.
Тобто, мені легше з Сніжаною говорити, коли я заходжу з неї, до неї, з відкритої двері.
Є друга ціль, через яку я можу з неї ще мати будь-який контакт, подивитися,
тобто, з нею поспілкуватися більш-менш.
то про почуття, це називається, це відкрита дверя,
це двері сіль, а це пастка.
Влада, в мене питання, тобто відкрита дверя, це в мене про дії,
двері сіль, це в мене про почуття, а двері пастка, це думка.
Це так в мене, воно не у всіх так, так?
Не в усіх так. Це я гіпотетично, Сніжано, я просто не витрачала більше часу,
треба було більше послухати, але я взяла перше речення,
послухала те, що я почула, і далі дала зворотній зв'язок.
Ань, питання на одну хвилинку.
А двері пастка, це то, о чому не треба говорити, або що?
Так, то, о чому не треба говорити.
Тобто, якби я у Сніжани зараз почала питати, що ви думаєте далі про ці концепції, Сніжана б на одну секунду зависла би, їй було б нецікаво про це говорити.
Я вже і зависаю, ви вже не говорите, прям відчуваю.
Розумієте? Тобто, давайте зараз ми відпочинемо 10 хвилин.
Звернемося і потім ще раз про це поговоримо.
Ань, можна буде далі задати оце питання, продовжити.
Добре?
Давайте, смачно.
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Дякую за перегляд!
Повертаємося і працюємо далі.
Так, Лір, слухаю.
На вопрос возник.
Якщо ребінку не приходилось адаптируватися, то є виживати,
предположимо гипотетично, що ідеальні умови,
то тоді будуть визникати паттерни, які просто чаще проявлялися?
Як в цьому питання?
Якщо ребінку не треба було виживати, значить він буде просто жити.
І все, у нього будуть якісь свої ексклюзивні паттерни.
Якщо ви виросли в здорових семіях, а у вас все всегда було добре,
тоді вам цей матеріал буде не актуальним, не интересним.
Але в будь-якому, в будь-якому, в будь-якому, в будь-якому, в будь-якому, в будь-якому, в будь-якому, в будь-якому, в будь-якому, в будь-якому.
Двери контакта вам будуть открыты.
А так бывает?
Я пока ще за всю свою практику не видела.
Ну і в житті.
Тобто, якщо в сім'я їжеш ще з отцю, все рівно на дітській площадці, чи бабусі-дєдусі.
Ну, да, ну, поэтому реальність такова, да, я поки ще не бачила людей, які не мають хоча б якісь адаптати.
А віживання, да, можна назвати це не віживання, а просто спеціально такий термін взяли для того, щоб углубити понимання.
Ребенку треба було віжити.
Можете назвати це, ну, життя, життя в сім'е.
Так називаємо, як підтрійка, підстраиватися під якісь ситуацію приходилося. Я розумію, о чому я кажу.
Тепо да, тепо да, тепо підстроїться. Настя, був какой-то питання?
Ну да, я так розумію, що ж на ребінка влиять і садик, і соціума, адаптация, і мир, мир, в якому ми розділися, так чи інакше.
Ну да, ну да, такой у нас мир, такая у нас жизнь, да, я ще не виділа, щоб ми всі жили, як в раю.
Жили б як в раю, ми бі з вами не изучали ні коучинг, ні психологію,
тим більше психіатрию, в якій я вам сьогодні здесь ввіщаю.
Хорошо, добре, йдемо далі, да?
Дивіться, і оце починаємо з цих дверей контакту.
Зараз показую цей слайд.
Відкрита двер, дверціль і двері пастка.
Бо в кожної людини це щось своє.
Перше, що нам потрібно зробити, це встановити з людиною контакт.
І тут дуже важливо зрозуміти, що з нею відбувається, як це відбувається.
Як з Ніжановою ми розмовляли, тобто, чи дії, чи почуття, чи думки.
Через двері відкриті я можу зайти до будь-якої людиної і бути з нею в контакті.
Це дуже гарно, це дуже цікаво, це дуже легко, в нас буде цікаве, гарне спілкування.
Тобто, ми заходимо через контакт.
Друга двір, другі двері, це ціль, це куди ми маємо йти.
Ну, тобто, ми можемо про це розмовляти, наприклад, Сніжано, а що ви сьогодні робили там вранці, прокиснувався, або речі збирала, добре, о, речі зараз, я цікаво, буде більше питання, а що почувала,
коли оці речі збирала, які почуття були?
Задоволення від того, що сьогодні буде дуже гарне товариство.
Ну, от і так, тобто легко про це говорити.
А от двері пастка, про це людина не любить говорити, вона не хоче говорити.
Ань, я слухаю зараз питання, а потім далі буду доказувати.
Дуже коротке питання, тобто двері можуть бути тільки думки, почуття, поведінка.
Правильно, поведінку ми визначаємо по тому, що говорить людина.
Ось Сніжана сказала «я думаю».
Так, «ді», «почта» або «думки».
Ось, так, Ань, слухаю.
А чому людина, якщо це пастка, і він не хоче об цьому говорити?
Чому вона об цьому взагалі упомянула?
Вона ж могла і не сказати про свої думки.
На самом деле, Аня, для нас дверя, ловушка – это самая интересная дверя в коучинге, в терапії.
Это то, що нам треба розвивати для стабилизации личності человека
і давати більше можливостей думати, розказувати і висказувати своє мнення.
то Снежана получила б необыкновенный апгрейд,
якщо б ми постепенно розвивали через действие, через чувства її мышління.
Це б ще більше піднімало її по ступеням на верх уверенності,
коли б вона чітко починала говорити все, що вона думає.
Но якщо б я зразу зходу залетела і сказала, а Снежана, а що ти думаєш об цьому, це був би дисконнекшн, то є це інтересна двість з точки зрення розвития Лічності Человіка, она як загадка, дала відпов
ідь на випадку, її потрібно прокачувати, абсолютно верно, але заходить в її сразу нельзя?
Ну, не через нього заходить, скажем.
Якщо нам хочеться лігкого общення.
Нет, заходить в нього нельзя.
Це все ровно, що ти заходиш в тупик.
Человек не буде з тобою, це буде обрив коммуникації.
Клас.
Тобто спочатку ми встановили контакт, далі прийшли до цих двері.
Ціль – це ті двері, з якою необхідно працювати, щоб відбувалися подальші зміни.
Тобто, якщо ми зараз аналізуємо, наприклад, людину, в якої перше – це діє,
друге – це почуття, третє – то думки,
то тут якраз через оцю ціль, двері, ціль, відбуваються зміни,
Тобто підсилюється особистість і з'являється можливість перерішення зробити, зробити новий розвиток і взагалі робити нові якісь ідеї. Це дійсно класно.
І двері пастка – це як зона найбільшої вразливості. Тобто це той стан, коли людина дуже часто застрігає. Вона захищається від контакту, вона уникає контакту через цю двері пастку.
Але, але ще раз наголошую, що саме у дверей пасті ловушка, відбуваються найбільші зміни у житті людини.
Найглибша робота, найглибше все, що може бути.
Але заходити потрібно поступово.
Як для вас ці двері? Цікаво чи не цікаво? Давайте зараз на 6 хвилиночок, на 3 хвилинки на кожного, ви для себе занотуєте і подумаєте, де у вас відкрита дверя, тобто двері контакту, де у вас ціль і що
у вас є пасткою.
От ви зустрічаєтесь зараз у кабінетах, починаєте про щось говорити, інша людина щось записує,
ви щось записуєте, а потім показуєте один одному, що ви записали відносно себе, добре?
Щоб зрозуміти, де відкрита, де ціль, де пастка.
А потім будемо далі вже це досліджувати.
Юлія, слухаю.
Відносно себе ми розповідаємо, так? Не відносно того, що ми побачили про іншу людину, не так, як ви тільки щось сніжаною робили?
Ми спочатку розповідаємо відносно себе, інша людина це записує для себе і пише нотаточку, я думаю. Але ви коли самі про себе розповідаєте, також собі пишете, де відкрита ціль, де відкрита двері, двер
і контакту, де ціль і де пастка.
Ну, про щось розкажіть, ну, буквально декілька речень, Йоль.
Сама записала, інша людина записала, порівняли і пішли далі. Добре?
Шість хвилин.
Так, можна заходити.
Відкрила зали.
не не не давай ты сюди і туди
ну побачу
ревностною женщина
сердце дадай кажешу ты така дурна не можна тобі навіть прочесати димушка
я почула тодому я там і почула
Ні, що?
Я розумію, я розумію, Даймонда теж треба причесувати, як тебе?
Тобав це 6, так бывает.
Дякую за перегляд!
Чи є якісь питання?
Чи все зрозуміло?
Що не зрозуміло. Так, Лер?
Є вопрос. Немножко путається цель і ловушка.
Здесь имеється в виду, що дверь, цель – це то, що легче тебе проявляти в діалогі з другим.
Или як це обозначить? Направьте, будь ласка.
Хорошо, перша, відкритая двері, двері контакта, це то, що легко.
То, що у кожного з нас є одне перве, дуже важливе, дуже значиме.
Для кожного з нас що-то своє.
Наприклад, чи действия, чи чувства, чи мысли.
Следуючі, це двері-цель.
Це куди можеш піти далі, щоб допомогти іншому людину зміниться.
І він тебе пустит туди.
То есть, куди ти просто продовігаєшся, як в следующій дві.
Представте себе три двери.
Одна йдет за другою.
Ти не можеш зразу зайти в кімнату, в третью дві.
Тому що йдет вначале одна дві,
потім втаря дві, через яку ти проходиш, як цель.
Куди? Чтоб чого постепенно, мягко ввести дальше к змінням.
І третя цель.
Двір, она дуже класна, она інтересна.
Але ти можеш заїхати, наприклад, в третю двері,
я не знаю, там на скорости залететь.
І чоловік, ну, скажеш, ти обалден?
Ти куди приперся сразу в третю двері?
Ти почему со мною на таку тему говориш?
Я с тобою говорити на эту тему не буду,
мені це неприятно.
Поэтому, перше, це двір контакта,
куди ми легко залишли.
Дверь-цель – це куди ми подвігалися далі, т.е. нас спустять, нам не скажуть «остановись, пожалуйста», ти не туди йдеш, тому що людина буде почувати мягкость вашої коммуникації.
І дверь-ловушка – це куди ви йдете для глибоких змінений, для того, щоб допомогти зробити рост цьому чоловіку.
Заходити треба правильно, з правильной двери.
Лер, дала відповідь на випадку?
Благодарю, да.
Настя, слушаю.
Да, я вас зараз сидюю і розумію, що це третє дє...
Якщо ми вспомнюємо шкалу, в якій ми з контактами общались,
то, в принципі, третє дє двє, це вже туди, біже к інтимності.
Да, це моє, це моє сокровенне.
Ну, з однієї, це можна об'єднити і з контактами.
то есть ты быстрее придёшь к контакту со мной,
если ты правильно будешь заходить через двери.
Ну, і, в принципі, в глубину йдём, да,
то есть і сейчас ещё озвучили, осеніли,
то есть вот это вот последнее, например, у меня действие мысли і чувства.
Понятно, що якщо мені начинається від чувства,
то сразу я, ну, это моя вообще закрытая дверь, да, вот.
І тут получается, що на уровні чувств со мной, работая,
ну, да, вот коуч, ментор, то не важно,
То есть он начинает на уровне действий со мной разговаривать,
потім переходить, що ти об цьому думаєш,
і на уровне чувств
відбувається та, грубо говоря,
магія, де можна
со мной глубинно вивести
і какой-то зробити прорыв.
Да, я сподіваюся.
Спрашиваю, а що ти об цьому думаєш? А ти мені говориш, ну не знаю, там, що угодно, скажи, давай там, що, ну, любой вопрос, давай, що ти об цьому думаєш? Ну, я думаю, що це не дуже справедливо, наприк
лад, не дуже справедливо.
Це не дуже справедливо. Настя, скажи, а що ти відчуваєш, коли ти думаєш, що це не дуже справедливо?
Ну да, а тут вже переходимо в голубину, що це взагалі може бути боліно, це боліно, це не, грубо говоря.
Смотрите, не заслужено, ну, опять.
Помніте, я вас вчила 4 базових чувства – гнев, страх, печаль, радость.
Знає, що чуствуеш, коли ти думаєш, що це не дуже справедливо.
Печаль.
З цим і треба працювати.
Якщо ми працюємо з цим і будемо працювати,
то, першу, контейнер Настя освободиться,
вона буде по-другому себе відчування,
вона виплеснє куча гнева,
сможет оплакати кучу печалі
і повернеться абсолютно щастливой личності.
Да, ну я поняла, то есть мы заходим сначала в контакт через первую дверь, потом вторую, ну и третью. Ну у кого-то чувство на втором, а третья мысль.
У каждого своё, да, не делайте.
Работаем с тем инструментом, который за третья дверь.
Ми хочемо з нею работать, з цією третєю дверю,
але для того, щоб хоча б в кочингі нам установити контакт
і нормально бути в контакті.
А нам не говорили, що це за кочка мені прийшов отмороженого.
А вообще, какой-то коч не може контакт установити со мной.
А ви послушайте, і зразу зайдете.
Скажет, крутой коч, хороший, хороший, хороший.
Адже автоматически, да, как-то.
Класно знать і видеть.
Василю слухаю в нас в кімнаті було два коуча так і теж вийшли думки думання на останньому місці
так дивлюсь Сніжан нам було тут і ми двоє теж наскільки це теж залежить від виду діяльності
тобто наоборот ми як коучі теж діємо думками в кінці а будемо первинно діяти там через почуття
а потім через дії, ось наскільки це відображається чи ні, бо тут в мене вийшов рот, що якщо я багато, ну типу, коуч він мав би думати,
то до мене наоборот через думання можна було би зайти.
Ні, ні. Заходити треба туди, де двері відкриті, а не пертеся як отой танк, там де все зачинено.
Тобто, наприклад, якби ми спілкувалися з тобою, я б сказала, слухай, що ми зараз разом зробимо?
Скажеш, ну, пішли там щось, будемо вивчати.
Пішли, добре, там, ну, що зробимо, да?
Бо якщо діє, це є те, через що можна зайти до тебе.
А потім я запитаю, а що ти відчуваєш, коли ми це зробимо?
А ти кажеш, ну, прикольно, радісно, добре, а що ти думаєш про це?
І так поступово формується зміна особистості, да?
Це не завжди так, а що ти думаєш про це, а що ти думаєш про це?
А люди іноді не звикли думати, в них система виживання була така, що їм потрібно було щось робити цій родині, а не думати.
А є інші родини, там де мама казала, ти не роби нічого. І дитина сидить собі, і вона думає, думає.
І людина, в неї можуть бути дії на останньому.
І тут взагалі треба пушити ту людину, щоб вона почала діяти,
бо вона забагато думає.
Розумієте?
А є інший стан, коли люди не відчувають,
глибоко може травмовані,
бо це почуття, то найбільше біль в їхньому житті.
Так відбулося, на жаль.
І ти прийдеш до цієї людини, а що ти почуваєш, а що ти відчуваєш, знаєте, для мене оце, до того стану, коли я почала вивчати психотерапію, транзакційний аналіз,
в мене було єдине почуття, мені неприємно. Це ми потім вже, знаєте, багато років, 20 років до цього, мене запитули, що ти відчуваєш.
Ви ще люди здурілися, що я відчував, а мене голова болить, тобто в мене неприємно це все, що я навіть не хочу про це розмовляти.
Тобто потрібно крок за кроком йти. В кожного по-своєму. Це зрозуміло? Це дуже важливо.
Тут мені зрозуміло, але в мене чуть-чуть питання було в іншу сторону.
Тобто, виходить, якщо мій основний вид діяльності, це все-таки відчувати саму собою, але більше під час сесій ми думаємо і аналізуємо.
І виходить, що воно в мене аж на третьому місці.
І це для мене дивно, що мій вид діяльності основний в самому блоці.
Василю, розслабся, бо ти будеш до себе притягувати людей, які будуть мати такі самі відкриті двері.
Бо з людиною, яка, наприклад, за твоїм видом діяльності має думати,
ти буде з нею, в тебе
ерор. Ерор.
Одразу, ерор. Це не означає,
що вона прийшла, вона тобі говорить
не інтелектуалізація,
говорить, говорить, говорить,
говорить. І ти думаєш, блін, я ж кочі,
ми ж маємо думати. А в тебе
самого це закрито. Ти не
думаєш, ти дієш.
То й люди до тебе прийдуть такі самі.
Не треба хвилюватися із-за цього.
І взагалі, слухайте, досить
думати шаблонно.
Чого ви думаєте,
Шаблона, як має виглядати ідеальний коуч. Він виглядає так, як ви виглядаєте. Немає картинки ідеального коучу. Що ми зараз тут подумаємо?
Ви ідеальні коучі, ідеальні, занотуйте собі, і до вас прийдуть такі самі люди, як і ви, бо це називається, що ми притягуємо людей за неасімільованим досвідом.
Тобто людина, яка в неї була така схожа історія, вона прийде до вас.
Бо конкуренції в світі взагалі не існує.
Ви повчитесь в мене, підете вчитися в якоїсь іншої людини,
транзакційному аналізу, вона вам не зайде просто.
От просто буде не воно, ви будете казати,
бля, навіщо мені той транзакційний аналіз до вона і ця людина розповідає?
бо досвід не асімільований, ви різні з ними, за сценаріями, різні.
То живіть собі спокійно, до вас прийдуть ваші клієнти.
І ви, геть зовсім один з одним, не конкуренти, на все життя запам'ятні.
Немає конкуренції, це як батьки.
Оце головне, добре? Всі запам'ятали?
Ідеальні, якого, чи то ви?
О, ще раз, повтори, будь ласка, вже на камеру,
ото про це ідеальне ідеальні кучі то Ви хочеш ще раз повторю та ще раз на Василя то мені за
це платять гроші ідеальні кучі то Ви нормально записав викладай Добре Оля секундочку Васенька
Отметь, пожалуйста, всіх участників, всі себе зроблять репост.
Окей, окей.
Давай, Оль, скажи.
Да, Влад, у мене тут теж рож случился,
тому що я коли розказувала, у мене було дуже багато дійствий,
потім чувства, а думати я взагалі не думала.
У мене не було в речі, що я о чому-то подумала.
Молодець.
Вот це і є двоє репостка, навіть якщо я це не озвучила.
Конечно. Люди об цьому не говорять.
Все, спасибо.
Ви поняли це? Запомніть, це правда дуже важливо.
Не треба ломитися не в те двери.
Лен, слушай.
А вот, якщо прислати, наприклад, клиенту, і у нього питання у мене на роботі не складається,
і вот він говорить дійсною, а на самом деле, тільки лише тому, що у нього нет чувства в семьі.
Вот як понять, то він прийшов з проблемою, дійсто ми видим, двір дійсто, а там треба йти в чувства.
Или це в процесі його розказа?
В процесі розказа, але як же ми підемо в чувства, якщо чоловік про чувства не говорить?
Лена, він скажет, що все, якщо ти в чувства підеш, чувства – це двір-ловушка, не йдіть туди.
Ідіть туди, де двері відкриті.
Ну, вот, трудоголик он, напрямер, да, вот у него дома не все в порядке, он бежит в работу.
Ну, хорошо, пришел, рассказывает о работе, а ты, ой, как хорошо, какая интересная работа, хорошо, а что ты думаешь о работе?
И он дальше, ля-ля-ля-ля-ля-ля-ля-ля, а что ты чувствуешь, когда ты так работаешь?
Он говорит, блин, дофига, а вот работаю, думаю, что очень много работаю, в жизни можденной, все надоело, чувствую печаль.
Мільйон на счет не упав.
О, добре. А якщо якісь проблеми?
Так постепенно треба. Ідіть за людьми.
Зрозуміла, пасіло.
Сніжану, слухай.
У мене таке не питання, я так все і подумала.
Власне, коли до нас приходять клієнти і починають розповідати нам,
що ми б не хотіли з нами попрацювати, ми формуємо запит.
Ми ж навіть як людина формує запит, ми можемо зрозуміти,
ось ці двері відкриті, вона буде більше говорити.
ми можемо дати уточнюючі запитання, щоб розчупити оцю дверці і те, що лишиться, ми можемо туди з першого разу не йти, бо людина дійсно може закритися.
Так.
І в мене була помилка, я зараз навіть бачу, класно, бо в мене там один був такий кейсик, мені було важко, а там людина була, перша дверя в неї була, думати.
Я от зараз вас почула себе, в неї була перша двері думати, а останнє діяти, а в мене навпаки.
І в нас був дисконект.
А ще більше скажу, тебе ці люди, вони будуть бісити.
Ох, як бісила. Я передала. Я коли відчула ось цю емоцію, що мене людина бісить, я її передала колезі.
і там і там був дуже класний конект дуже класний колега і клієнти були двоє мені вдячні
тобто класна класна штука я прямо зараз себе навіть зняла бо в мене оце так знаєш таки було
сиділо в голові типу ну цей кейс типу що я не окей коуч але мені зараз окей а тепер ти колегі
напередаєш і кажеш добре-добре розумію розумію да налаштована на контакт да готова далі
дякую Влада Боже я обожаю транзактний аналіз обожаю Влада бачите бо я вмію його викладати
цікаво дуже дуже правда чесно я дивлюсь я така сміюся сміюся але дуже нормально викладаю
Добре Настя кажи 100% подача просто із-за цього він заходить так би не зашов
Що я тільки що інсайт просто поймала, що, наприклад, мій клієнт 100%, в якому на останній місці буде мислить.
І, значить, коли ти вже знаєш ще й свого клієнта, як будеш…
Блин, тут взагалі можна як себе в соцмережах проявляти і його там через действия зазвати, да, відкриті двери, тоді твій клієнт точно прийдет.
Ти на дістях його потім поглубиш, углубиш на мислі.
Міняє мислі, міняє нейронні зв'язки.
У мене виходить у клієнта результат.
Тут можна общатися стратегію простроювати.
Молодці, вже з соцмережі все працюємо. І розслухаємо.
Тут дуже цікаво, тому що сказали, що перше запитання можна почути.
Ми коли були в групах і якраз ось там відповідали,
У мене була структура свого, як я роблю дію, тобто у мене були дії, потім думки і потім емоції.
Тобто мені здавалося, що емоції – це моя закрита двір.
Але зараз спілкуючись і слухаю, я розумію, що в мене йдуть спочатку дії,
бо нема чого думати, треба діяти, не гайчасно, тобто в мене ось ці паттерни дають.
Потім йде емоція, від якої я, якщо мені окей, або щось добре-недобре, і аж тоді думки, бо мене йде перше, нема чого думати.
І ось там ловушка, тому що я зараз навіть працюючи, в мене йдуть рефлексія, мене звісно ковбати, тому що треба думати,
але самі великі помилки були якраз і цей, от в переробленні, тому що я собі не давала можливості думати, зупинитися, подумати,
Тобто тут теж яке відшліфування і зрозуміти, бо з першого, коли задаєш питання, можна і помилково людина то відповідає, але в житті, в реальності вона потім діє зовсім по-інакшому, наприклад, або все
від сценарій відбувається зовсім інакший.
Тобто тут те, що говориться одне, а потім в розмові, як взагалі то все відбувається, може інша картинка бути.
Можна просто поговорити трошки більше, та й все.
І далі в тебе буде класна, красива картинка,
бо ти зрозумієш, що з цією людиною відбувається.
Просто дайте собі час, добре?
Дякую.
Добре, йдемо далі.
Ми з вами вже почали вивчати ці адаптації та розлади.
Ви зрозуміли, що ці адаптації, саме як розлади,
вони дуже класно використовуються у психіатрії.
Але до нормального життя люди не звикли так спілкуватися.
І оце все переробили, та бікалі, рвенджойсь туди трошки, це все поміняв.
І вийшло дуже красиво.
І ви вже зрозуміли, що адаптація формується від того,
як взаємодіють діти зі своїми батьками або батьківським середовищем,
або навколишнім середовищем у перші 6 років життя.
І зараз я вам покажу, які є адаптації, куди вони, з чого все починається.
Готові робити собі скріншоти, якщо потрібно, дивіться.
Адаптації для виживання.
Шизоїдна, або пишемо, мрійник.
Антисоціальна, чарівний маніпулятор.
Параноїдальна, блискучий скептик.
Далі, пасивно-агресивна.
Це що в нас там?
Я забула, треба цю табличку відкрити.
Зараз подивлюся.
А, бунтар, точно бунтар.
Мачта думає російською, то не завжди перекладає на українську.
Обсесивна-компульсивна – трудоголік.
І стероїдна – емпатік.
Три адаптації для виживання, три адаптації для одобрення.
Це допомогло вижити, це допомогло отримати своїй родині схвалення.
Далі. Адаптації для виживання формуються від 0 до 18 місяців, не до 3 років.
Адаптації для схвалення від 18 місяців до 6 років.
І адаптація пов'язана з потребою, яку дитина хотіла отримати, але так її батьки її не задовольнили.
Чому батьки її не задовольнили?
Тому що у батьків було мало емпатія, або були батьки відсторонені, хворі, депресивні, працювали багато, не мали можливості бути в контакті з дитиною.
І в залежності від рівня фрустрації дитини визначається рівень або ступень, от наскільки багато цієї адаптації.
А оця адаптація для одобрення, яка виникає від 18 місяців до 6 років, це адаптація, щоб відповідати батьківським вимогам та очікуванням.
І зараз, що я вам покажу? Я вам покажу секрет.
Які батьки були і які сформувалася адаптація.
І трошки потім розкажу про цих батьків.
Дивіться, мрійник, шизоїдна, адаптація для виживання.
Від нуля до 18 місяців.
Стиль виховання випереджальний.
Зараз просто собі це занотуйте, а потім я вам це розкажу.
Далі. Антисоціальний.
Слухайте, мрійник від нуля до шести місяців.
Мрійник від нуля до шести місяців, не до 18 місяців.
Це помилка тут.
Тут 6-12, а тут 12-18.
Вони всі формуються від народження, але щось може бути таке, знаєте, що відбулося в цьому віці.
Антисоціальна адаптація, також вона йде при батьках, які упереждаючі, тобто щось робили наперед.
Паранайдальна, коли батьки були непослідовні.
Дивіться, мрійник, маніпулятор, бриліантовий скєптік.
Ань, слухаю.
Я хотіла, можна на русський перевести «вупереджальний» і «упереджуючий»?
Для мене це як-то дуже похожі слова, я не можу їх панять.
А щас я буду більше об цьому розказувати, про стилі воспитання родителей, і там буде дуже понятно.
Хорошо?
Так.
Отлично.
Далі.
В нас цей бунтар.
Це коли був надмірний контроль.
Далі, обсесивно-компульсивний трудоголік – це акцент на досягненнях.
І далі, істероїдна, емпатик – це акцент на тому, щоб робити щасливих батьків.
Так, ідемо далі.
Тобто, стилі виховання.
Що таке випереджальний? Буду показувати.
Які батьки були?
Уявіть собі батьків, які недостатньо задовольняють потреби дитинки.
Ну, такі, трошки відморожені.
От бачите, тата і мама.
А вони займаються якимись своїми справами.
Ну, такі відморожені, там, зайнятося сильно, або такий процес, мама, депресія.
Не буває такий ноді, тато працює.
І все.
І дитина живе сама собі своє життя, тобто явіть дитинку, яка сама собі, от вона хоче щось отримати від батьків,
але на рівні невербалики вона розуміє, що вона нічого не отримує.
Бо батьків, начебто, не має. Не має. Вони є, але їх немає.
І що вони роблять, ці батьки?
Дитина навчається сама про себе піклуватися, вона їм не показує свої потреби.
Знаєте, говорять, ой, божечки, ти така красива дитинка, в нас народилася, мамка спала все життя.
Я спала всю ночь завжди спала, всю ночь спала.
Мене була післяродова депресія, і ти така гарна, от братві, то я біля нього сиділа, а ти така була комфортна дитиночка, доня.
От іде тебе посадиш, там ти і граєшся.
Ну зрозуміла, яка формується адаптація. Дитина вже нічого не очікує від тієї мамки.
Вона така щаслива, що вона собі спить і тому формується поведінка у дитини, що вона сама себе заспокоює і вона дбає про себе і ще й про маму.
Що негативного в цьому виховання?
Тобто, коли батьки недостатньо задовольняють потреби дитини, дитина приймає рішення, що ви мені не потрібні, я буду сам про себе дбати.
І дитина задовольняє свої власні потреби, увага, за рахунок своїх мрій.
Що її робити? Лежить собі і мріє.
Далі. Оце слово «упережающе». Ти що запитувала? Так, Ань, слухаю.
Да, я по поводу дітей. У мене двоє, і один реально був спокоен с самого рождения, а второй – це був «Ветер с пылью».
Но я ж не можу її місяць-два і почати її тормошити, давай тобі будуть...
Режит себе ребёнок, прекрасно себя ведёт, нічого у нього не болит.
А здесь дуже важливо, угадує ли мама потребності цього ребёнка?
Т.е. вовремя ли она покормила, достаточно ли она своего ребёнка погладила, хорошо ли она на этого ребёнка посмотрела.
В данном случае я гиперболизировала, що сидит сін, например, і мама возле сіна кружиться, а дочка чувствує себе неуместно, не в тему, не нужно, не важно.
Сын – первый, дочка – вторая, і живет сама себе свою жизнь.
Потому що мама думається, то она якось сама справиться.
Ответила на вопрос, Аня?
Здесь жит про контакт більше, да, со своїм ребёнком.
Ну, от у мене первый спокійний, то есть у мене ще не було перед кем кружиться.
Я була максимально мамою, максимально мамою.
А другим наоборот, у мене практично не було декрета, і він був дуже активний ребінок, дуже, ну то есть там глац до глаць було за ним.
І, ну то есть це двоє абсолютно різних дітей. Я вже підстраивалась під них, а не тому, що там, ну я не знаю, я не знаю, стиль воспитання какой-то определенний вибрала.
Ну, це добре. Але можна я всі остальні стіли дозкажу, а далі вже буде розповідно?
Хорошо. Настя, слухаю.
Да, але це може бути не тільки вліяние, наприклад, мамі, дали маміна підхода.
Тому що мій рівненок перший тож дуже тихий, був датуативний.
Але це все сталося після того, як її забрали на неділю в реанимію, і мене не пускали.
І після цього в мене вцепилась, і всю 2 недію ще в больниці.
Просто я в туалет ходила, она у меня так держала на руках, я ее держала, я спала, сидя, держала.
І після цього вона стала дуже тихою.
Ну, і она і була до цього, в принципі, не сильно так активно.
Але можуть ли другие фактори ще тож сработати?
Да, другие.
Ми потім працюємо з цим, да, вже.
Це дуже хороша премерність.
Діти, які забрали в реанимацию, то вже зразу діти имеють отчасти эту мечтательну адаптацию.
Вони должны як-то справитися з гиперстресом, у них чувства будуть на останній місці, вони будуть бояться інших людей,
тому що в силу рождения цих дітей, чим дольше остається рівенок сам без матері в реанимации,
чи без отця, чи в момент рождения, тим більше він уходит в своїй фантазі.
Я вас розуміла, ми з цим працювали довго.
Добре, добре.
Йдемо далі. Оцей опереждаючий стіль, тобто є такі батьки, зараз покажу, ви бачите, які хочуть показати своїм, усьому світу, що вони просто офігенні, що вони супер батьки.
Знаєте, як я кажу, мамка року або татку року. І вони починають на початку дуже сильно надмірно турбуватися про дитину.
І це роблю, і це роблю, і це роблю, і це роблю,
а потім втомлюються.
Ну що, спробуй, це ж дитина, вона ж народилася,
вона через місяць назад не залізе, через два.
І що далі відбувається?
Вони втомлюються від цієї турботи
і йдуть в іншу полярність.
Не звертають увагу на своїх дітей.
І дитина почуває себе відкинутою, непотрібною.
І двоє батьків, вони стають байдужими до дитини.
І з часом вона розуміє, дитина, що вони про неї підклувалися тільки тоді, коли вона народилася.
І дитині потрібно весь час привертати до себе увагу.
Тобто, позитивно, з однієї сторони, при цьому стилі виховання дитина вміє привертати увагу.
Негативно, тому що в неї батьки тут, знаєте, такі погранічні межові були.
Тут вони дуже турбувалися, тут вони від неї відшарахнулися, бо вони втомилися.
Дитина починає маніпулювати іншими, для того, щоб досягти того, що вона хоче.
І є присутні відчуття у дитини помсти своїм батькам, бо ця поведінка батьків була суперечлива.
І іноді може бути в цей час і сексуальне фізичне насильство
Це також, знаєте, там побили дитину, щось відбулося
Тут позитивно, тут побили
Це також до цього призводить
Тобто якщо перекласти на російську мову
В першому випадку, де родителі відстрінені
Це формирується «мечтатель», отстранённі чи відсутніші родити.
Другий вариант – це такі суперродіти, вони як будь-то б упреждають,
вони спешат удовлетворити потребності ребёнка,
устають безбесконечно і становяться отстранённими.
Гиперопекуны, так їх можна назвати.
Ну а вони, може, на якийсь період часу, вони гиперопекуні, такі супер-мамы, супер-папи, ну а как, діти, це ж на всю життя, вони думають, що це там на місяць-другой, вони входять сильно активно в цю д
истанцію.
Всі потребності вначалі удовлітворили, а потім у Сталіна, і дитина забіли, і віддали бабушці через полгода.
І сказали, живі свою щасливу життя.
А ти чого? А я пішов працювати.
Ну, щось таке, такі історії бувають.
З цими батьками ми розібралися, далі в нас непослідовний стиль поведінки.
Тобто, така непередбачена манера поведінки батьків, що вони в цьому випадку роблять.
Вони навчають дитину бути занадто обережними.
Ой-ой-ой, обережно, обережно, зараз падеш.
Це перше.
Друге, дитина не розуміє, якими прийде сьогодні тато чи мама.
Знаєте, у терпії це так, як виглядає, наприклад, якісь деструктивні родини.
Тато трошки випивав.
Або ще щось відбувалося.
І клієнт говорить, я чув, як тато, по тому, як тато іде і шаркає ногами по полу,
який в нас сьогодні буде вечір.
Чи мені потрібно з братом ховатися, бо ця подлюка буде бити маму?
Чи ні?
Тобто отак зростають діти, які підозрівають, вони не знають, що далі буде, батьки непослідовні, або мама, яка піклувалася-піклувалася, що з нею зробилося, а потім вона впала в якийсь депресивний стан
.
і дитина йде там з дитячого садочку з бабусею додому і не розуміє яка мама сьогодні буде відсутня
чи присутня Василю що кажи у мене було переконніше від того який я розумів чи тато випивши чи ні я
розумів який буде вечір бо якщо тато випивши то тоді мама погана тато спокійний а мама тоді наоборот
типу починала коли він випав і це дійсно дуже працювало коли ти щитуєш навіть як мама яка заходить
все ти вже знаєш який вечір що і як і ця емпатія патологічно розвивається тоді це щитувати не
відчувати і це прямо дякую дякую дякую приклад цікаві приклади да тобто ну такі є і батьки вони
Дитина спілкується непередбачувано, тому і називається це непослідовний стиль поведінки.
І дитина боїться весь час, що вона щось зробить не так.
Стає дуже обережно.
Далі, адаптація для схвалення, для того, щоб дитина хоче щось отримати,
і їй потрібно зрозуміти, як цього досягти, як за це боротися.
З цими батьками є наступні.
Надконтроль.
Тобто батьки роблять ставку акценти на фокус, як досягти успіху.
І саме фокус, якщо досягається успіх, ти щасливий.
І вони говорять своїм дітям, ти маєш робити так, як я хочу.
І діти з такими батьками, коли є над контроль, вони завжди відчувають постійну боротьбу.
Знаєте, це отака боротьба.
Позитивно діти стають більш відтравалими, негативно дитина дуже вперта.
І якщо вона не може отримати те, що вона хоче, вона починає казати.
І ти цього також не отримаєш, як і я.
Тут зрозуміло?
Бо тоді виникає оця боротьба з дитиною в віці від 18 до 36 місяців, коли батьки її контролюють.
Знаєте, це перше дитяче ні, коли дитина їй каже, вдягнися, ні, зроби щось, ні.
А батьки починають її занадто контролювати, тому так і формується оцей пасивно-агресивний стиль поведінки.
І дитина дуже часто знаходиться у конфронтації з батьками, і саме через це вона формує свою власну силу.
І ви можете побачити таких дорослих людей, коли ти прийшов, а ти їм щось говориш, а вони тобі ні.
Ти їм щось добре говориш знову, а вони тобі ні.
Ти їм знову щось добре, а вони так, але. І оце так на весь день, і ти відчуваєш себе не дуже комфортно з цією людиною, тобто вони з тобою борються.
І сенс їхнього життя – це боротьба з вами, щоб ви розуміли.
Далі, акцент на досягненні успіху, але через щось інше, через навчання.
Тобто контролюють дітей, як вони навчаються, який в них результат, який процес, тобто ти маєш бути успішним.
Де твої гарні оціночки?
Негативна. Завжди орієнтація у цих людей на успіх, як спроба отримати схвалення.
І дитинка, вона починає весь час показувати, наскільки вона хороша.
Її соромлять і страшать за те, що вона не робить для батьків і виникає обсесивно-компульсивна адаптація.
Тобто від 3 до 6 років акцент робиться на досягнення, батьки хочуть, щоб дитинка була зразковою і дитина вимушена погодитися.
Наприклад, говорить, от такий розумний хлопчик, така гарна дівчинка, вилізь на стілець, розкажи віршика.
Ми так тобою пишаємось.
І останнє – це необхідність радувати людей.
Діти стають надмірно реактивними.
Також батьки можуть бути депресивними, або якийсь процес у них відбувається, а діти стають чутливими.
І дитина весь час задовольняє потреби батьків.
Тобто батьки показують, що нам потрібна ти народжена дитина для нашого щастя.
І діти весь час розважають своїх батьків.
Які є питання?
Що там, знайшли своїх батьків? Красивих? Гарно?
Давайте так, вигрузимо контейнер на 6 хвилиночок.
У парах, хто що познаходив.
Щоб не було більше суми. І далі будемо вивчати все.
Згадайте, як вас виховували, ваші батьки, визначте, що вони взагалі з вами наробили.
А поставте мене з Катєю, будь ласка.
Секундочку, розставляю слухачів.
У вас багатсько.
Катя не буде слухачем. Нас тільки двох поставить.
Ні, Катя слухач.
Вона підтвердить. Ну коротше, зі мною не буде слухачем. Буде активним учасником.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
гініємої інсайти озаріння роздуми
щось цікаве познаходили
Так, Настя.
Піспраця почала відсхідти тільки в 24 року, ми тільки почали сепаруватися.
Тому тут теж, цей страх покинутості.
А якщо б Софію послушать, то она, може, і по-другому сказала.
Я буду жити з тобою до Віку, мені з тобою добре.
Мам, мам, у нього не було скандалу, очень удобний ребёнок, знаєте?
Може, она просто компанейський ребёнок делов-то. Ладно, переходим к тесту. Может, она просто маму любит, это ж хорошо, это ж необязательно проблема.
Не обязательно, но проблема.
Очень хорошо, это не проблема.
Заметили мою, да, часть, но...
Да, да, мы поняли.
Там не досталось от мамы с папой.
А я заметила, да, кто бунтует. Так, Лер, слушаю.
Я зараз зазнала, що в мене-то ще ввремя є почувствувати себе родителям ще не зовсім, не тим, яким хотілося б бути.
Так що до 18 місяців ще є ввремя, є о чому задуматися сьогодні.
Благодарю.
Там і до 6 років є о чому думати, да? Некоторим повезло більше, вони сьогодні послушують семинар і будуть вести себе по-другому.
Ладно.
Попажаю. Благодарю.
Давайте, наслаждаемся. А тепер у нас саме главное – це тест. У вас є тест по этим адаптациям? Давайте я вам буду сейчас читать вопросы. Ставте плюсик-минус. Добре?
Дивіться, тут дуже важливо з цим тестом, Табі Каллер дуже-дуже вабаглива така людина, і він поставив авторські права на цей тест.
Будь ласка, ніде його в соцмережах не постіть, бо він такий дуже переслідуючий і дійсно досягає мети.
А так можете говорити зі своїми клієнтами, ставте плюс та мінус. Плюс, якщо вірно, а мінус, якщо ні.
Перший. Я думаю, що більшість людей легковажні в тому, чим вони займаються.
Друге. Люди кажуть мені, що я тихий.
Третє. Мені комфортніше займатися справами, ніж спілкуватися з людьми.
Четверте. Я тікаю, коли все йде погано.
П'яте. Під час конфліктів я відчуваю, що б я не зробив, буде гірше.
Шосте. Якщо люди незадоволені мною, я почуваюся скривженим і збентеженим.
Сьома. Коли я з іншими людьми, мені здається, що я маю поступитися своїми бажаннями.
Восьма. Я люблю ділитися своїми почуттями.
Дев'яте. Часто я вважаю, що необхідне відстоювати свою правоту.
Десяте. Коли в мене важливі проєкти на роботі, я затримуюся довше за колег, щоб зробити все правильно.
Якщо ти роботодавця. Тож можна відмітити плюсик. А можна 9-й ще? Я не поняла. 9-й? Часто я... Да, я не понимаю. Часто я хочу відстаивати свою правоту. Благодарю.
Я хитрий, я клиз.
Дванадцятий. Мене злить безвідповідальність.
Тринадцятий. Я схильний. Не робити перерп, а одразу переходити до наступної справи.
Чотирнадцяте. Зазвичай я поспішаю через велику кількість справ, яку потрібно робити одночасно.
П'ятнадцяте. Мені складно приймати рішення.
Шістнадцяте. Мої почуття написані в мене на обличчі.
Сімнадцяте. Мені подобається ризикувати.
Вісімнадцяте. Мене звинувачують у тому, що я все сприймаю дуже близько до серця.
Дев'ятнадцяте. Часто мені доводиться робити кілька справ одночасно.
Двадцяте. Я думаю, що важливо бути уважним до всього, що я роблю.
Двадцять перший. Я схильний сумніватися в усьому, доки немає доказів.
Двадцять друге. Мені комфортніше бути на одинці, ніж серед людей.
Двадцять третє. Я люблю порушувати правила.
Двадцять четвертий. Іноді мені буває страшно до смерті.
Двадцять п'яте. Я втомлююсь, якщо занадто довго перебуваю серед людей.
Двадцять шосте. Я відчуваю, що життя – то борьба.
27. Я люблю все робити швидкою і очікую того ж від інших
28. Мною рухаю збудження або цікавість
29. Люди часто розбивають мені серце
Тридцяте. Друзі кажуть мені, що я фліртую.
Тридцять перше. У спілкуванні з людьми я намагаюся все продумувати на декілька кроків вперед.
Тридцять друге. Мені подобається говорити людям, що я думаю.
Тридцять третє. Я часто заздрюю іншим людям.
Тридцять четверте. Я постійно тримаю в голові все, що мені потрібно зробити, тому мені складно дозволити собі просто бути поруч з кимось.
35. Іноді я боюся, що покажу своє справжнє почуття і потреби, і люди не будуть знати, що з цим робити.
36. Мені кажуть, що я перфекціоніст.
37. Я часто перевіряю, чи все вимкну.
38. А про мене кажуть, що я сором'язливий.
39. Я хотів би, щоб люди самі здогадувалися про те, що мені потрібно, без моїх прохань.
40. Мені подобається усамітнення.
Сорок один. Мені часто здається, що я неважливий для людей, які мені небайдужі.
Сорок друге. Коли справи йдуть погано, я пориваюся втекти.
Сорок третя. Мені здається, що мій обов'язок піднімати настрій оточуючим.
Або я часто піднімаю настрій, оточуючи.
Сорок четверте.
У групі людей я намагаюся сидіти тихо.
Сорок п'яте.
Я остерігаюся бути покинутим.
Сорок шосте.
Багато речей мене засмучують.
Сорок сьоме.
Я відчуваю відповідальність за те, що відбувається навколо.
48. Я вірю, якщо я хочу, щоб щось було зроблено правильно, я маю це зробити сам.
49. Я відкладаю розваги, доки робота не буде завершена.
50. Я відчуваю, що змушений робити правильні речі.
51. Я люблю бути в центрі уваги.
52. Я занурююся в речі глибше, ніж інші люди.
53. Я добре вмію розв'язувати проблеми.
54. Мені подобається розважатися серед людей.
55. Коли інші розважаються, я працюю.
56. Мана злить, коли люди не відповідають своєму становищу, тим, ким вони є.
57. Я імпульсивний.
58. Коли я злюся або мені боляче, я намагаюся, щоб ніхто про це не знав.
59. Мені складно дозволити собі бути спонтанним.
60. Я нікому не довіряю.
61. Я стримую своє захоплення.
62. Я підозріло ставлюся до мотивів інших людей.
63. Міністрів.
Мені не комфортно бути у центрі уваги.
64. Люди вважають мене надто емоційним.
65. Я не вмію поступатися.
66. Люблю, коли мені все сходить з рук.
Шістдесят сім. Коли на мене звертають увагу, я відчуваю себе коханим.
Шістдесят вісім. Ненавиджу, коли мені нудно.
Шістдесят дев'ять. Люди часто заздрять в моїй безпосередньості.
Сімдесят. Мені важко нічого не робити.
71. Мені подобається розгадувати хитроумні схеми.
72. Мені простіше зробити те, чого хоче інша людина, ніж чинити по-своєму і при цьому засмутити її.
Зараз рахуйте, будь ласка, кількість тверджень, позначених плюсом за кожною школою.
Творчий мрійник, шизоїдна адаптація.
Рахуйте.
Друге питання.
Третє.
Сьома.
Двадцять друге.
Двадцять п'яте.
тридцять п'яте, тридцять восьма, сорок, сорок чотири, п'ятдесят вісім, шістдесят один, шістдесят три.
Сумуйте, підсумуйте.
Далі, чарівний маніпулятор, антисоціальна.
Четверте, одинадцяте, сімнадцяте, двадцять третє, двадцять восьме,
Сорок п'яте, п'ятдесят третє, п'ятдесят сьома, шістдесят, шістдесят шість, шістдесят вісім, сімдесят один.
Далі. Близькучий скептик. Паранаїдальна адаптація.
Один. Дев'ять. Дванадцять. Двадцять. Двадцять один. Тридцять один. Тридцять три.
40 вісі 52 56 62 65
грайливий опірник а можна не і вернуться у нас предыдущий не успіваю чуть-чуть
Можете йти далі?
Йдемо далі.
Грайливий опірник.
П'ять.
Шість.
Чотирнадцять.
15, 18, 24, 26, 29, 39, 42, 46, 47.
Відповідальний трудоголік.
Десять, тринадцять, дев'ятнадцять, двадцять сім, тридцять чотири, тридцять шість, тридцять сім, сорок дев'ять.
П'ятьдесят.
П'ятьдесят п'ять.
П'ятьдесят девять.
Сімдесят.
Ентузіаст, емпатік.
Вісім.
Шістнадцять, тридцять, тридцять два, сорок один, сорок три,
П'ятдесят один.
П'ятдесят чотири.
Шістдесят чотири.
Шістдесят сім.
Шістдесят дев'ять.
І сімдесят два.
Порахуйте, будь ласка, по кожній шкалі.
Хто останній був?
72 начебто.
Ні-ні-ні, яка посада?
А, посада емпатік.
Рахуйте, будь ласка, за шкалами, що в кого вийшло.
Аня, слухаю.
Я хотіла просто в шокі.
В шокі от чого?
Я ніколи не думала, що у мене така високая шкала емпатичності.
Я все-таки думала, що я манипулятор і трудоволік, і бунтар.
Как раз манипулятор, трудоволік і бунтар – одинаковая шкала у всіх трех.
Я емпатик – вообще практически в два раза більше.
Я ніколи не думала, що у нас таке емпатичне.
Ну, це більше про радость других людей все-таки.
Окей, Василю, слухаю.
Чарівний маніпулятор 10 і емпатік 8.
Марійник, трудоволік по четвіручці.
Добре.
Ви порахували кожен свої оціночки?
Пішли пообідуємо, повертаємось в 30 хвилиночок.
Доброго? Смачного!
Дякую! Смачного!
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Да, чайок. Вірні, не чайок, коллоген.
Коллоген – це добре, Аня.
Це сила.
Так, добре.
Занітували свої результати?
А можна питання?
Можна.
Поки все підключаються.
Це навіть, скажімо так, не мій питання.
Мені часто його задають люди, не особо осознанні.
Те, хто практично ніколи не був в терапії,
Зачем мені це треба?
Ось смачте, зараз, зная, то є вже якась глибінна знання про психологію, про кочинг, про все, я зараз вижу, да, свої драйвера, я вижу свої психотипи, то есть я понимаю, як це роботає, потому що я в ць
ому осознанно і обізнана, так скажімо.
А вот є клієнт, для того, щоб я проведу їм цей тест, він введет в свої три ведущих роли і скажет, і що мені з цим робити? І що? Я предвкушаю цей вопрос вже просто.
І можна у нього спросити, що ти хочеш з цим робити?
Тобто ми ж не заставляємо його, іди сюди, ми тебе зараз робимо тест.
Ти спрашиваєш, у тебе є проблема?
А в чому у тебе проблема?
А він, наприклад, розказує у нього там определенне,
він багато робить, менше чувствує, а думати взагалі не може.
Наприклад, вступати на публіці не може, тому що для нього це продумати.
І ти говориш, а хочеш з цим розібратися?
Він говорить, а хочу.
І далі постепенно йдеш за контрактом і робиш.
І все.
Ну, мені просто в соцсетях такі прилетають випроси.
І, ну, то есть я не приглашаю к себе.
То есть це не мій клієнт, він не приходить ко мене за допомогою.
А я не знаю, а зачем тобі це?
А не мій малючий ВП, а зачем тобі це треба?
Ну, якщо тобі треба, значить, ти задаєш випрос, да?
Він задаёт вопрос, йому вже інтересно.
Да, йому інтересно, він може піти в тестування.
Ну, і можна спросить.
Да, що мені тепер з цим робити? Таке удивлённе лицо.
Понимати, що у тебе є, якій ти по житті.
Понимати, чому ти, наприклад, все время подозрівака,
чому ти шарахаєшся от всього, чому ти не доверяєш миру.
Понимати, чому люди з тобою коммуніційною не хочуть,
Якщо у тебе параноїдальна адаптация високая, то другим людям з тобою тяжело.
А, навіть, ну, як люди ж часто, ми ж парні, ми ж хочемо жити довго і щастливо в парі.
І якщо без конца твоєго партнєра прилетає, що у тебе є тільки одне твоє мнення,
чи ти пассивно-агресивний, то тоді ти розумієш свою боль, розумієш, чому у тебе є історія.
І менюєш її, і все.
І не менюєш.
Хорошо, така встречний вопрос.
Можна ли поменять вот эти базовые настройки,
которые у нас до 18 месяцев формируются?
Нельзя их поменять, Аня.
Эти базовые настройки, их можно понять, принять
и жить с ними долго і счастливо.
Якщо я параноик, да, то есть, если я постоянно...
Ну, в следующий раз, когда разговариваєш,
ну, гипотетически, да, я сейчас вспоминаю...
У меня параноик, кстати, самый маленький, если що.
Да, ну, я на всякий случай...
Я пам'ятаю одного дуже, я не знаю, одну семейну пару,
де він йдет і без конца віщає, він йдет і без конца віщає,
а вона вже вся бледна і зеліна, вона никак не може успокоїться.
Тому що він віщає, у нього є тільки його одна точка зрення.
І це допомагає видеть даже вот цю семейну динамику і сказати,
ну смотри, ти без конца говориш, ти без конца, у тебе є твоя точка зрення.
А она емпатик, да, он подозревает, а она емпатик, їй чувств хочеться, ей хочеться вот этих обниманий, вовлечения.
Ну, ти понимаєш, що у твоїй жены є проблема, да, є.
Ти її любиш, да, люблю.
У нього проблема в відношеннях з тобою, да, а какая проблема?
Ты слишком много говориш і считаєш, що у тебе є одна точка зрення.
Хорошо, ти хочеш жити зі своєю женою довго і щастливо, да, хочу, замечательно.
Вот посмотри, для твоїй жени дуже важливо, щоб ти не вищав, а радував її.
Сделай щось хороше.
А, ну, поню, пошов, делай.
Ну, а вопрос, він же може таким образом предавати себе?
Ну, він не такий, це не його естество, це не його суть.
Ну, Аня, ну, якщо він хоче бути в відношеннях, реальність життя такова, ну, вона такова, да?
Нам необхідно підстраиватися друг под друга.
Ми не живем в раю, ми не живем в пони-единорогах.
Якщо це його така суть, і він, наприклад, чи вона приймає рішення, що я відстану від свого мужа, як в цій парі, помніте, о чому я вам говорила, і буду ходити гулять зі своїми подругами, і все.
Ну, то є, понятна, на що-то менше можна соглашаться.
На що-то ти можеш согласиться, ти розумієш, що так створилася твоя життя, такі у тебе були родители, ну, ти так вижив, ну, що робити, така реальна життя.
а по совместимости лучше всего это все-таки разнополярные люди или это если и стероидом
на самом деле часто притягивается полярная полярная все таки там где вот это чувственная
да как вот про эту пару я не зря вам ее привела которая она говорит боже мой ну я думал меня не
Ну, я прийшла, я його хотіла так поразити, я йому такий романтичний ужин. А він каже, їдло, дай мені нормально, звари мені борща, що ти мені усімаєш?
Що ти мені усімаєш бетмен?
А, що ти мій за молекулярну кухню? А вона каже, боже, я так хотіла, я так хотіла його вразити. Я йому зробила день народження, це вже наступний випадок, а я ж сиджу слухаю, мені ж цікаво, знаєте,
думаю, як людина зробила.
«Я йому в перший рік наших стосунків
весь всю кімнату кульками
і дату його народження кульками».
А він зайшов і вийшов.
І вона знеміла.
Вона просто неміла.
Вона була в шок-контенті.
159 шариків.
Його ім'я, його возраст.
А він, бідний, увидел це все і спугався і вийшов.
І що робити?
А вона проплакала піввечера. Каже, я з тіких грошей дурна витратила на цього. А йому мої кульки як мертвому припарочка.
А нарциси — це хто з них? Или це взагалі другое?
Це другое. Ми щось про адаптатию, а не про ТСМ-5. Так, Настя, слухаю.
Хорошо, як би ми не підстраивались, але нутро ж лізет.
А ми такі всі осознанні, а нутро то все ровно лізет.
Грубо говоря, от у мене МПА, трудоголик і манипулятор на одному рівні.
Ну, типо, значить так, ребята, ну, или делаємо, по-моєму, сразу,
или я знаю, де ваша точка G, про манипулируйте, все ровно, сделаємо, по-моєму.
Тобто як би осознанно предупреждати, чи що?
Не, ну, якщо видіти, що є якій-то процес, і інші люди валять вже від вас, уходять, відбігають вас, з вами не остається,
треба розуміти, що, можливо, німножко стоїть притормозити?
Не, так не валять.
Це добре, все.
Такого трудоголика, емпата, можна свалити.
Це я вважаю в трудогалізм, щоб не видіти никого.
І тебе теж стоїть уважати, а не видіти.
І тебе вилічу, мені так добре. І тебе вилічу. Спасибо.
Юр, слушаю.
Я, поки у нас пауза була, зробив тест. Быстро.
Вот. Кому удобно.
Какі у мене можуть бути наказання?
Що це мене можуть посадити за таке?
І то як? Штрафи больші?
От ви говорили порушення авторських прав.
А що таке?
Сделав просто тест быстро, щоб удобно було кликати.
Тому що я писав в столбик, у мене от 73 получилось.
Я один плюсик перепутав.
І мені було впадло потім считати математично.
І ти зробив тест тепер со всіми, ти прям програму написав.
Да, полністю програма вже готова в сайт.
Можете проходити просто кнопочка.
Да, дуже класно, я вже прохожу.
Я можу тільки розрадоваться, що в нашій групі такий талантливий, гениальний Юр, ні пість нигде.
Тобі Кайлер, він дуже жистокий мій насправді.
Коли він попадає в реальній життя, і починається з суждення авторських прав.
Нас правда реально про це предупреждають.
Якщо ти не проходила обучення у нього, якщо ти не заплатила мене багато гривень,
Лучше не вкладывай. Ну, вот так вот. Друзьям отправь, нам отправь. Я могу порадоваться за тебя.
Ну, не делай этого.
А що, мені цікаво по файту ти сьо там?
Юра, не дурей. Знаеш, є вещи, вот там, де можна развлекаться, а є, де можна просто получить по шапке.
Они такі, вони неприятні. Вот Джулия Хей, я тебе скажу сразу, да, она дуже жестока со своїми опросниками.
в транзактном аналізі, а тетушка
очень с хорошими границами.
У них граница простроена, Юра,
нам так никогда в жизни не снилась.
І Таби Калер очень
в этом хорош. Поэтому
нас просто нам настоятельно рекомендую,
когда мы где-то что-то используем,
писать ссылку
на этих авторов. Обязательно.
Тест там или опросник
продуман, придуман
гениальным человеком.
А, типо, якщо це буде продумано гениальним чоловікам, це навіть є, у мене ІІшка вже це зробила.
Підвільна к особистність адаптати Джойсона, він там матеріал з курсу.
А ціни Джойнс це бікалі, почав, адаптовано Джойнсом, ось так правильно.
А, ну короче.
А вкладачка черга, да, ну ти є, ну шо я могу сказати, ну гениальний парень, мужчина молодой, молодец, горжусь, горжусь, молодец, спасибо.
Скажіть про драку, як там буде, мені інтересно.
Юр, ну, це правда, я не люблю це. Оно мені скучно, знаєш, мені не краще тратити на це всякі, а ти, а не, а оно, то мені безразлично, як оно. Це ж у тебе буде не у мене, да? Я не люблю такое. Я тебе
предупредила, делаю, як знаєш. Лен, давай. Олэн, кажи, що там?
А у мене вообще получилося так, що я сначала думала, що у мені одні адаптации, а по тесту вийшло вообще абсолютно другое.
Це так могло повлиять, допустим, соціальна життя могла так на мене повлиять, що я думала, що на інші вещи, а тут оно мені показало все ровно, як Настя говорить, моє естество.
Дякую, ще знаєш, що може бути, може бути процес психотерапії хороший,
либо змінення соціальних условий.
Ну, наприклад, Настя, тебе вспомню, да, там, наприклад, жила б ты там замужем за екстра-богатым человеком
или с пассивным доходом, который у тебя там XXX, гипотетически.
Не знаю, Настя, ти там що-то вже возмущаєшся?
Я не працювала ні дня.
О, о!
О!
І ми б вичеркнули у Настеньки трудоголика.
Я думаю, що не.
Я б творила, так я впахивалась, встала, надо за шкирку, а так б я творила.
Це з другого вообще состояния б було.
У мене б біля, як для жінки, біля біля закріта,
Я б розслаблена, не з тревоги, не встала і пошла роботи. А я б пошла роботи. Творила б, лагодійний фонд б відкрила, альтруист був мій там вообще кайфував.
Да, Настя. Утром б там не в 7 утра вылезла на роботу, а пошла себе.
А в 10 вечера, в 10 утра с девчонками б встретилась, кофе б пила, в час дня с клиентом б встретила, пообщалась бы.
Да, прощайся, все, виписали.
Це все по-другому. Це мій фантазер з дитства.
Да, ми поняли, якась там адаптация, тут же ведущая.
От кормюшки раз в три часа нужно було чем-то себе развлекати.
Олен, відповіла все? Є відповідь на питання?
Ну, да, але тепер буду сидеть, розбираться з цим уроком заново, коли його вложат, исходя вже з тесту, тому що до цього все складувалось совсем по-другому.
будем смотреть будем смотреть дальше можна пересмотреть Давайте тепер ідем в описі давайте
зараз же підемо в опис до всього тут же буде красиво з усіма схемам із усім да взагалі зараз покажу вам
О, погнали.
Описи.
Оцей шизоїдний творчий мрійник, шизоїдна адаптація від 0 до 18.
Дивіться, в чому є проблема.
Дуже жорсткий критикуючий батько, внутрішні, у людини.
І дитина, дитина, внутрішня дитина, вона захищається від цієї батьківської фігури і втечею.
Тобто, якщо ми спілкуємося з цими людьми, в них виникає дуже сильний критикуючий діалог.
Вони себе завжди за все критикують.
І вони, ну, їм добре наодинці, бояться інших людей, да, їм не дуже прикольно бути з багатьма людьми, люблять, коли до них хтось підійшов, зробив перший крок.
Тут такі професії художники, драматурги, оце, Настя, те, що ти казала, да, я б творіла.
Добре працюють, бо терплячі і роблять те, що треба.
Всередині – це підтримуючі люди.
Насправді, з цими людьми іноді буває і легко бути, і нелегко бути.
Бо вони поважають і свій простір, і простір інших людей.
Але є складність.
Якщо вони не заземлені, то вони дуже багато відлітають у мрії.
Це зрозуміло? Будь здоров.
Дуже дякую.
На здоров'я.
Дивіться, про контакт.
Давайте, щоб ви знали, як з цими людьми заходити в контакт.
Поведінка, мислення, почуття.
У результаті терапії або коучингу вони стоять живими, енергійними і радіють життю.
Отримали у дитинстві послання, що вони ок тільки тоді, коли сильні.
І коли вони не помічають своїх почуттів.
І вони все життя залишаються сильними, щоб нічого не відчувати.
Як ви з цим усе?
Як на ісповіді.
Як на ісповіді, бачиш.
Наізнанку вивернули, витрусили, показали.
Витрусілі показали, отакі в нас адаптації. Дивіться, що важливо. Важливо встановити оцей контакт з людьми через поведінку і витягувати їх поступово назовні, на ці почуття.
І треба у стосунках їм навчитися піклуватися про себе.
Це важливо, так само, як вони піклуються про інших.
І потрібно їх навчити заявляти свої бажання.
Найважливіше для цих людей, що їм потрібно усвідомити,
Мати власні почуття і бажання – це нормально.
І що інші люди мають зважати на їх почуття і потреби.
Бо вони занадто комфортні.
Це зрозуміло?
Так, Лєр, кажи.
У мене тут, Флата, одразу питання.
Якщо далі десь буде відповідь, то так кажи, що ми ще про це поговоримо.
Ми всі попроходили цей опитувальник, вже хтось ділився, хтось не ділився результатами,
але здебільшого 1 плюс-мінус ключовий якийсь та адаптивний цей момент і 2 паралельні.
Десь 9 і по 7 були еквіваленті, десь всі 3 плюс-мінус рівні.
як тоді правильно обирати цю стратегію контакту?
Типу поведінка, мислення-почуття чи почуття-мислення-поведінка.
Бо воно ж в будь-якому з цих адаптивних варіантів по-різному. Це треба тестувати?
Так, треба тестувати. Ліпше тестувати, бо ви бачили, наприклад, у вас спочатку була фантазія,
що у вас там от така схема за цими дверима, а тут, можливо, вас трошки по-іншому,
бо ми ж всі люди, ми іноді виглядаємо у суспільстві ліпше, ніж ми насправді себе відчуваємо.
Ну, умовно дивитись, де легше оця відбудова проходить, туди і рухатись.
Так, це важливо, просто дивитися.
Так, далі. Чарівний маніпулятор.
Де цей чарівний маніпулятор? Зараз покажу.
Дивіться, що тут виключений, бачите?
Слухайте, до речі, я все одно вас запитаю.
Ви взагалі пам'ятаєте оці такі замальовочки красиві?
Бачите, отакі темненькі і тут темненькі.
Це означає контомінацію, тобто зараження дорослого.
Дорослий, він думає, що він не має оцих почуттів і має не говорити про свої потреби.
І оця стрілечка, це означає, що дуже великий внутрішній діалог.
А оця стрілечка, такий, знаєте, маленький, як дитинка, вона йде.
Тобто людина не бачить своєї дитини.
За схемкою.
Тут за схемкою.
Коли ми дивимося на цього чарівного маніпулятора.
Батьківський стан цих людей, він виключений.
Бо їм потрібно досягати своєї мети.
Так відбулося.
І правил не існує.
Іде зараження дорослого.
Оце темненьке зараження.
А оця така стрілечка – це виключення.
Тобто менше має батьківського стану.
І зараження дорослого для того, щоб досягати якихось своєї мети.
Дивіться, до речі, слухайте, чарівні маніпулятори – гарні продажники.
Гарно продають бізнес.
Бо в них виключений оцей батько, активна взаємодія, вони вміють очарувати.
Вони можуть бути там, де треба, агресивними, але дуже чарівні, коли їм щось потрібно.
Вони можуть або залякати, або спокусити, як Настя сказала, я зараз вам надавлю на ту точку, все буде так, як я хочу.
І вони можуть і продавати, і розкручувати нові проекти, і вони можуть маніпулювати, але їм іноді буває важко самоорганізуватися, тобто треба прикладати зусилля для того, щоб відбулася ця самоорганіза
ція.
Далі. Контакт зі світом. Показую. Поведінка почуття і мислення.
Що їм потрібно робити? Головна рекомендація моя – думати про довгострокові наслідки своїх дій, бо вони живуть оцим моментом, який в них є сьогодні.
Їм потрібно думати, що буде потім.
У дитинстві вони отримали послання, що вони ок, якщо вони усіх перехитрять.
Прикольні люди, бо можуть бути на декілька кроків попереду інших людей.
І важливо встановити контакт через гру, але викривати спроби їхнього обману.
Казати, я тебе бачу, я бачу, що ти зараз мені щось зробиш, я бачу, я бачу твою маніпуляцію.
І важливо зрозуміти, що вони насправді хочуть.
І зрозуміти, що для них є недосяжне.
Чому вони хочуть перехитрити вас?
Для змін. Важливо дати їм зрозуміти, що ви їх не покинете, бо вони такі, бо їх кинули.
Розумієте, люди стали такими антисоціальними, бо вони бояться, що їх покинуть.
І треба їх навчити, що вони можуть знайти тих людей, які будуть їх любити.
І важливо їм зрозуміти, що якщо люди для них доступні і що для них роблять, то їм потрібно бути таким самим у відповідь, а не прикидатися.
Навчання у коучингу, що їм потрібно задовольняти свої потреби у співпраці, а не в маніпуляції.
все натували записали зараз ще одну адаптацію для виживання і далі зробимо вправу добре
так що в нас далі а йшов нас далі а далі в нас блискучий скептик параноїдна адаптація
Дивіться, тут в нас дитина вже пішла на прогулочку, вона виключена і є зараження дорослого батьківським оцим станом.
Є стан не відчувати, бо відчувати це небезпечно.
Вони уникають інших людей, як і трудоголики.
Вони люблять самотність або контакт з одним-двома людьми.
А вони готові бути проактивними або чекати, коли хтось зробить інший крок.
Класно думають, успішні в тих сферах, де потрібно бути дуже пильним до деталей.
І вони можуть прикольно щось організувати і люблять контролювати ситуацію.
Вони хочуть, щоб всі все робили правильно, але тільки правильно, так як вони уявили.
Контакт зі світом, мислення, почуття, поведінка.
І тут оця інтеграція почуттів, коли вони розуміють, що вони відчуваються,
що люди відчувають поруч з ними, веде до змін у поведінці.
Вони стають менш підозрілими людьми.
У дитинстві вони отримали послання, що вони ок, доки доскональні і сильні.
І так себе поводять, щоб ніхто їх не дорікав.
Так, Лєр, слухаю.
Влад, хочу тебе попросити ще раз, щоб розібратися.
У нас було там, де творчий мрійник, оця контомінація, це зараження.
Я просто зараз почула, що ти зробила акцент, що в цьому блискучий скептик
Дорослий заражений батьком, а там було якось навпаки. А можеш ще раз?
А там подвійно.
Подвійно. Там і дитина, і дитяча контомінація, і доросла.
Ні, я маю на увазі, дивись, коли вони отак поєднані.
Ну давай на прикладі той, що зараз у нас був. Блескучий скептик.
У нас хто там? Батько, дорослий і маля. І в нас батько і дорослий перехресна.
Хто ким заражений? Чи воно немає?
Зараз покажу.
Типу, оцей нижній дорослий заражений батьківським чи навпаки?
Батьківський стан заражений дорослим? Отут у мене питання.
Зараз, Лєр, дуже класне питання. Дивися. Оце ти маєш на увазі, так?
Ну, як приклад, так, і там же ж в нас вище також було.
Як приклад, дивися, давай.
Тут зараження двох, тобто дорослого заразила.
Ну, я зрозуміла.
Так, і батько, і дитина.
Ага.
Тобто дорослий, він заражений.
І батьківськими усвідомленнями, наприклад, що світ, весь світ небезпечний.
І дитина, її зарадження, я не можу просити про допомогу, бо я самотній, мене все одно ніхто не почує.
І тому дорослий, він діє так, як собі мають ці усвідомлення.
І ще тут дитина взагалі, вона відсутня, ну такий стан як відсутності, розумієш? І ось ось показаний внутрішній страшний критикуючий діалог, тобто внутрішній батько говорить, у тебе нічого не вийде
все одно, ти один, ти нікому не потрібен, тебе кинула.
Тут батьківський стан пішов, він відповідає за правила.
Дорослого заразила дитина, яка каже, плівати, я хотіла на ваші правила, мені потрібна увага.
І тому дорослий, замість того, щоб думати про свої наслідки, про те, що він буде
далі отримувати у житті
дорослий. Він каже,
буду мати
в цю секунду задоволення,
а все інше
потім. І така
пустінка людина.
Це зрозуміло.
Тут, дивися,
заразив батько.
Він каже, тільки завдяки
правилам ми існуємо
в цьому житті. І дорослий
каже, так, слухай, зараз я вас
Я всіх навчу, і тебе, Лєра, навчу, і Юру навчу, як треба робити, що не можна то робити, і Насті розкажу, як жити.
Короче, я вам всіх зараз, я вас всіх просвіщу, проповідуваю вам.
А оцей дитячий стан, вона не радіє ця дитина, вона як використована, тобто забагато батьківського і мало радості в житті.
Я пояснила?
Так, все, зрозуміла тепер, дякую.
Ага, добре, добре. Олен, кажи.
А в мене питання. У мене, наприклад, по опросинку вийшло, що однакова кількість у творчого мрійника і черєвного маніпулятора, якщо я правильно все повідповідала.
І тут питання, як може бути одночасно дуже сильно критикуючий батько і виключений батько?
А тобі треба ще раз пройти цей тест і подивитися по цих питанням, де творчий, що в тебе все одно домінує.
Знаєш, може ти відповідала, була в цьомусь неуважна.
Юра ж нам зробив вже систему, то ми тепер можемо ще раз пройти всі тести, передиватися і отримати достовірну, як нормальні люди, інформацію.
Юра, треба було зробити раніше, що ти відвіщала?
що я тут займався я би зробив а я ж не знала о боже гені кваліфікацію не знала наступного разу
буду вказати тести робити неможливо щоб було декілька одна адаптацій що вона одна повинна бути
Ну, якщо чесно, Олена, можливо, але є все одно для виживання більш відуча, є якась ліпша зараз на цей стан життя, наприклад, якщо подивитися на тебе, то я думаю, що в тебе все одно буде мрійник біль
ший, ну, бо я вже бачу, ніж що там в тебе друге?
Маніпулятор.
Чим маніпулятор? Ти мрійник більший, ніж маніпулятор.
А от Настя, якщо подивитися, ти вже є досвід, ти вже розумієш профайл, розумієш, якщо там чогось рівно, все одно буде якась домінуюча.
Настя як накрутивний трудоголік, він вилізе все одно.
Це зрозуміло?
Так, ми з вами пройшлися три адаптації для виживання.
Три, що нам потрібно робити з цим блискучим скептіком, потрібно дати йому важливість довіряти іншим людям і сказати все, зупинися, досить контролювати інших людей, бо люди від тебе побіжать.
Зараз робимо вправо, розбиваємося в пари і починаємо рефлексувати відносно свого, що ми там познаходили.
Так, Лєр?
Поки нас розбивають, Влад, підкажи, будь ласка, у нас вже виходить 3 адаптації на виживання і 3 адаптації на схвалення.
Якщо проходити оцей опитник, у нас буде топ-3 якихось, якщо сукупно дивитися.
Чи може про щось говорити, про клієнта, наприклад, якщо в нього всі 3 тільки про виживання або всі 3 тільки про сподобатись?
Це взагалі ніяк нам нічого не говорить, правильно?
Погано, він пройшов тест, нехай проходить ще раз.
Розуміло, дякую.
Лада, хочу, в момент уже було це питання, тобто у нас по-любому, по тому тесту є 6 адаптацій,
і одна якась адаптація буде та, що до 18 місяців, друга, та, що до 6, так?
Так.
Дивимося просто, яка, куди відноситься, і так більше розуміємо про самого клієнта і про себе.
А на скільки хвилин ще підскажіть?
Так, на скільки, 12 хвилин, по 6 хвилин.
Можна заходить в кимната.
Дякую за перегляд!
Дякую.
Я піду, візьму собі води.
Скоро буде все добре?
Так, звісно.
Дякую.
Дякую за перегляд!
Скажіть мені, будь ласка, чи все зрозуміло?
Чи є якісь питання?
Що не зрозуміло?
Так, Сніжан?
Знаєш, Владо, це таке не питання, це таке, скоріше, усвідомлення.
Ще раз проговорено, до речі, ми проговорили в зомфінаті.
Я сказала, ну, мені також там, знаєш, зробила тест, і ці всі назви, от в мене там по виживанню, параноїдальна ця штука типова, до 18 місяців.
Я розумію, що поки нам щось не подобається, так, яка там у нас адаптація, може би ми хотіли іншу.
От сьогодні ми говорили про те, що я думала, що в мене така адаптація, а по тесту виходить інакше.
Ми ж б підсвідомо хотіли якусь інакшу адаптацію, може нам більше подобається чисто по названню, я не знаю.
Але коли, я думаю, ми приймаємо якийсь факт про себе,
що таке адаптація?
Ну, це адаптація, це не добре, це не погано, це факт.
І коли ми приймаємо цей факт, тоді ми можемо ним оперувати.
От я, добре, я тепер знаю про себе більше інформації,
що я хочу з тим зробити?
Якщо ми будемо виводити це в прийняття і в світло свого сприйняття,
і розуміти, що нами керує, я думаю, що ми з любою адаптацією
можемо якнайкраще розкритися і реалізуватися в тому житті.
І в стосунках, і в професії, і в загалі.
Так.
Якщо так, ти боротися, приймати.
І це круто, тому що ти розумієш, це те, що тобі допомогло вижити.
І як я кажу, давайте з того, що нам допомогло вижити, зробимо гарну монетизацію.
Це вона ж, ну ми ж ми сильні в тому, типу, круто.
Ну і все, я кажу, ну добре, є такі от сильні сторони.
Я називаю це взагалі сильна моя сторона, так?
Давайте її монетизувати.
Я більше знаю про себе, як я на цьому зароблю гроші.
Що? Просто так страждала, чи що?
Добре, клас, молодці.
Давай, Настя, що там в тебе?
Ну да, це лишній раз підтверджують мою теорію,
яку я все занесу, що будь-який, як називаємий,
вроді недостаток, чи якась там ситуація,
взагалі все можна зробити в силу і в плюс.
Наступно, Наступно.
Наступно так.
Чому, знаєш, коли говорять, в чому смысл жизни, я вот пришла к тому,
що смысл жизни – познання себе.
І чим ти більше познаєш себе,
тим більше становиться прекрасне і інтересне цей мир.
Я, наверно, добавлю ще одне слово.
Не тільки познання, але і принятие себе.
Така чудесная, я замечательна є,
вот такой вот себя принимаю на этом деньги зарабатываю живу дальше да и если хорошо умею
это понять осознать то в принципе другим людям со мной нормально окей давайте давайте тоді
далі ідемо готові да що в нас там далі з нашими адаптаціями ми поговорили про выживання
Зараз в нас іде адаптація для одобрення. Показую.
Пасивно-агресивно. Тобто, надмірно контролююча поведінка батьків або одного з батьків, або така гіперопека.
І це є зворотня реакція дитини. Тобто внутрішній діалог контролює в голові, а дитина завжди в цьому внутрішньому діалогі бунтує.
З однієї сторони є подвійне зарадження дорослого, і люди активно з однієї сторони взаємодіють і люблять бути частиною групи, родини.
Але коли потрібно вирішити проблему, вони говорять, ой-й-й-й-й-й-й-й, щось мені робити, як мені жити.
І знаєте, оце таємне бажання, візьми проблему, вирішення проблеми на себе.
Тобто чоловік, який може сказати, слухай, що мені сьогодні вдягнути?
А що мені сьогодні? Які мені рубашку-сирочку вдягнути? Білу.
Ні, біле не хочу, давай сіру.
І оце так буває, так оця пасивно-агресивна ситуація.
Добре, що є контактом зі світом?
Поведінка, пошуця, мислення.
І головне, вони думали, слухайте, в пасивно-агресивної адаптації є драйвер старатися, намагатися.
то вони думають, що вони окей, тільки поки вони намагаються.
Але старайся і не завершуй.
Вони намагаються мислити, але несправді і не дуже розумієш, про що вони там говорять.
Всей час, весь час вони бунтують.
Що з ними потрібно робити з цими людьми, взагалі, щоб їм легше було, ну і нам легше з ними жилося,
їм потрібно трошки про них потурбуватися.
Їм потрібно пояснити, що для виживання у суспільстві не треба боротися.
Якщо тобі щось потрібно, тобі потрібно про це попросити.
І попросити інших людей задовольнити твої потреби.
І це класно з ними працює.
Далі, наступна адаптація, улюблена у багатьох у цій групі.
Переходимо до трудоголіків.
Відкривай.
Контамінація в батьківському стані, батько заразив дорослого, багато батьківських послань, що так треба, що треба робити правильно, що це важливо, уникають великої кількості людей, комфортно на один
ці або двоє-троє людей, дуже класно розв'язують проблеми,
Самі можуть ініціювати контакт, відповідальні, тримати слово, складність у визначенні, де закінчується їх відповідальність.
Тобто люди, які беруть все на себе.
Хто там трудоголік, досить брати все на себе, не робіть того.
І дивіться, що в них є проблемою.
Проблемою в тому, що вони не вміють радіти досягнення.
Люди не вміють відпочивати. Тобто, склали там, попрацювали, склали речі, знову взялися до роботи. Тобто, дуже важко, дуже важко, їм дійсно дуже важко гратися, сміятися.
Контакт, мислення, почуття, поведінка.
Ой, їм треба розслаблятися, оце головне.
У дитинстві вони отримали послання, тільки вони окей, доки вони досконалі.
Слухаю, Сніжа.
У мене, Влада, питання.
Ти кажеш, що в них мислення, почуття, поведінка.
От всіх трудоголіків.
У мене по тесту вийшло, що я трудоголік.
Але в мене, якщо ми пам'ятаємо, як ти мене опитувала, в мене поведінки.
для виживання виживання Сніжан от головна починай з виживання з виживання в мене параноїдальне Ну ти
добре що там в параноїдальне контрольор Ну і все от починається тренда це ж я думаю що
моїм домашнім трохи тренда від мене що вони мені таку трохи отаку тільки чоловік витримує
Таке життя. Починайте завжди аналізувати з виживальної, але можна і так, і так зайти. Якщо ти працюєш, то можна і так до тебе зайти.
Мислення – така історія. Все одно в тебе більше дій.
У мене більше дій, я взагалі чоловік про дію, тому мені коутінг дуже подобається, бо я кожна на кінці, що робити будемо.
А що робити будемо, це дуже добре. Головне, знаєте, що людям дозволити більше розслаблятися, тобто трошки не робити, а бути. А що робити?
а нічого не діляться ніжо а що треба навіть коли вишиваю я люблю вишивати це дуже класна для
мене форма ну знаєш від того всього контрольорсу і трудогалізму да дуже гарна форма таке взагалі
відновлення так я що ти думаєш я просто вишиваю я ж паралельно дивлюся розумні лекції і записую я
роблю три справи одночасно я тут вишиваю тут дивлюся і тут ще записую це триндець це страшна
Жінка, страшна жінка, добре, давайте повернемося до тих,
кого тут емпатік, що з емпатіком, о, Василь зразу активний,
дивіться, контомінація дитяча, тобто заразили дорослого,
люди сприймають світ через почуття, і якщо їм погано,
вони думають, що усьому світові погано, можуть спілкуватися,
взаємодіяти з людьми, бути душею компанією,
емоційно реагують на людей, відчуваються іноді як теплі, приємні,
люблять розважатися або придумувати щось, як вони проведуть час
і бажають, щоб з ними так само поводилось.
І організацію зроблять, і психотерапевти, до речі, і куча гарні,
бо вони знають, як імпатувати іншим людям.
Дивіться, в чому є проблема? Вони надто чуттєві, реактивні.
І вони замість того, щоб сісти і подумати, і щось зробити, вони реагують на складні ситуації через почуття.
Іноді буває інфантильність.
Відкрита дверя почуття, двері ціль мислення і двері пастка поведінка.
Тобто їх потрібно стимулювати, щось доводити до кінця.
Що їм потрібно зробити для того, щоб їм легше жалося?
Трошки пригальмувати почуття і дати їм зрозуміти, що треба робити.
У дитинстві вони отримали послання, що вони окей тільки коли радують інших і догаждають інше.
Потрібно почати догаждати собі і важливо їм донести, що вони значущі, що вони цінні, їх люблять навіть без постійної уваги.
І знаєте, що в них ще є? Іноді стан, що я правий, це не завжди означає, що це дійсно так і є.
Тобто, їм потрібно розвивати спокій і власну силу.
Добре, зараз давайте знову поєднаємося в пари і обговоримо наші основні адаптації для одобрення.
Так, Лєр, слухаю. Розбиватися будемо на 12 хвилин, по 6 хвилин в кожну.
Підкажіть, будь ласка, Влад. А чи може бути якийсь типу внутрішній конфлікт? Одна частинка занадто чуттєва, а інша частинка
там більш логічна там про дії і так далі і як тоді тут будувати комунікацію з однієї сторони
з іншими людьми буде розкриватися чуттєвість а в вечному просторі буде розкриватися більше якась
дієвість розуміло дякую давай
можна мне вопрос пока отбивають нас комнаты водку тесту я действую первое через действие
ну по тесту первому который мы проводили там двери наши двери а в конце то есть я эмпат
причем не 11 баллов по импат должен адаптация для выживания какая манипулятор но все значит
тогда и по-другому заходим по тесту через эти двери смотрим на адаптацию для выживания она
буде більш ведуще, вконтакте. Але якщо, наприклад, Аню сьогодні зашквал чувства і енергії,
ми розуміємо, що зараз у нас вулиць емпат, і треба, якщо підстроиться, тоді йдемо вже в другое.
Ідемо в чувства, потім в мыслях, потім в поведення. Опять-таки у мене все завістить от состояния,
хто сьогодні більше проявився. Але ведуще, конечно, адаптация для вживання.
Так, Сніжан.
Лада, ти звернула увагу, що дивися Сніжан на адаптації по виживанню.
В мене там параноїдально, я подивилася по слайдах.
Там теж мислення, почуття, поведінка, теж навпаки.
Що робиться? Що-то не пойму, що я.
Значить, Сніжанка, я на те визначила.
Може, ти подумала про щось, а потім зробила?
Так, я тоді, коли ти мене питалася, я перше, що зробила, подумала.
Ти сказала, як пройшов твій ранок, а я згадала, як пройшов твій ранок, подумала, я сказала, ну я не можу все розказати тобі, це було перша речня.
Ну, значить, бачиш, я зробила помилку, це окей, тоді ти подумала, потім ти що там в нас подіяла, а потім відчула.
А люді, я все одно маю на другу.
Мерсі, мерсі, мерсі, Волода.
Кошечки, знаєте, це ж ти сидиш, слухаєш, слухаєш, слухаєш, слухаєш, так?
Ти кажуть, це зроби милилися, і що?
Але це гарний кейс для нас, тому що то, що я подумала, було невидимо.
Це гарний кейс для нас виявився.
Красиво, красиво, так, це гарний кейс, дуже гарно.
Так, Василь, кажи.
А де я прогуляв, як визначити, яка для виживання, яка для схвалення?
Ну перші три для виживання, другі три для схвалення.
Ага.
О, думаю, що це перші три для виживання.
Так.
Все, понюю.
Так, Лєр.
Влада, повторите, будь ласка, по дверям для антисоціального.
Зараз посмотрюю і повторюю.
Поведінка почуття мислення.
Так, все, 12 хвилиночок, повертайтеся.
Так, а що нам треба зробити ще раз, а то ми поки проаналізували свої виживання.
Залістувати остальних три вида адаптации для одобрення і понять свої зони росту заодно, що я буду робити по-другому, які у мене шаги будуть в адаптации.
Захватися в кімнату.
Дякую за перегляд!
Субтитрувальниця Оля Шор
як Ви так Сніжан Лада я хочу просто подякувати одну хвилинку бо я маю йти а я хочу подякувати я
потім додивлюся і за сьогоднішню лекцію за весь курс я закохалася в транзактний аналіз Ну реально я
однозначно буду стукати в двері до вас особисто там з приводу подальшого якоїсь можливості і я
не знаю для мене коучинг став ще більше дієвіший завдяки транзактному анализі тому що мені
значно легше бачити тепер клієнта розуміти його краще розуміти себе це просто мастхет я не знаю
як відносити там інші викладачі але в цій академії для мене особисто ваш предмет став
найулюбніші найулюбніші це просто бомбічний предмет я дуже дякуюсь правда дякуюсь була дуже рада
познайомитися і вчитися вас ви теж геніально це навзаєм дуже дякую була рада зустрічі буду рада
бачити ваще проходит заждай рада пока так а не слухай у меня вопрос это даже уточнение я прошлась
по всем шестерым позициям у меня не клеится только трудоволик мне кажется что трудоволик
Сначала думает, делает, а потом только чувствует.
То есть мысль, действие, а потом сидит, зачем я туда, ну как бы, то есть у него вот эта мотивация идёт заслужить внимание.
А у вас, получается, написано о том, что сначала мысли чувствуют, и только потом поведение.
То есть получается, вот трудоволика, поведение, это слабое, вот это третье.
Я зараз объясню. У нього родители говорили ему вначале, подумай, как ты достигнеш успеха.
Когда ты достигнеш успеха, мы будем рады. Мы тебя оцениваем только за хорошие оценки.
Да, але почему чувства, да, впереди?
Ну, потому что они в любом случае, они могут чувствовать. Трудоколики разве не чувствуют?
вони чувствують, вони можуть сесть, вони можуть подумати, вони можуть і зробити.
На мій взгляд, здесь у них все три двери у трудоголиків, вони будуть ведущі.
Вони будуть і делать, вони будуть і думати, вони будуть і чувствувати.
Тому що, якщо вони привыкли добре робити, то їм необхідно всі ці вещи збалансувати в той чиїна степені.
Але вони вначале подумають, що вони зроблять, потім вони почувствують по цьому поводу, що вони зроблять,
А потім пойдуть і доведуть до конца.
У них один із драйверів –
бути совершенним і достигати цели.
Мені кажуть, наоборот,
трудоголики менше всього чуствують.
Вони об цьому думають саму последнюю.
Ну, я просто скільки трудоголика видела?
Менше всього чуствують мечтателі.
Вот вони менше всього чуствують.
Все остальні у нас, получается,
три адаптации для вживання.
Они самі жісткі.
Все, що касається второго блока адаптации для одобрення, там вже можуть, ну, там попроще делать.
Ну, для мене у трудоволики більше всього вопросу сейчас вызвали.
Тож, мне кажется...
Аня, а я думаю, що об цьому можна сообщити Тоби Калеру, с ним вести дискуссию, це ж його концепція.
Якщо б це моя була, я б, можливо, дискуссировала.
Не, я спрашиваю, може бути де-то там, або опечатка була, поэтому уточнення.
Нет, нет, я зараз вам покажу, у него вообще там, да, с этими, честно, то, что мне кажется, в каждый момент времени, это я так думаю, да, выспались мы, не выспались, у нас что-то может немного видоизм
ениться по нашему состоянию, и, возможно, в один момент мы лучше думаем, в другой момент мы лучше чувствуем, а в третий момент мы просто действуем, всё зависит от стресса.
Ну, мы берём просто это за основу и работаем с этим, и всё.
Аня, трудоголики, кажуть, я не знаю, почему,
а потом объясню себе.
Но я так чувствую, що надо пойти це і сделать.
Такого у тебе ніколи не було?
Не, у мене, наоборот, мисли.
Мне надо це сделать, мне надо доказати,
мне надо заработати.
Я йду, а потім сижу і така,
я зачем я це роблю?
Ладно.
Ладно, мисли.
Але все равно у трудоголиков
нет проблем з поведенням.
Ну, це сто процент.
Ну, у них нет проблем з поведенням,
потому що це адаптация для одобрення.
Все, що зв'язане з одобренням, більше проработане, ніж адаптації для виживання. Там вже получше справа, постарше. Це ж вітрі вже не той, вже від трьох років і більше. Лір, слухаю.
У мене тут виникло питання. Ми коли починали, здається, ми з Юлією про це працювали, ми коли починали, то я для себе якось через призму досвіду завжди визначаю,
що в мене на першому місці поведінка, потім мислення і вже десь там почуття, як за закритими дверми, і там, де найглибинніша трансформація.
Зараз по всіх тестах, по всьому в мене відущі антисоціальна адаптація і тоді в мене виникає питання, бо тут контакт зі світом, поведінку, почуття, мислення.
Чи може людина, перший варіант, не усвідомлювати, що є для неї найбільш вагомішим, а друге, чи може навпаки навмисно проходити якісь оці двері, наприклад, з почуттями і йти одразу в мислення.
Я думаю, що людина, в залежності від травми, знаєте, ми будемо з вами сьогодні критикувати цю концепцію.
Наприкінці я залишила критику.
Давайте я вам скажу одразу і відверто.
Так, ця концепція допомагає. Вона допомагає дещо про себе зрозуміти.
Але якщо її критикувати, вона занадто узагальнена.
Вона дійсно занадто загальнена, бо в кожної людини свої травми, свої історії і свої зміни. Одна людина може про це говорити, інша не може про це говорити.
Це концепція, вона відома, вона класна, вона базова, але сюди не включили ані нарцисичні розлади.
І є таке поєднання, вони взяли виключно DSM-5, оці шість адаптацій, але, слухайте, розладів вже набагато більше.
Тому, на мій погляд, це так, знаєте, як я кажу, вход в тему.
Ти сів собі, подивився, зрозумів, але ви, кожен особистість, кожну з вас своя історія, в кожну з вас свої травми.
Виберіться за концепт, а якщо потрібно поглибитися, більше усвідомити, попрацювати, як Лір, ти кажеш, з почуттями, добре, буду з цим працювати більше.
Це я більше знаю, Влад, з точки зору роботи з клієнтами, для того, щоб розуміти, що це може бути не прям 100% стратегія.
Не 100% стратегія, це рекомендовано. Вони його спростили, вони сіли його, бо там, знаєте, там більше іноді буває питань.
Але як для початку зрозуміти, чому в тебе дисконнекшн з цією людиною, щоб не віддавати другу, так? Ліпше це зрозуміти, добре?
Дякую, Мила, дякую.
Ага, Лен, слухаю.
Я хотела сказати більше спасибо, Влад.
Очень интересно, очень познавательно для мене все такое.
Мне просто нужно убежать.
І мене слышно?
Да, конечно.
Зависли все.
Мне нужно убежать часика на три.
Я понимаю, що на сессії, на уроки не встретимся.
Поэтому спасибо большое.
Буду пересматривать.
Да, дуже рада знакомству.
Це дуже взаємно. Сіле і процвітання бізнесу.
Добре, давайте далі. Я вам зараз покажу таку цікаву тепличку, вона мені подобається.
Дивіться, в чому. Тут адаптації для виживання в нас ідуть.
Шизоїдна. Василь, це для тебе, ти мене питав. Де воно?
Далі. Параноїдна і антисоціальна.
мрійник, маніпулятор і блискучий скептик.
Що тут є? Основний досвід дитини.
У адаптації для виживання це порушення базової безпеки та довіри.
Про що думає ця людина? Мене немає для іншого.
Батьки, якщо підсумувати, відсторонені депресивні перевантаження.
Далі, для параноїдної, світ небезпечний, це вже зрозуміло, батьки непослідовні, тривожні і контролюючі, антисоціальне, я сам за себе, хаос, відсутність смеш, зрада і довіра, тобто такі хаосні батьки.
Далі, адаптація для виконання, одобрення. 18.6. Що я маю робити, щоб мене любили? І тут вже є оці очікування батьківські, і як люди отримують умовну любов, тобто не безумовна, а умовна.
Обсесивно-компульсивна, трудоголіки, а будь правильним, контроль-вимогливість, емпатики, будь помітним, підкріплення уваги за те, що ти даєш багато емоцій, пасивно-агресивна, не будь з собою напряму.
Завжди боротьба за оцю владу. Кажи, Василю, кажи.
Во, які тести треба проходити, коли починаєш відносини, а не нумеролога?
А бачиш як. А в нас же Юра вже зробив офігенний тест, до речі. Класний, Юр.
Юр, я подивилася, молодець взагалі. Ну, не маю навіть, що сказати.
Просто красавчик, красавчик. Я рекомендую, пройдіть Юрин тест.
Дивися, але тільки вноси там вправки. Хто зробив, що зробив? Не джойнс, не дури людей.
Ну, це повиправляй. Добре?
Що джойнс? Який джойнс?
А ти там щось написав таке, що там опитувальник джойнс, то не джойнс.
А, ні, то заїжка з презентації все згенерила.
Ага, добре, вона не клавить.
Просто не диктуйте мені, я її скажу, вона все поміняє.
Ну, там, подивися, треба виправити, хто головний в цьому процесі.
Дуже класно зробив, дійсно.
Ідіть, подивіться, переробіть собі тести, скільки не роби,
будете дивитися хоч кожного дня, за 10 хвилин проходьте тести.
І там дуже класно згенерувалися і ігри, і заборони, і все-все-все.
Красиво, Юр, молодець.
Якщо щось треба звертатися, я вам зроблю дуже багато чого.
Дякую, дякую.
Просто офігенно, офігенно, красунчик.
Далі, ідемо.
Що ми робимо з оцією, цією інформацією?
Давайте подивимось, які є сильні сторони, якраз двохвилинки,
і які в нас є слабі сторони.
іде і підемо відпочивати.
Значить, дивіться, емпатик, як може заробляти гроші?
Чуєте емпатики?
На емоційній відкритості, на здатності швидко встановити контакт,
слухати інших людей, бути з харизмою, в творчості, в гнучності,
тобто монетизація неймовірна, ризики вразливості,
Нестабільність, залежність від уваги інших людей, іноді важко думати, драматизація.
Драматизація для емпатиків – це дійсно дуже притаманно.
І перевантаження стосунками.
Трудоголик.
Відповідальність може доводити справу до кінця, надійність, структурованість, висока працездатність.
Беремо їх на роботу і нехай працюють люди.
Трудності з відпочинку, перегнічення почуттів, жорсткі вони трошки можуть бути у роботі, перфекціоністи, виснаження, контроль замість контакту.
Скептики, гарне аналетичне мислення, уважність до деталей, здатні бачити ризики, автономня, таке під питанням, і сильний внутрішній контроль.
Недовіра, підозрілість, закритість і труднощі з близькістю.
Мрійник. Дуже класне і глибоке мислення.
Велика креативність.
Самі можуть доводити і робити свою роботу.
Повага до меж, внутрішня автономія.
Вони можуть бути на самоті більш-менш спокійні.
Ризики. Соціальна ізоляція.
Ізоляція, труднощі з ініціацією контакту і зникання у стресі.
Тобто, якщо ви переписуєтесь з творчим рейником,
він замість того, щоб вам писати якісь послання, буде сердечко відправляти.
Або емоджі.
Це його максимум. Не хвилюйтесь.
Хлопці, дівчата, якщо замість там або плюсик вам поставить, це про них.
Пасивно-агресивний бунтарі, чутливість до несправедливості, критичне мислення, креативність іронію,
труднощі з прийняттям рішень і перекидують відповідальність.
Лір, кажи.
Чогось згадала, вирішила поділитись, ти сказала про ці смайліки.
В мене колись в житті був керівник.
Я йому пишу питання, а він мені постійно, це стандартно було,
Три якихось смайлика, там вішенка, цвіточки, ладошки, і ти сидиш і думаєш, я задала питання, що я маю, вибачте, зрозуміти по оцих трьох смайликах.
Ти ще раз питаєш тобі плюс. Зато, якщо в тебе такий керівник, ти дуже класно вчишся вирішувати питання сам.
Потім просто факт написав, отримав оці цьомчики, смайлики чи ще щось, і все прекрасно.
Оце дуже прикольно.
Лєр, слухай, зараз скажу дуже цікаву, але сумну історію.
Їм було настільки важко виживати, що вони економлюють ресурси навіть на розмові.
Або вони занадто втомлені, бо в них це подвійне перевантаження,
контамінація і безкінечні внутрішній діалогі.
Добре, ми з вами цю табличку закінчили майже до кінця.
Тобто харизма маніпуляторів і імпульсивність дуже велика.
І вони не будують антисоціали, глибокі стосунки,
бо вони не завжди відповідальні, бо в них були такі предаючі їх батьки.
Давайте зараз відпочинемо, повернемося у 13 хвилин усім смачного, хто їсть.
Дякую за перегляд!
Повертаємося і продовжуємо.
Чи є якісь питання? Чи все зрозуміло?
Скажіть, що там не так в тесті, я зараз швидко виправлюю, бо я так і не зрозумів, що там не так.
Зараз.
опитувальник особистих адаптацій джойнса Тобто тут потрібно написати так третя редакція шесть
адаптацій та бікалір там треба ще у дужках додати і все додати та бікалір дайте напишу
правильна була а би ой обі калер так правильно зараз зараз алена не не не одна
одна Л зараз тут за матеріалами зараз Юро зачекай
третя редакція так тут є
Добре, слухай, залишай, нехай буде третя редакція, але треба все одно його там показувати, тобі Кайлер, зараз тобі покажу, Кайлер, та воно все одно тільки для вас, мені не страшно, тобі все одно, то
добре, Тобі Кайлер, К, А, ось, дивись.
А, Кайлер. А воно є в презентації, так?
Я, я, я, я. Худе висіпати.
Добре, скажіть, будь ласка, чи є якісь питання?
Влада, я хочу все-таки спросити. У мене адаптації виживання три одинакові, по 9 балів, во всіх трьох.
Одобрення – 10 балів трудоволік, а виживання – всіх по 9.
Я два рази проходила тесты вручну і у Юры.
А я предлагаю, Олі, ще завтра утром проснуться і посмотреть.
Хорошо, спасибо.
Мало ли так бывает, да?
Бывает, иногда в один день все по 8 или по 7, или по 9, да?
А в другой день бывает, ты уже проснулся с другим состоянием,
это більше чувство, що у тебе це, ну, як-то інакше.
Ну, Юра, я прям швидко пыталась відповідати, навіть повторилися.
Так, от в цьому є смисло, тому що вони дуже рідко, коли міняються.
Ну, дивіться завтра.
Так, добре, чи є якісь питання зараз, чи немає якихось питань,
чи все зрозуміло, чи не все зрозуміло, взагалі, як воно для вас,
чи подобається, чи не подобається ця штука з цими адаптаціями.
ще раз підсумую
як ми сходимо
плюсики, ой, дякую, Аня
вже зрозуміла, в нас мрійник
сьогодні виліз
добре, дивіться
на всяк випадок нагадаю вам
дивіться
адаптація, контакт, ціль, паска
зробіть собі скрін
якщо у вас його немає
Добре, з цим поговорили. Далі переходимо до інформації мовою ТА.
Дивіться. Якщо ми говоримо про мрійника. Двері відкрита – це поведінка. Іноді відкриті двері – поведінка, зокрема, бездіяльність.
Мінімум контакту – право бути острень, драйвер – бути сильним.
До них важливо, щоб їх ніхто не чіпав.
Замість того, щоб запитувати цих людей, що ти зараз відчуваєш,
треба запитати, що ти зробив у цій ситуації і як ти це розумієш.
Тобто ви зрозуміли, відносно дверей контакту, ви замість того, що ти там подумав або що ти там зараз відчуваєш, потрібно починати контакт завжди з питання, яке відкриває ці двері.
Тобто для мрійника, що ти зробив в цій ситуації, як ти це розумієш і потім вже, що ти відчуваєш.
Це зрозуміло? І так по кожній адаптації ви можете працювати.
Наприклад, з маніпулятором також в нас є поведінка відкритої двері.
В нас є декілька драйверів, які для них актуальні, бути сильним та старатися.
І основна їх потреба – контакти, рух.
І вони входять в контакт через дію, але вони провокативні.
Що з ними робити?
Де їх питання?
Що ти зробив?
Знову ми запитуємо через двері контакта.
Будь ласка, що зараз пропоную вам зробити?
Зробити невеликий тест.
Ну, такий, знаєте, тесту спілкування.
Говорити про свої основні адаптації, коли ви починаєте говорити.
В мене такі основні адаптації, ви вже їх виявили.
І задайте питання так, щоб від дверей контакту дійти до дверей пастки.
Тобто, наприклад, що ти зробив, що ти подумав і що ти відносно цього відчуваєш?
Зможете так зробити?
Дуже швидко.
6 хвилин по 3 хвилинки в кожну сторону.
Беріть будь-яку свою адаптацію, або адаптацію для виживання,
або адаптацію для одобрення, і так просто задайте питання,
щоб це запам'ятати.
Ладно, можна ці питання ще раз?
Так, дивіться, давайте я вам ліпше замість цих питань оцю табличку покажу.
Ви берете, дівчата і хлопці, оцю табличку і за цією табличкою запитуєте,
яка в тебе адаптація, і далі просите щось розказати іншу людину, один-два речення,
і ви тренуєтесь, як зайти через контакт, куди йде бути ціль,
І далі до цієї останньої двері.
Наприклад, трудоголік.
Що ти про це подумав, що ти про це відчув і що ти зробив?
Або мрійник.
Що ти зробив, що ти про це думав і що ти відчув?
І дивіться, як на третіх цих дверях відчуває себе людина.
Чи є якась зміна емоційна, поведінкова, тілесна?
Добре?
Давайте не на 6, а на 8 хвилин.
Формую кімнату.
Добре.
Влада перевірте будь ласка чи все правильно там по вашим канонам зараз по нашим канонам
Слухо, по моїм канонам, коли зберігається перший оцей тест, то він вже не виправляється.
Там внизу він протест поміняв, поставив оцей Пол Велер, Тобі Кайлер.
У той самий період Тобі Кайлер паралельно рухався з боку транзакційного аналізу.
Чи де він мав поміняти?
Не знаю, щось в мене нічого.
бо так воно не дуже поміняло але нехай воно буде якщо воно давайте покажу а ти дивися боже як
красиво ну молодець молодець все чи де треба поміняти не тут красиво нехай так буде так
гарно я думала тут зверху бачить треба теж поміняти якщо треба буде вже так дивися ти
тут зробив опис все красиво ми всіх авторів казали все гарно молодець тут навіть
ви я вон та ви шо Боже яка приємна новина дякую ласка
так на 8 хвиленочок включаю кімнату давайте
Дякую за перегляд!
Дякую.
Не ваш файб, а ваш отдыхати, пока є така можливість.
У вас мікрофон вовлічен.
Нет, у мене просто відпочивається, що я обучаю взрослых.
Якщо кому-то потрібна моя допомога чи підтримка, вони мене позовуть.
Обичай так думаю, ходить, контролюти, говорити,
«Ей, діти, а що це ви тут робите? Я так не люблю».
Тем більше я сама була студентка, і я знаю, що ми іногда можемо обсудити
якісь дуже глубокі питання інтересні.
І тому, коли тут вдруг зашов преподаватель,
я считаю, це не завжди до місця.
Мадо зову?
У нас вчора так і було.
Так?
Да.
Глава заходить і говорю,
ми обсуждаємо інтимні віщі.
Говорить, які інтимні віщі?
На учебі немає, немає, немає.
Не розрешає від розкрывати то, що ми обсуждаємо.
Добре, чи є якісь питання?
Ми щось не дуже всі зрозуміли, що нам треба робити.
Ми пройшлися, взяли ситуацію і по ній ми пройшлися, але нам треба було звіритись?
Чи ми так само, в нас іде спочатку мислення, потім що ми відчуваємо, потім поведінка?
Чи нам треба було що? І коли ми дійшли до кінця?
Добре, Йоль, треба було ще раз повторити інформацію відносно дверів контакту, але вже знаючи свої адаптації.
Наприклад, ми беремо адаптацію, яка є провідна для виживання.
Що там, Йоля, є провідна?
Ми взяли, так, трудоголік у мене є.
Трудоголік, добре, ми відкриваємо цю табличку.
Що перше за трудоголиком?
Мислення, начебто?
Мислення.
Добре, ми запитуємо, розкажи, що ти думаєш про якусь ситуацію, наприклад, ти розумієш, що ти прийшла на коуч-сесію з трудоголиком, і людина починає щось розказувати, що вона думає про якусь ситуацію,
ти її далі чуєш, я не знаю, будь-яку ситуацію, розкажи.
Ну, я розказувала там зараз, що я хочу відкривати бізнес.
Ого! Круто, да? Ти що? А коли в тебе така думка появилася відкривати бізнес?
Та, ну, давно. Просто зараз прийшов час.
Ага, круто, добре. Тобто ти думаєш, що ти будеш відкривати бізнес.
А що ти відносно цього відчуваєш? Які в тебе почуття?
Ну, я сказала, що трошки лячно. Ми, в принципі, приблизно так і шли.
Мені трошки лячно, бо це нове, але нормально.
Лячно, боїшся? Добре, то коли тобі лячно, коли ти це будеш робити?
А я вже роблю.
Молодець, от так оце йдеться.
Треба було просто взяти...
Добре, ми це зробили, ми так і зробили, значить правильно.
А далі що?
А далі треба подивитися, наприклад, якби ти мені сказала,
ой, мені так лячно, і робити я це боюся, то треба було ще декілька задати, можливо,
питань, таких, що б тебе підтримало, як би тебе підтримало, де ти бачиш ресурси,
і потім, а коли ти то зробиш? Все, я зрозуміла. Зрозуміли, так, тобто потрібно просто ще раз
пройти по питанням, подивитися, як ви їх можете використовувати в роботі, і все.
Настя, віжу тебя.
У мене, відео, ми зазвіли не на вживання, а на проявлення.
Подовження, да.
І в мене озвучили, що бунтарь, я пошла повідинка, і коли я зашла в почерчі, пошла опер.
А перша, яка йдет до вживання, на Мринек, і, відео, я переключаюсь.
То есть я вже попала, то есть там йдет на цель – це мислення почуття, а в Пасхі наоборот.
В общем, ти можеш так і так на вторій двері застрять, в третью і закритую.
Поэтому мені прийшовся відкатитися опять в контакт, в поведінку, поговорити в поведінку і перейти уже через мислення.
І все, я стала думати, як, що, ну да.
Смотрите, Настя, це як раз то, о чому ти говориш.
Якщо ви почали обовжджати одобрення, першу адаптатию, може возникнути дискоммуникація.
Чоловік вийде в адаптатию виживання, і у нього тут абсолютно другая дверя.
Тому, якщо ви це осознаєте, просто перейдіть на адаптатию виживання.
Я так перешла, тому що у них перший контакт, і там і там поведінка.
Ну, і я, грубо говоря, перешла назад в поведінку і вже пошла далі.
Молодець, правильно зробила.
Тобто пробуйте, експериментируйте, наслаждайтесь, тестіруйте,
дивіться, як краще роботи.
У мене найголовніше, я дала вам механізм взаємодії з іншими людьми,
як ви можете з ними встановлювати контакт.
От і все, то працюйте.
Добре, давайте зараз подивимось, як ми взагалі цих людей лікуємо,
що з ними робити, як їм допомагати людям.
Хочете дізнатися чи не хочете?
Чи може нехай так все і буде?
Нахай собі так і живуть, дізналися і що, потім будемо казати, а навіщо, а не навіщо, а просто так, давайте, ідемо, ідемо тоді дивитися, слухайте, погнали, беремо з мрійника, пасивні чекають, але самі
знають, що будуть робити
Ідемо до рис. Дивіться, вони насторожені, вони надчутливі, але це закривають. Вони всередині собі, вони схильні до самоти, вони уникають конкуренції і їм потрібно бути наодинця.
Але іноді є інші комбінації, вони можуть конкурувати з іншими людьми. Драйвер. Бути сильним. Іноді буває радувати інших. Старайся дуже рідко.
Заборони. На мій погляд, я не бачу тут заборони, не існуй.
Часто в цих адаптаціях існує заборона, не існуй.
Не будь близьким. До речі, не роби, тут я думаю, що це більше помилка.
Не відчувай, не належ, не радій і не будь дитиною.
В них багато є рекітів, вони можуть бути депресивними, сумними, іноді бути неадекватними і відчувати себе небажаними.
Ігри, пни мене та оранжерея, тобто вони знаходяться в стані, формують стан для інших людей, коли з ними комфортно.
Сценарій ніколи, інколи завжди.
Так, що, Василю?
Про такі оранжереї.
Оранжереї – це коли інша людина біля тебе ніяк не змінюється, Василю.
Оце в мене вчора була дуже цікава історія.
В мене, наприклад, є клієнти, і їм потрібно робити конфронтацію.
А клієнти, що вони говорять?
Ви ж мій психолик, ви ж маєте мене любити.
А що ви мене засмотили?
Я до вас на сесію прийшла, гроші заплатила, то я хочу чути тільки те, що я хочу чути.
Оце називається, якби, як завжди казала, кивала гривою головою, кивала, боже, яка гарна думка, така класна, така офігінна, а людина не змінювалася.
Оце називається гра оранжере.
До речі, подивіться уважно на мене і запам'ятайте,
ваша задача – не давати радість безмежно вашим клієнтам,
а ефективно з ними працювати.
Це зрозуміло.
Майте силу конфронтувати людям.
Дала відповідь на питання?
Добре, йдемо далі.
В них є глибоке бажання, щоб про них подбали.
Вони обожнюють, коли про них дбають.
Якщо у вас хтось з оточення, з клієнтів, має цю адаптацію,
в них є така фантазія, дуже люблять, коли про них дбають і про них думають.
Вони можуть бути іноді пасивними, іноді.
Яка фінальна розплата? Вони можуть залишитися наляканими, покинутими, хоч виглядають як дорослі, але вони можуть мати депресивні стани і хворіти.
Допомагайте цим людям виходити в контакт і давайте більше радості цьому житті. Добре? Запам'ятали?
це важливо допомагайте людям нехай радіють цьому життю далі вам приклади наводити чи не наводити
чи вже і так все зрозуміло що це наводити чи ні наводити ну слухайте приклад дуже простий
наприклад клієнтка виросла у родині де мама мала депресію а батько пішов з родиною
Обоє емоційно відсутнє, обоє недоступнє.
Дитинство провела з бабусею, яка хворіла на рак.
І вона жила в постійному стані, що у бабусі буде рецидив.
На сесіях ніколи не вступала в контакт.
Мовчала, коли були складні теми.
Не заявляла ніколи про свої потреби.
Не будувала, їй було 30 чимось років, коли вона прийшла і вона не мала ні з ким нормальної довготривалих стосунків.
Стосунки закінчувалися за тиждень, залишалися відрізаною від радості від своїх власних бажань.
Нормально? Така реступніка.
Добре.
Далі. Говоримо про маніпулятора.
А маніпулятора зараз покажу.
Тут у нас маніпулятор. Ось.
Вони нетерпимі, імпульсивні, трошки безвідповідальні,
а не завжди навчаються на помилках.
Драйвери. Бути сильним, старайся раду інших, бути досконалим.
Забронене, належне, відчувай смуток, гнів, страх, не довіряй, не будь близьким і іноді не роби.
Рекети, фрустрація, депресія, тобто вони можуть бути подавленими, коли в них щось іде не так, і вони депресивні.
Ігри, нехай вони поб'ються, боржник, роззява, якби не ти.
Тобто, якби не ти, в мене б все було добре.
Сценарій, ніколи завжди і майже.
а не живий сюди не йде тут треба дивитися ну в загальному сенсі начебто як ні але на мій погляд так
я думаю що при цих адаптаціях виживання оці перші мрійник і антисоціал вони можуть мати заборону
не живе. Але за та бікалером, ну чомусь не написано, але в моїй практиці це часто бувало,
бо ця дитинка маленька і треба було виживати. Так, Настя, я тебе скажу, що маніпулятор і моя там була
не живі. Тут то саме десь в моїй терапії було усвідомлення непрямого вказівки навіть мами,
Типу не живи своє життя, будь прислугою, бла-бла-бла.
Тому тут прям воно.
А це найбільше в мене оцей маніпуляторчик, то прям мастхерчик.
Таке може бути, може бути.
Добре, дивіться, вони дуже хочуть, щоб їх любили.
Дуже хочуть.
І вони хочуть, щоб вони до чогось належали.
Тобто, щоб в них було своє, це для них дуже важливо.
справжня своя родина, наприклад.
Але захисний механізм, що їх не дуже люблять,
і вони не дуже належать, бо вони дурачать людей.
Фінальна розплата.
Коли вони такі поганці, їх кидають.
І тоді вони потрапляють у психотерапію, кочинг, ще кудись.
Але якщо він не змінився, він каже, що ви ще за це заплатите.
І знову дорачить людей, і знову потрапляє в цю петлю, знаєте, цього сценарію, де його не сприймають.
Коротше, що треба робити з цією людиною? Треба навчити, ну, бути в стратегії він-він.
І завжди, коли ця людина щось робить, знаєте, як вона маніпулює тобою, каже, я бачу, що ти то робиш.
І перший раз, коли це відбудеться, може бути вибух.
Люди не люблять, коли ти їм кажеш, що я бачу, що ти робиш.
Що, Василю, кажи?
А коли ти маніпулятор і, в принципі, ти озвучуєш зразу мотив маніпуляції.
Тобто, ми використовуємо всі ці фішки, архетипи, бла-бла-бла.
Але, типу, зразу говорю, так, мені це вигідно.
Для того, то для того, то твоя вигода така.
Тобто, коли теж оцього маніпулятора використовувати, як він-він,
тоді це буде екологічно і тоді людей не буде.
Це відторгнення, правильно, оскільки я розумію?
Коли ти правдивий у своїй маніпуляції.
Якщо ти дійсно правдивий, то все буде добре.
Це вже не маніпуляція, це називається правда.
Якщо ти хитрюга, кажеш, я тобі зараз приподнісу цю інформацію так,
щоб ти подумав, що ти будеш у він-він.
То тоді інша людина, знаєте, вона говорить ні, ні.
ну просто для прикладу для прикладу якщо розглянути ситуацію зараз Інстаграм використовує
маркетинг та маркетинг використовує болі і точки дотроку та і люди якби не Інстаграм певне до
психологів чи коучів ходило на відсотків 40 менших людей ось і тут з одної сторони це токсично
не екологічно використовувати точки болі типу і тоді пішло з другого сторони от для прикладу
Якби там сама перша моя наставниця не транслювала 10 тисяч доларів на кожну сторіцю а-ля,
то мене б це не зачепило, я б сюди не пішов.
Тобто де тоді є оця межа своєрідної екології і токсичності?
Треба дивитися, ну я думаю так, якщо є брехня, то вона завжди вилізе і все.
Оце моя коротка відповідь.
Настя, покажи.
Ну да, манипуляція, весь маркетинг – це манипуляція.
Весь маркетинг – це манипуляція.
Открываємо, коли род в діалогі з кем-то – це вже манипуляція.
Уже манипуляція.
А вот екологічність, духовність і все остальне – це вже стає за цим.
І, опять же, манипуляція.
Сначала ти даєш і презентуєш.
Я вступаю, скільки проєктов закривала і скільки договорів підписувала.
Я розказую, як вигодна йому, і це тож манипуляція.
І це вин-вин, я сначала даю йому, смотрите, ви получите вот це, вот це, вот це, вот це, вот це, вот це, і він соглашається, і я починаю брати.
А я хочу, і це тож манипуляція.
І тут якраз разниця манипуляція, які, ну, мінусова, є в мінусі, є в плюсьі люди живуть.
І як ти це вже використовуєш? Тут тож.
Триггерні психологи, це тож манипуляція.
І тут дуже важливо, щоб все було він-він.
Да, і ще екологично.
Екологично?
Екологично по отношению, да, к другому.
Любове слово.
Мой сын приходит і говорит, мамочка, я тебя так люблю, так люблю, так люблю.
Я возьму 10 евро, там схожу себе, куплю щось вкрусне.
Це тож, сука, манипуляція.
І тут соглашаєшся, а не соглашаєшся?
Не, ну так ти можеш сказати, сін, а спасибо, що сказав, що я, ти мене любиш, я тебе теж люблю. Десять евро у мене в кошельке, всього хорошого.
Ну да, я і так кажу, і так кажу, свої десять евро. Боже, мені так приємно, що ти мене любиш, але свої десять евро ти вже теж потратила, ще вчера. І теж так можу.
Ну і тут ж манипуляція, ж да, є разні. А вот коли люди страдають, то це вже добить.
Так, треба, щоб не страдали. Йорс, давай. Тоже вопросы, ідемо дальше.
Я, типо, манипулятор. Я це признаю, понимаю і так далі. Для мене вся життя – це манипуляція, і всі ми друг друга манипулируємо.
Якщо хтось скажеш, я не виглядає грані між манипуляцією і не манипуляцією.
Вона где-то є грань на уміння відстаивати чоловікам своїй личні границі, любим із людей.
І для мене манипуляція... Я хочу просто, щоб ви свої згадали.
Манипуляція починається там, що люди називають манипуляція, де ти не готов відстаивати нести відповідальність за ті слова, які ти маніпулируєш.
Тобто, якщо я готов нести відповідальність за все, що я сказав і проговорив, то це адекватна манипуляція.
Якщо я не готов нести відповідальність, то це вже не вин-вин. Я не можу просто розуміти в цю сторону вин-вин. Вин-вин каждый для себе определяє.
Я ж не можу понять, чоловіку це добре чи плохо.
Ну, в моєму представлі, це може бути добре, чоловіку це може бути плохо.
Вот мені інтересно цю грань від вас розуміти.
Грань дуже проста.
Якщо другому чоловіку з тобою плохо, він уйдет від тебе.
Якщо ти без конца делаєш їм плохо, це вже не вин-вин, це раз.
Якщо ти розсматриваєш глобальну концепцію по житті з точки зрення своєю мужською ідентичності,
Одна із сильних сторон, яка є магнітизмом – це спокійство в здорових отношениях.
Либо коли є манипуляція, буде притягнення нездорових паттернів поведення.
Вот ці качели. Ти хочеш качели, тебе качели в відповідь.
І тоді це не буде формувати, удовлетворювати головну потребу манипулятора –
і мати щось своє в довгосрочній перспективі.
Вот і все.
Тому, якщо глобально рассмотреть цей паттерн,
необхідно вместо того, щоб манипулировати,
научитися прямо говорити то, що ти хочеш отримати.
Прямо.
Прямо говориш, я хочу вот це.
Для примера.
Є соціальний рівень потребності, а є психологічний.
На соціальному рівні потребності ми можемо говорити «я хочу це», «я хочу це»,
а на психологічному рівні удовлетворення цих потребностей «я хочу близости»,
«я хочу бути в контакті, в теплоті з тобою».
Це є глибокая внутрення потребності антисоціалу.
Він действительно її розыскиває, він її іщет, він може прерувати контакт,
Він може вважатися обратно, але він іщить цього доверительного відношення.
І тому вмісті грі і маніпуляцій антисоціалам рекомендувано прямо вистраивать відношення,
построені не на цих качелях, а на такій стабільності, спокійстві і частності.
Вот це я називаю стратегією вин-вин.
Ты говориш мне, я думаю, могу ли я тебе це дать, і возвращаю обратно.
І вот так вот формируються здорові, здорові паттерні взаємоотношення.
Дала ли я відповідь?
Ну, тут я согласна, тобто, що мені це важливо.
І тут треба зразу говорити, що насправді на психологічному рівні важливо.
Щас я приведу пример, Юр.
дуже інтересний пример, да, один такой клиентський кейс.
Так на самом деле выстраивает отношения антисоциалу часто.
Хочешь, покажу?
Конечно.
Можете ти себе узнаеш, я ж не могу тебе говорити.
Скорей всего, да, у меня є проблеми з близістью,
типа, ну, я вот даже спостерігал,
у меня є вот такая вот стена,
которая вырисовується на какому-то ментальному уровню,
я не могу її пробити, я її спеціально ставлю,
какой-то защитний механізм, я этого не можу розгадати.
Ну, в общем, если описывать антисоциалу,
якій кісебелі, якія була історія, мати залишила свого сина з батьком в п'ятирічному віці.
Це дійсно такі клієнтські випадки, які були в моїй практиці.
Мама пішла кудись там, в неї була зрада, вона таки не повернулася до родини,
батько постійно заробляв гроші, був на роботі.
І оцей маленький хлопчик в п'ятирічному віці почав сам про себе піклуватися.
Готувати їжу, їздити до школи, яка була в іншому кінці міста або інший кейс.
Батьки їздили на заробітки, кинули свою дитину бабусі і потім повернулися, взяли цю дитину, поїхали заробляти до Москви гроші тоді, коли ця дитина була ще маленькою.
І замість того, щоб заробляти гроші у Москві, вони сказали цій дитині, іди, дитинка моя рідна, сіли там біля машини, іди, або десь сіли на лавочці, кажуть, іди, воно бачиш Макдональдс?
Так, так, бачу Макдональдс. Добре.
«Іде ми машини біля того Макдональдса, дитиня 6 років, інші хлопці, і він дрався за те, щоб заробити гроші батькам з цими хлопцями».
Це називається, це такі дуже сумні і дійсно відсторонені кейси, тобто дитина була покинута, дитині потрібно було виживати,
В одному випадку піклуватися про себе, в іншому випадку приносити гроші батькам, які брали ці гроші, потім витрачали і казали,
«Та, похєр, все одно, що з тобою відбувається, іди працюй далі біля того Макдональдса».
І хлопець знову дрався і так виживав.
Щодо цього це все приводить до дорослого життя.
Тобто, що людина звикла виживати в цьому світі, люди розуміють, що нікому не можна довіряти, вони розуміють, що ніхто про них не може подбати, і вони розуміють і так собі живуть, що їх можуть покину
ти.
І у дорослому житті вони не довіряють людям, які поруч з ними.
І вони завжди маніпулюють у стосунках.
І вони дуже часто під свідомо своєю поведінкою будують скандали.
Ось така історія.
Чи можу я піти далі вже?
І що з ними робити, я вже вам сказала.
Виводьте нечисту воду.
Що, кажи Юр?
Я виводжусь не типу, я не йду в скандали.
Я виводжусь на частину, от мене картинка прийшла, от є оця стіна між мною людиною, яка на ментальному рівні,
і я можу закидувати дуже багато уваги або ще щось, але в мене враження все одно ніби не доходить.
І людина може мені дати багато фідбеку, але все одно ніби відбивається.
Я оцю штуку не можу ніяк, коли її осмислюю, вона проходить осознання і так далі, але фундаментально в мене немає цього відчуття,
типу як сказати по замовчуванню от не цікаво якісь рекомендації нас побачити почути як це дуже
проста Юра вона буде зараз дуже неприємна
чи хочеш її почути конечно звісно коли ти так робиш ти неприємна людина з тобою
не комфортно не робить так це тоді нічого не буду продовжувати да я не буду нічого казати
да рекомендація для антисоціалів для усіх які дійсно я говорю зараз да буде про такий патологічний
процес порушують межі якщо ви зрозуміли що у вас є така составляющая не знаю як це сказати
українською мовою, будьте ченними до інших людей, бо це неприємно, людям некомфортно з вами, вони не хочуть
з вами проводити час, ви будете підтверджувати свій сценарій, що ви залишаєтеся на атецію, а така буде
фінальна розплата, на таке життя. Робіть так, щоб людям було з вами кайфово, дійсно класно, і це, я кажу зараз,
не тільки про антисоціалів чи про когось іншого в цьому житті просто ну робіть так щоб вам з
вами було цікаво щоб з вами було комфортно і вам було добре оце головне все
прийняв дякую дякую дякую що почула добре можна ще питання ні
Близько чи скептик? Дивіться, дуже часто вони одягають маску такого атакуючого, бо вони хочуть усіх перехрестити свою віру.
такі проповедуючі, як я до них говорю.
І вони хочуть дуже змінити світ, змінити людей,
і щоб всі чули їхню думку.
Що в них з драйверами, які вони взагалі зараз,
оці брілянтові скептики, вони ревниві, вони підозрілі,
вони нечутливі до критики, надчутливі,
коли їх критикують або контрольують.
Драйвер – бути сильними, бути досконалими, заборонами, не довіряй, не будь близьким, не радій і не належ.
Вони відчувають багато болю, дуже заглиблюються в цьому процесі як живачка, коли щось йде не так, як вони хочуть.
Багато гніву, багато страху, ревнощів і депресія.
Ігри – хіба це не жахливо?
Ти з ними спілкуєшся, скандал?
в сценарії ніколи поки не.
Що з ними ще потрібно робити?
Тобто їм потрібно просто довести,
що ще цікаво, вони хочуть дуже сильно радіти
і належати до когось,
але вони також не дуже такі бувають приємними людьми
і вони розлякують інших тим,
що вони завжди це перехрещують в свою віру,
таке проповедують, як я кажу.
В них, може, часто буде професійне вигорання,
і іноді людина може відчувати себе на дні,
і вона може відкривати аварійний люк,
вбивати себе, хворіти дуже сильно,
і залишатися на сумоті.
І саме то,
тому що ця людина думає, що я не змогла переконати інших людей.
Слухайте, приклад з практики.
Жіночка росла в родині алкоголіків, і я вже вам наводила цей приклад,
вона мусила, це про чоловіка, а це ще й про дівчинку,
вона мусила щодня прислухатися про того, як і батько йде додому,
як мама йде додому.
Мама її не могла захистити, не хотіла розлучатися з батьком,
оскільки родина жила, сім'я жила в квартирі, яку ніхто не хотів ділити.
Ранки проходили більш-менш нормально, бо всі були на роботі,
а ввечері тато і мама поверталися п'яні і відбувалися скандали.
У дорослому житті ця жіночка знайшла собі чоловіка, який її відштовхав, тобто він багато працював, а іноді він приходив, коли вона з ним не була в контакті, він проявляв любов, а потім не проявляв.
І такі були качелі.
Підсумок цієї історії, анорексія в неї, вага 42 кілограми, майже на грані смерті.
І дуже важко було будувати ці контакти з іншими людьми.
Отак, що робити з цими людьми, навчити їх довіряти світу і менше контролювати і проповідувати.
Тобто розуміти, що є думки інших людей.
Як ви зараз цим? Нормально? Ще не всі спите?
Якісь свої історії сімей не згадали?
Ці історії, вони вам цікаві? Чи можна їх пропускати?
Такі нормальні, так, життєві? Добре.
Давайте переходимо до нашої цієї адаптації трудоволіків, що з ними робити.
Трудоголік. Риси. Сумлінний. Дуже багато робить ритуалів. Драйвери. Бути досконалим. Радуючих і старайся. Заборони. Не розважайся. Не відчувай. Не радій. Не будь близьким.
Далі рекати. Гнів. Тріумф. Провина. В неї дуже багато провини. Буває. Ігри. Скандал. Загнана домогосподарка. Ага. Попався сучий син і вада.
Сценарій, поки ні і тупік.
У мене немає планів.
Коли їм немає чим, що робити, то в них немає планів.
Їм важко придумати, як їм жити.
Коли вони до вас прийдуть в коучинг, вони не будуть знати, що робити далі, якщо не робити.
Вони не відпочивають.
А коли їздять на відпочинок, знаєте, я бачу таких трудоголіків, вони сидять і працюють з телефоном.
У мене ось моя коліжаночка скинула фотку своєї родини.
Вона лежить, він працює.
Бажання в них, знаєте яке, підсвідомо, бути визнаним,
щоб їх просто так любили.
Захисний механізм, вони переслідують,
переслідують людей, бо вони ж багато працюють,
і тому біля них багато жертв, які не хочуть працювати.
Хто там трудоголик? Що Настя?
А потім вони йдуть в терапію,
тому що вони, спасателі Малібу,
замахались всіх спасателі.
Просто.
Тому що всіх. Дай займі.
Ой, горе, допомоги, перевези.
Кошечка Тонін, бляд.
Тільки плащ одеваєш і побіжав.
Не всі йдуть в терапію.
Хтось змирає швидше, ніж піде в терапію.
Так, так, так.
Ну, бачиш, мене спасло.
П'ять років терапії, як бабка пошептала.
А в мене чоловік, трудоголік, а я була тою людиною, коли ми починали з ним стосунки, я була тією людиною, яка хотіла сісти на шиї і нічого не робити.
Слухайте, є погана новина. Хочете, скажу для трудоголіків, що погано?
От Василь сказав чесно і сказав відверто, вони перепрацьовують і вони вигорають, в них дуже багато інфарктів і інсультів.
і діагнозів, які останавливають, ну, самі не останавливають.
Чаще всего по себе можу сказати, ти не чуваєш усталость, ти не чувствуєш нічого.
І просто в пасний день ти не можеш відкрити брові, ти не можеш відкрити глаз,
тому що немає сил.
І ще було відкричене тело, тело відкричено, ти просто не чуствуєш.
Ну, поки не положат на операційний стол.
Ну такою буває, така жість, у них, к сожалению, один із видів віддіха – це попасть в больницю, к сожалению, не доводіть цих людей до больниці, слухайте, який приклад з практики, там жіночка одна вир
осла в родині, де батько її постійно критикував і постійно критикував її і її мама.
Батько був перфекціоністом, він постійно казав, що треба робити, а донька вирішила стати для свого батька ідеальною жінкою, бо мамка сиділа вдома, а батько її критикував, то вона почала багато працюв
ати.
І ще в неї був брат, який часто потрапляв в якісь історії погані, такі, не дуже класні.
То вона закріпила в себе оцей стан бути ідеальною, догодити татові.
І в дорослому житті вона весь час проводила свій вільній і невільній у роботі.
Її було дуже складно радіти, дуже складно жити своє життя.
Бачу, Настя, скажи.
Ну, мені, мені, мені, каже, що в мене другої була руха по поводу того, що мене просто, ну, в нашій семьі прийшлося кому-то стати дуже рано взрослым.
І взяти відповідальність за маму і, да.
І такий кейс, вот Настін кейс, да, коли папа, мама, або хтось там не работает, або папа ушел, або мама осталась одна, і мама впала в депресію, і у рівенка не було.
Це я, Насті, не знаю, це я фантазую.
Ну, просто пришлося взяти відповідальність, да, за себя.
Маму, і за того парня, і прохожа пішла.
Так, так, добре.
Ну, коротше, що треба робити?
Нічого не треба робити з цими людьми.
Їм треба дати можливість відпочивати.
Що робити? Нічого не робіть.
Відпочивати і нічого не робіть, щоб не хворіти.
Далі, наступне останнє – це оцей емпатік.
Емпатік. Дивимось на нього.
Реактивний, драматичний, залежний.
Драйвай радуй інших, старайся, будь цільним, будь досконалим.
Не рости, не будь важливим, не відчувай, що ти відчуваш, не виражай гнів відкрито, не будь собою.
Така сумна історія.
Що відбувається?
Під всім цим, під емпатією, є великий смуток.
Тобто вони радістю закривають смуток.
Є багато тривоги, є багато гніву подавленого.
і є депресивний стан.
Але це все виглядає
красиво, як отобу, знаєте,
бутерброд з ікрою, начебто зверху
оця радість, і вони такі
ха-ха, то-та-та, все
добре.
Ігри, пни мене,
ви чудові,
і сценарій після
імажа, тобто люди,
в яких немає такої відпочинку
і все, на потім, на потім.
Шо вас кажуть?
Ігри не понімаю, так прямо.
Дуже добре, люди дають багато радості, тому багато людей, яким вони дають радість, кажуть, ти поганець, вони б'ють по-протилежному, скажімо так.
Ні-ні-ні, ти даєш радість, вони кажуть, що ти мені дав? Знецінюють, розумієш? Тобто люди знецінюють.
то ця гра ви чудові ні ви чудові наприклад говорить людина ви чудові ви чудові ви чудові ви
чудові а ця людина ну вона хоче знаєш завоювати цю довіру оце і прив'язані зробити а ця людина
каже Боже мені твоя чудовість нахер мені твоя чудовість зовсім не потрібна на футболці є то
слово то не проблема ні а це дорослі люди не треба так казати я сьогодні бачу та втомилася вже після
вчора добре це зрозуміли люди добрі мої студенти Блін а ціль майже зараз догори і оце це прям і після
це прям про мене а при когось Василю що ми тут робимо ми про тебе говоримо сьогодні ти вже
сказав, що в тебе є емпатік,
то ми про тебе, центр уваги.
Ну, що робити? Бажання,
щоб його пестили і піклувалися
про нього. Ну, що робити?
Розплата його
відкидають. Бо, знаєте, люди,
вони не завжди цінують оцю радість,
яку дають іншим.
Це зрозуміло?
Що робити з цими
людьми? Давайте приклад наведу.
Жіночка росла
в сім'ї, де була
старша сестра, вона була молодшою.
Батько постійно звертав
увагу
на інших
жінок.
І звертав
увагу на цю маленьку доньку.
І мама
його ревнувала.
І ця маленька доня, вона отримала
багато уваги, коли тішила
тата. І коли була тихою
і приємною. Вона
любила вбиратися.
І мріяла про принця, слухайте.
але життя таке трошки інше, принців не буває,
то вона почала замість того, щоб вирішувати своє питання,
чекати, що хтось прийде і вирішить за нею все питання.
Її було важко у спілкуванні, де потрібно було будувати кар'єру
і брати на себе відповідальність.
От такі історії.
Як ви?
Ми вже головне майже закінчили.
Слуха она.
Ну, от эти эмпады с трудоголиками не прям переплетаются чуть-чуть.
Ну, так, есть немножко.
Мотив, потому что у меня и эмпад, и трудоголик, ну, по девятке, одинокий.
Ну, шо делать? Такая жизнь, знаете? Такая жизнь, такая жизнь.
Добре. Че все зразуміло зараз тут? Че якесь питання?
Слухай-то, давай-то, да, Настя.
У меня питання тоже лично.
Хорошо, трудовольник. Я кайфанула, не работать, ничего не делать.
Я все все распинать не можу в трудоголизм.
У меня страх уже, что я туда опять пойду.
То есть, если начинаю, да, все, у меня страх где-то в голове,
что я сейчас опять окунусь в этот трудоголизм, и все.
Идет опер от любого такого, сейчас, оргово-масштабного.
Мне понравилось отдыхать, короче, мне понравилось, ніхали не делала.
А, ти просто хотела сказати, що тебе подобається отдыхати, одобряю.
Спасибо, мне це перекос, кажуть, це просто перекос.
Баланс, він встановиться, ну, як то, чи все?
Или то, що там 30 років працювала без віддіху, тепер мені треба 15 років віддіхати.
Тепер не треба 30 місяців віддихати, щоб зновитися, я зрозуміла.
Так, так, я встала до смерті, як я говорю.
Так, добре, слухайте, давайте трошки покритикуємо цю модель і на цьому закінчимо.
Дивіться, модель прикольна, класна, але я думаю, якщо починати працювати, вона дуже заходить.
Якщо працювати глибинно, потрібно більш досконало вивчати такі стосункові моделі, є така історія, називається стосункові контакти, терапія, тобто тут дуже багато уваги діагностиці, як сьогодні Аня
казала, а що з цим робити, ну просто розуміти, що є така модель, вона занадто універсальна, вона не дуже така, знаєте,
Вона є глибока, але универсальна.
Її дуже прикольно використовувати у психіатрію,
її можна використовувати у спілкуванні.
І ця модель, чому її плюси, вона може знижувати нашу тривогу,
коли ми не знаємо, що робити.
Це важливо.
Що з мінусами, як я вам казала?
Тут немає оцього нартистичного, межового розладу, то воно сюди чогось не входить.
І тому це не означає, що таких проблем у житті людей немає.
Тобто, якщо підсумувати, це класні орієнтири, але це ніколи не замінить більш такий контакт,
більше питань, якщо щось йде не так, як треба.
Дивіться, нам потрібно для кожної з цих адаптацій допомогти зробити перерішення,
тобто сформувати ціль, на чому тримати увагу цьому клієнту.
Суть цього перерішення, вона є в тому, що людина розуміє своє стару поведінку,
старе рішення і приймає рішення діяти за новим стилем.
І це йому допоможе більш спокійно жити своє життя.
Тобто допомагати людям зрозуміти, що їм потрібно жити трошки по-іншому.
Для емпатика потрібно навчитися думати, думати і діяти.
Тобто ми починаємо з ними теплий контакт, допомагаємо їм прожити їхні почуття,
Допомагаємо їм пройти ці травми.
Я неважливий, я маю бути милим або добрим, щоб мене любили.
І дозволити їм бути недобрим, дивитися на себе, задовольняти свої почуття і думати самостійно.
Трудоголіком, і за того, що вони занадто концентровані, нам потрібно становити з ними чіткий контракт і допомогти їм трошки заспокоїтися у роботі так, щоб вони не відчували, що вони втратили контроль
над своїм життям.
для них робота то безпека тому їм потрібно поступово їх повернути до життя через дитячість
через ігри через спонтанність тобто в них нове рішення бути живим а не працювати
Алло, трудоголики, ви чуєте там?
А як вже з дитства обратно звернутися?
У мене чуть-чуть далі, чому Настя.
Вона тільки недавно випала з трудоголизма, а я вже давно, я вже застряла в другой, я вже наотдыхалась.
І я вот то, що ви говорите, що тревога піднімається за того, що я нічого не роблю,
у мене дійсно піднімається тревога, тому що, якщо я щось роблю і роблю,
Значит, це безпекає.
І зараз у мене, да, в обратну сторону, як повернутися.
Аня, треба поняти, по якому поводу поднимається тревога і її переработати.
Обычно під цей тревогою стоїть дуже глубоке понимання.
Для того, щоб я була ценной, я должна багато всього робити.
І тут дуже важливо пропечалити це, прогрустити це, пережити свій страх і розуміти,
що я ціна тільки тому, що я є, а не тому, що я виконала, як вул, 159 задач і роботу.
І поки є за що жити, спасибо багато, і я поки буду перерабатувати свої сторони,
свої процеси, свої страхи, свої тревоги, свої печати.
Хочеться включитися, але тут спротивлення йде, тому що страх опять встати в цю упрямку і забыти...
А коли ти розумієш, що ти цінна, тому що ти є, у тебе наступає баланс.
Уже не работаєш, як лошадь.
Ты пошла?
Да, це легко, Аня.
Це загружається флешка?
Да, це загружається флешка, дуже красива флешка, да?
Тобто треба задавати себе питання, якщо мені достатньо по состоянию на сьогодні?
Ні скільки у мене должно бути, щоб я умерла і лежала в красивому білому гробу?
Недостаточно мені ще.
Ну, що хочу, мені мало.
Мань, в цьому є жадність.
Я завжди кажу, що красиві, красивої білої гроби недостаточна
чи счастлива, радостна життя того, що у тебе є, з тим, що у тебе є.
Написано далі во многих религиозних трактатах, таких як Коран, Библия.
Счастлив тот, хто довольствується тим, що є.
І, к сожалению, у многих із нас довольствуються не малым,
це не подобається, а тим, що у нього є, і це є хорошим аспектом в трудоголізме.
Ось так.
Так що там треба загрузити? Просто те, що...
У мене всі достаточна. Денег раз є, за що піти сьогодні на йогу,
якщо я правильно увидела утром, чи на треніровку.
Ну, все, живем далі.
Коли не буде дінег, за що піти на йогу, чи на треніровку,
і не за що буде купити себе новий спортивний костюм,
можна виходити на роботу, це страх, це страх. Ладно, йдемо далі. Смотрите, дивіться далі, з пераноїдною адаптацією,
тобто в них дуже мало цього дитячого, їх потрібно повернути до дитячого також, і перерішення з ними відбувається
з пераноїдною адаптацією дуже повільно, дуже довго будете встановлювати контакт, і має бути контакт дуже сильний,
тоді вони можуть з вам довіряти.
Основна задача – це прожити їх почуття,
що вони були в нестабільній ситуації, особливо страх і біль.
Вони прийняли рішення «я можу жити, вижити тільки коли контролюю»
і довіряти небезпечно.
Тому нові рішення будуть формуватися відносно,
коли ви з ними будуєте довіру, і вони поступово будуть довіряти світові.
Далі, шизоїдна адаптація, коли їх потрібно активувати.
Тобто казати, не сиди, будь ласка, не чекай, доки до тебе хтось прийде,
давай потрошку проявляйся, потрошечку.
І їм потрібно дати зрозуміти, якщо вони не будуть проявляти самі перші контакти, вони будуть самотніми.
Бо вони думають, що зі мною щось не так, тому я не буду проявляти контакт.
І нові рішення тут дуже важливі дати їм право на існування і бути у контакті.
Пасивно-агресивна.
У них велике було розчарування, тому вони дають багато цього опору і потрібно з ними, трошки підтримуючи контакт, знижуючи цю напругу, поступово переводити до цих почуттів.
Вони думали, що їх не чують, то їм потрібно казати, я тебе чую, я тебе бачу, кажи мені відкрито про свої потреби.
Це дуже важливо для мене.
Антисоціальна адаптація.
Що з ними робити?
Робити з ними чіткі межі.
Тобто казати їм, де сьогодні, де ці межі.
Не купуватися на маніпуляцію, чесно з ними розмовляти.
і в них є великий страх, що вони нікому не потрібні,
давати їм зрозуміти, що вони дуже потрібні.
І тоді вони стають справжніми, чесними,
і вони починають бути без ігор.
Чи є якісь питання тут?
Шевця, зрозуміло.
Подскажіть, що це тест можна проходить вже в совершеннолетній?
Ну, типо подростки, діти, туди нет, да?
Я думаю, що можна дітям, якщо адаптировати вопрос немножко, там же ж он по-взрослому поставлен, да?
Ді, можна, можна.
Можна, можна.
Можна, мені, можна, діти можна понять, да, якщо ти їм німножко переведеш, вони все пройдуть.
Мої дорогі гені, ми з вами зробили велику роботу, дуже велику роботу, пройшли дуже багато сьогодні.
Ми з вами поговорили про те, як встановлювати контакти, поговорили про цю історію, як два чоловіки придумали.
Один придумав психіатричну історію, інший придумав польвар та бікаляр, він придумав більш красиві назви, поговорили з вами про відкриті двері, закриті двері, поговорили з вами про адаптацію, зробили
опис цих адаптацій, навіть покритикували ці моделі.
Як ви сьогодні, мої любі друзі?
Або, як завжди, після технічного аналізу втомлені, голова кипить, але оргазм був.
Це добре. Я люблю, коли є оргазм. Це дуже красиво. Я рада за вас. За усіх дуже рада.
Дивіться, мої любі друзі, в нас це останнє заняття.
Давайте з вами на цьому останньому занятті скажете мені, що вам сподобалось у моєму курсі.
Будь ласка, занотуйте мені або декілька слів, або одне речення.
Можна в чат написати, я почитаю зараз.
Можна слово сказати, але ліпше написати, бо мені я так зможу багато чого прочитати.
бо треба ж як нормальні дорослі люди прощатися
ми залишаємося з вами в прощанні в цих ролей
коли я ваша викладачка, а ви мої учні
і мені з вами було неймовірно цікаво, дуже круто
ви зі мною були майже рік, такий великий шлях
в мене було багато змін за цей рік, у вас було багато змін
і ви дуже змінилися, і я вам неімовірно пишався, я вже самою, вже самою, Настя, кажи.
Я хочу вас поблагодарити, тому що такий, скажімо так, грустний, грустний матеріал, на самом деле,
і дуже легко і просто, і без травматизиції, тако лагерно було, що осознання того, що це факт, і це є, і при прийнятии, с вами проходит дуже лагерно, принятие того, що є фактом, дуже благодарна, і кур
с був действительно дуже насыщений, і він легко подавался.
Дякую! Послухайте, це життя. У кожного з нас є свої травми. В цьому нічого не страшного. Ми з цим справились. Тому живемо далі. Счастливого життя. Василю, я тобі слухаю.
Правильно. Я розумію, що краще текст, а не кружечок, так?
Ні, тут можна щось написати. Ну, Василю, напиши або скажи.
Питання думаю, чи воно десь далі мити, то я готовий кружечком відгук, і пішло-поїхало.
Я наоборот для більше. Питань нема, все, почу.
Приємно почути вас, я ж з вами прощаюся, я ж також хочу, як доросла жінка, попрощатися,
сказати вам, що ви для мене важливі.
Окей, супер. А в мене ще одне питання, коротеньке.
Ми маємо цих шість, скільки типів, так?
Чи є для кожного з цих типів лікувальні вправи на щодень?
Що я маю на увазі?
От мені особисто зайшов щоденник вдячності, щоденник перемог.
Тобто, чи є десь підібрані вправи під кожен тип,
якщо їм дати на кожен день, от там одному,
ти показати, не помню хто, що я тебе чую,
оцю мантру давати.
Тобто, чи є щось таке, чи треба самому вже дати чаду GPT дано,
і він щоб перетворив, щоб швидше було?
Дивись, Василю, там є головна мета, на чому тобі потрібно тримати увагу.
Головна рекомендація.
Наприклад, якщо ми беремо цього емпатіка,
ми, коли з ним спілкуємося, ми його гальмуємо і кажемо досить драматизму.
І це головний напрямок твоєї роботи.
Це не вправа, бо одну вправу ти зробиш щоденник вдячності,
а тобі потрібно робити корекцію з дня в день.
Гальмуй емоції і роби.
Знаєш, це і є твій щоденник вдячності для цієї людини,
бо тут більше буде працювати,
тому що це була проблема у стосунках з батьками.
Зробити інший, стати іншим батьком для них.
розумієш тобто задовольнити їх потребу от так дуже-дуже так добре олін слухає олі олі оліна оліна
не слышит ань слухаю я хотела поблагодарить прекрасно курс транзактного анализа і
Сказала, це така некая психотерапія самого для себе.
Очень доступна, очень легко.
Благодарю вас за все ваши ответы.
Мне очень понравилось то, что вы приводите примеры из жизни,
а не просто сухой текст и теория.
То есть там, где ты можеш примерять, скажем так, на себя это всё,
либо на своих близких.
і ще одна можливість познатися бачити.
Тому благодарю вас за ваш курс, було приємно звичати.
Так, з радістю.
Так, Алін, ти нас слухаєш?
Алін?
Так, так.
Давай, скажи.
Я постараюсь в двох словах.
Скажу, мене транзактний аналіз в раз.
частину, бо того, що
дуже чітко, дуже структурно, дуже
зрозуміло, прям
усі схеми
ну ясно що ми спочатку відслідковуємо на собі і вже далі в роботі їх вже видно вже ну я там
майже всі знають що я пробувала іти далі з вами да я просто здалася бо я не справилась з таким
великим об'ємом навчань але я думаю що якщо якщо я таке виросту до того що я захочу стати
психотерапевтом то завдяки тому що ви привели любов до транзактного аналізу Влада я з вами піду
далі але зараз ну просто реально втомилася від просто від всіх навчань у мене ще паралельно
ще кілька є я вам дуже дякую ви неймовірна знаєте така чарівна жінка яка от ви точно той
якір транзактного аналізу для мене тобто от де говориться про транзактний аналіз у мене от
Заразу ваш образ. І дякую вам за вас, за те, що ви так розвиваєтесь, так вникаєте і проживаєте усе те, що ви нам даєте. Безмежно, вдячна. І надіюсь, до скорої зустрічі.
До скорої. Як же, мої двері завжди відкриті. Відкриті.
Дякую.
Так. Лєр, кажи.
Я також приєднуюсь до всього, що було сказано попередньо. Неймовірно цікавий курс. І от ви сказали, та, що найбільше там вразило. Я не можу виділити щось одне, тому що кожна зустріч, вона розкривала
і транзактний аналіз, і вас, як викладача, все більше, і більше, і більше.
І воно нашаровується, і мені дуже подобається, з якою легкістю ми пройшли цей шлях.
Бо я сьогодні ділилась десь в групі, коли ми працювали, що я думала транзактний аналіз, якщо згадувати Берна і його книги,
це щось просто таке складне, що треба, щоб мозок вибухнув.
Легко, така легка подача, енергія і оцей драйв, де ти вивчаєш щось, не штудуючи інформацію безкінечно, а воно легко запам'ятовується.
Такі життєві приклади прості і в той же час те, що ти можеш приміряти на себе.
Це неймовірно вдячна, бо незважаючи на те, наскільки складно іноді буває щось швидко з себе витягати,
це все одно якось заворожує.
Всі модулі проходили з величезним зануренням і залученістю. Дуже дякую.
А знаєте чому?
Бо ви мої перші, ви мої генії.
Всі в мене генії, але перші, вони особливі.
Це знають діти, вони так говорять.
Ми знаємо.
Дайте я тут прочитаю зараз, я хочу прочитати, мені ж приємно.
Дайте послухаю.
Так, трошки сумно, мені дуже сумно, що це останнє заняття.
Далі. Дякую, Влада, за ви закохуєте, зачаровуєте за те, як доступно ви викладаєте.
Дуже складні теми. Дякую, Юля Кравчук.
Очень понравилась доступность донесення інформації.
Сложная інформація? Ну, просто.
Ой, это моя кисть. Спасибо большое. Мені приятно.
Наташ, я вижу, я сейчас прочитаю, скажу.
Олена. Пішла гуляти з собакою, але закохала в ТА. Це дуже класно.
Лера. Так, ми не слышали нашу Алину.
Транзактний аналіз Маша написала. Моя любов і я також в серці. Маша, це навзаєм.
І складні речі так просто писнете. Все забираю, що можу унести. Беріть мене, будь ласка, в кармашку до себе.
Нехай я з вами залишуся. Знаєте, хочете в кармашку таке покладіть, я з вами буду ходити на всі ваші там сесії.
Забираю. Забираю, задоволені.
Даруй себе в кармашку. Дякую за неймовірний досвід, подачі, не завжди моє середенько.
Більше сподобалися базові драйвери, сценарії, емоції, і ви неймовірні.
Я так буду за вами сумувати, я ж буду за вами усіма сумувати.
Ульяна написала «З вами, да, да, любов, глыбок, учасно дуже свідомлено, да, ці також це дуже класно, Ульяна, раді тиму».
Оля написала «Влада, я в восторге, благодаря моїй харизме і стилю преподавання».
Правда, училась этому стилю преподавання. Говорять слишком, послушайте, хотите, я вам расскажу.
С точки зрения образования, моїй стиль преподавання крайне демократичний.
Як Юра сьогодні сказала, а ви не ходите по кабінетам?
Нет, я не хожу, Юра.
І мене за це ніякі колеги можуть преследувати,
тому що вони считають, що я дуже демократична.
Але я відкриваю вам секрет.
Коли я вважаю людей, я думаю, що вони як різні.
І я завжди сажу в благодатну почву.
І у мене не от цього, як у багатьох преподавателів,
Которые стоят над своими растениями
Говорят, ты вырос сегодня
Ты роботу сделал
А ну расти скорее
Я считаю, что
Если быть рядом
Любить, поливать
То все будет хорошо
Все вырастут
Тому я дуже рада, що ви земно
Я вас дуже божню
Слухай-то, Даля
Дякую відсову серця
И рада, що я вас
Раскрываю також
Наталя, дякую за курс, за подачу, дякую за все.
Рада, що це ваш улюблений предмет.
Мені приємно, по-чесному скажу.
Наталя, приємно, що ви закохалися в цей ТА,
бо я думала, що в нього люди не закохаються, знаєте?
І коли запитували, у нас вже була така співбесіда,
що брати, ми зараз вирішуємо КПТ чи ТА
і взяли транзакційний аналіз.
Це круто, завдяки цьому я з вами зустрілася.
Катя написала, любимий предмет, все супер, моя енергія волшебна.
Спасибо, спасибо всем.
Таня, Влада, дуже вдячна за ваш курс, закохала в ТАУ, приємно.
Влада, дякую, влюбили в ТАУ, тоже приємно.
Це треба моїм колегам, давайте напишемо моїм колегам.
Давайте колегам зараз напишемо, що вони там лоснуть від заздрочів, дівчата.
Ви слухайте, я вам чесно скажу, якщо ви скажете, що я вас всіх закохала, це буде в мене знову нова волна хейту, як завжди.
Ну, така любовна, знаєте, транзакційна.
Так, дуже дякую за любов, кайфово були, що ви з нами, глибина, неймовірні дячність, подяка.
Так, кайфово, що мене замотивувало зробити ще багато матеріалу.
О, Юра, ну ти взагалі генія, генія, Юра, сьогодні от сердечко тобі круто зробив, молодець.
Робимо спільне фото, робимо, зараз дайте дослухаю Наталю, бо вона руку тримала, дайте дослухаю,
зробимо спільне фото і підемо. Наталь, кажи.
Я просто хотіла, я зараз усвідомлюю, що якби в цьому курсі, ну, просто транзактний аналіз настільки доповнює основну картину
і дає можливість відштовхнутися,
щоб справді принести результат,
щоб людині дати можливість
прийти до її результату,
що це справді захоплює, що ваша подача,
ваша дорослість, те, наскільки ви
вмієте, ну, справді свій кейс,
чоботар з чоботами,
що дивишся на вас і розумієш,
що справді це все можливо, і от є куди прагнути.
Тому великі-великі дякую.
Ой, любіть, любіть.
Ріка Берна, класний, дуже класний
був психотерапевт.
Кать, кажи.
А я хочу вам сказати, що ви просто безумно красиві.
Ці гипнотичні глаза я не можу.
Я кожен раз, мені хочеться йти, я смотрю на вас,
і я набираюся цього не тільки знань,
але ще й...
Як-то я не знаю, ви свою душу так передаёте.
Чудесне чудо ваше душе, вот правда.
Я не завжди женщинами восхищаюсь.
Я бачу більше мусин смотрю, які вони там, а ось тут, правда, і енергія дуже заворажає, дуже.
Патя, рідна моя красота в глазах смотрящого.
Я вас благодарю. Я обязательно дойду к вам на личну консультацию, я вже коли-то писала.
Я буду рада, всегда буду рада, і красота в глазах смотрящого.
Якщо ми видимо друг друга такими красивими, і ми друг другу подобаємось, це тому, що у нас, знаєте, ми відкликаємося друг на друга.
Це важливо. Юра, говори, у нас фото, і ми уходимо.
Я згідно підтримую, сто відсотків. Мені неймовірно вражає ваша оця жіночність, оця божественна оця красота.
І з другого боку оця строгість і неприбуваємість характеру. Я просто аплодую стоючи, тому що я такого не бачу.
От, Еріка Берна мені рекомендувала ще з університету, я так до нього не дійшов, але ви мене знову надихнули і повернули на цю лінію, щоб перечитати його.
Все-таки перечитати. От, скільки я не пробував десь зачепити, тригернути і так далі, в мене цього не вийшло.
Я признаю свою поразку і кланяюся вашій стійкості, тому що в мене дуже рідко цього не виходить.
От, і тут не вийшло, того, як сказати, знімаю свої ці, коротше, низький поклін за вашу стійкість, оцю внутрішній стержень, скільки я різних підходів шукав, так і не знайшов.
От, того признаю вашу майстерність публічно. Браво!
Юра, це дуже велика похвила, дякую тобі, дуже дякую, мені було з тобою дуже весело, ти був тією людиною, з кожним було весело, але з тобою воно було просто весело, чесно, каже, бо я знаю, в мене такі
кейси часто приходять, такі антисоціальні, я знаю, що вони дивляться, думаю, от така блондінка, зараз я її чіпану, от це таке життя, так буває, але воно не завжди проходить.
Але я тобі дійсно, Юра, дуже дякую за те, що ти зробив, бомбісимо, бомбісимо, молодець.
Я усім рекомендую, використовуйте, але так тихенько, щоб тобі калір не знав, добре?
Давайте таке антисоціальне зробимо щось.
Зараз Маша щось каже, і ми робимо фото, ідемо, в нас вже одна минута, одна хвилиночка вашого часу.
Те, що всі почали говорити про вашу красу, я пам'ятаю перше нашу зустріч, тільки ми заходимо і я бачу вас, і я так одразу не вітаю, і кажу, боже, яка красива, боже, яка красива, ось, і оце було перше
, кохання з першого погляду по сьогоднішній день, я не знаю, а що, транзакційний може бути якийсь інакше, я ж не знаю, з чим порівнювати для мене це взагалі.
Я взяла це повністю своєю рульовою моделью і передаю дівчатам.
Забираю все, що можу унести, яке я писала вам. Дуже дякую.
І отак, і отак.
І отак, і отак, і отак.
Добре, мої хороші.
Давайте, у нас останні фото, хто робить, робіть.
Мільярди поцілунків.
Давайте я вам кожному по серцю.
Моє сердечко, давайте, отаке сердечко.
всі мої хорошіки я вас люблю я вас обіймаю завжди залишаюся у контакті пишіть поруч з вами
і бережіть себе давайте зростайте я буду слідкувати за вами у соцмережах
поки до зустрічі мої хороші до зустрічі
дякую дякую
фух на речі закінчить